ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
TODAY IS MONDAY MAY ELEVENTH
AND WE HAVE SOME. HOUSE KEEPING
WORK TO DEAL WITH FIRST BEFORE
WE'RE GONNA START THE HEARING
WE DON'T YET HAVE A QUORUM BUT
WE DO HAVE ENOUGH TO START AS A
SUB COMMITTEE SO WE WILL TRY TO
DO THAT. SO WELCOME. TO THE
FIRST SEVENTY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE IN TESE INTERESTING
TIMES. LIKE TO THANK ALL OF THE
STAFF HERE AT THE CAPITOL
EVERYONE WHO HAS. SET UP A- TO
KEEP US SAFE BUT ALLOW US TO
HEAR THE BILLS THAT WE NEED TO
BE HEARING IN ORDER TO KEEP OUR
BUSINESS MOVING DUE TO THE STAY
AT HOME ORDER WE'RE PRACTICING
A PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM AS WELL AS
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL SO THE
ONLY HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
SEATS AND WE HAVE DISTANCED
MEMBERS OUT. APPROPRIATELY AND
WE CAN ONLY HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN THE ACTUAL
HEARING ROOM HERE. AND SEATS
ARE DESIGNATED SO FOLKS CAN BE
APPROPRIATELY. SEPARATED I WILL
ALSO NOTE THAT FOR THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. SINCE THE
CUSTOM OF THE PRACTICE OF THE
HOUSES THAT PEOPLE BE PROPERLY
ATTIRED FOR OUR COMMITTEE
WEARING. A MASK IS ALSO. IS A
REQUIREMENT OFBEING PROPERLY
ATTIRED FOR OUR HEARINGS. SO IN
ORDER TO TESTIFY. THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM CAN TESTIFY HERE WE
ARE IN HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO
OH TWO AND WE'RE HOLDING
PHYSICALLY DISTANT BUT AN IN
PERSON HEARING ALL MEMBERS WILL
BE HERE AT IF THEY WANT TO VOTE
AND VOTING WE WILL DO BY ROLL
CALL IN THE NORMAL WHAT. WE IN
THIS SPACE WE CAN ONLY. HANDLE
OUR ELEVEN MEMBERS AND- A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC SO THAT WE CAN
MAINTAIN APPROPRIATE SOCIAL
DISTANCING. THERE'S ALSO STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITAL ITEMS ABOUT
THAT BUT THAT IS FOR
EVERYBODY'S. SAFETY IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN IN THE
ROOM TODAYWANTS TO TESTIFY ON
A BILL READ RAISE YOUR HAND I
WILL ASK YOU TO COME FORWARD TO
THE MICROPHONE. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I'LL TRY TO BE
VERY CLEAR ABOUT. WHAT WHERE WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS IN WHICH YOU
TESTIFYING TO DO TESTIMONY- WE
ARE ASKED TO ASK YOU TO NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU MAY
JUST SPEAK INTO THE MICROPHONE
BUT IT BUT PLEASE DO NOT TOUCH
IT AND THEN YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM WHEN YOU'RE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN YOUR SEATS.
ON HIS WILL BEING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE. WE DO ALSO HAVE A
WITH VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM
AND THAT'S FOR THE- THAT
MONITOR IS ON THE SIDE WALL IN
THE- WITNESSES WHO ARE GOING TO
APPEAR. ON THE SCREEN SO THAT
MEMBERS CAN WATCH THEIR
TESTIMONY THERE MAY BE SOME TO
LIFE FOR THAT STREAM FROM THE
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM
SO THAT ADDS TO SOME OF OUR
TIME SO PLEASE. BE PATIENT I'M
NOT ACTUALLY SURE WHICH WILL
THAT IS. FOR DIALING WITNESSES.
YOU'LL BE WE'RE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY PERSON CAN
CALL IN TO TESTIFY WE'RE STATE
THEIR POSITION ON A BILL. THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THE HEARING
TODAY IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
WITH AN ACCESS CODE OF. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO
YOU CAN FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
WEBSITE ASWELL AS IT SHOULD BE
ON YOUR TV SCREEN MAGICALLY NOW.
IF YOU PLAN ON LONG CALLING IF
YOU WANT TO TESTIFY IN A CALL
IN. PLEASE CALL IN AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON BEGINS THE
PRESENTATION. AND THE MODERATOR
WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON
THE. ON THE LINE ON HOW TO.
PARTICIPATE IN HOW TO MANAGE
THAT CALL YEAH IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE DO ELIMINATE
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE TURN OFF
YOUR THE SOUND ON YOUR-
ELECTRONIC DEVICES IF YOU ARE
WATCHING THE CAT THE- WEBCAST
OF THIS HEARING. ALSO PLEASE
TURN THE SOUND OFF ON THAT SO
WE DON'T GET A FEEDBACK LOOP.
AND THAT WILL MINIMIZE YOUR ANY
OF THE DISTORTION AND WHEN YOU
ARE NOT TALKING PLEASE ALSO
MUTE YOUR DEVICES SO THAT WE'RE
NOT GETTING THE- ANY OF THE
FEEDBACK. PLEASE BE ADVISED
THAT IF YOU'RE A MAIN WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR AGAINST
THE BILL HE CAN REMAIN ON A
LIVE LINE- BUT YOU'LL NEED TO
MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOUR CALL
TO SPEAK SO THAT'S THAT'S TRUE
FOR- ANYONE IF YOU'RE CALLING
IN IF YOU'RE HAVING PROBLEMS
WITH A MODERATE PHONE SERVICE.
CALL THE COMMITTEE.
916-319-2334 OF MY STAFF WILL
BE THERE TO HELP ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND GUIDE YOU THROUGH
HOW. ARE SAYS WORKS. I ALSO
WANT TO KNOW THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY.
THROUGH A POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON OUR COMMITTEES
WEBSITE ANY. TESTIMONY THAT
COMES IN THAT WAY OR ANY OTHER
WAY THAT YOU SAID IN THE
COMMITTEE WILL BECOME A PART OF
THE OFFICIAL RECORD. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE.
INSURING THAT WE ARE SAFE BUT
ALSO BE ABLE TO CONDUCT OUR
BUSINESS IN AND APPROPRIATE
MANNER. OKAY SO NOW LET'S
CONTINUE. WE'RE STILL LACKING A
QUORUM BUT WE WILL OPERATE AS A
SUB COMMITTEE SO LET US START
THROUGH OUR PROCESS WE WE'RE
GOING TO BE HEARING BILLS IN.
THE ORDER. IN THE FILE ORDER
ESSENTIALLY BUTWERE ASKING
MEMBERS TO SHOW UP AND WE HEAR
ALL OF THE BILLS FOR THE
MEMBERS WERE STARTING OFF WITH
MISS WICKS. AND WE'RE GONNA
START OFF WITH AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTY SIX SO THIS IS THE
APPROPRIATE TIME OPERATOR YOU
CAN OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR AB
TWENTY NINE THIRTY SIX ANYONE
WANTING TO TESTIFY. YOU MAY DO
SO AT THAT POINT RIGHT MS WICKS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY SIX IS A
SIMPLE BILL THAT WILL CODIFY
THE TERMS DONOR ADVISED FUNDS
OR DEATHS. AND SPONSORING
ORGANIZATIONS AND ALLOW THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO ESTABLISH A
CLASSIFICATION FOR SPONSORING
ORGANIZATIONS THAT MAINTAIN ONE
OR MORE DEATHS. STAFFS ALLOWED
IT ESTABLISH AN ACCOUNT TO
WHICH THAT INDIVIDUAL CAN MAKE
A TAX DEDUCTIBLE CONTRIBUTION
TO A TERRIBLE SPONSORING
ORGANIZATION. THE DONOR THAN
RECOMMENCE GRANTS FROM HIS OR
HER FUND OTHER CHARITY CHURCH
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
DIRECT BENEFITS THROUGH
COMMUNITY SERVICE PROGRAMS OR
ADVOCACY. NATIONALLY DAFT HOLD
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TEN BILLION
DOLLARS AND DONATED TERRIBLE
ASSETS. OF WHICH ABOUT
SEVENTEEN BILLION IS HELD IN
DEATH SPONSORING ORGANIZATIONS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. THESE
TERRIBLE DEDUCTIONS ACOSTA ST
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
CONSERVATIVELY. FOR THEIR MONEY
STOCK OR OTHER ASSETS THAT A
DONOR CAN DONORS CONTRIBUTE TO
THEIR DEATHS. HOWEVER THESE
FUNDS CONCERT INDEFINITELY
WITHOUT PROVIDING ANY PUBLIC
CHARTER WILL BENEFIT THE PUBLIC
POLICY CONVERSATION ON DEATHS
IS CRITICAL BECAUSE THEY ARE A
PHILANTHROPIC TOOLS THAT IS
THAT ARE GROWING IN POPULARITY
AND THAT A LOT OF COMMUNITY
FOUNDATIONS AND THEIR
COMMERCIAL COUNTERPARTS ARE
CURRENTLY USING TO FUND GOOD
WORK. FOR EXAMPLE THEIR NUMBER
OF COPA NINETEEN REALLY FUNDS
THAT HAVE BEEN SET UP AS STAFF
TO HELP PROVIDE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
BUT AS I MENTIONED MONEY
CONCERT IN TAOS INDEFINITELY
AND NOTHING IN STATURE REQUIRES
THE FUNDS TO BE DISPERSED
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES SPONSORING
ORGANIZATIONS TO REPORT THEY'RE
GIVING. BUT THE AGGREGATED
TOTALS REPORT DO NOT TRANSLATE
INTO ACCOUNTABILITY FOR EACH
TAX DEDUCTION THAT TAKES MONEY
OUT OF THE CALIFORNIA GENERAL
FUND. HOWEVER THE OVERALL
EFFICACY. OF CALIFORNIA TRIP
ORGANIZATIONS ACCOUNTABILITY
SYSTEM IS A LARGER POLICY
QUESTION THAT AB TWENTY AND
THIRTY SIX DOES NOT PRESUME TO
ANSWER. THIS BILL SIMPLY HAD
INFORMATION ABOUT AFTER THE
GOVERNMENT CODE TELL WAS DELISH
BASELINE. BASELINE FROM WHICH
TO START ENGAGING ON ON THE
AFTER MENTIONED BROADER POLICY
CONVERSATION. I HAVE MY
WITNESSES SELF INTRODUCED AND I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. I THANK YOU BEFORE WE
MOVE TO WITNESSES I WOULD LIKE
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE. STONE HERE.
GALLAGHER CHAU YEAH. TO YOUR-
GONZALEZ HOLDEN. KALRA KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE. RAY IS.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT WE HAVE CAT TAYLOR
OF THE OFFICE OF CAT TAYLOR AND
WE HAVE TO AMEND PIPE FORMALLY
OF THE TIDES FOUNDATION SO THE
FIRST WITNESS. MISS TAYLOR. AND
THESE ARE ALL OF. GOING TO BE
TERRIBLE. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
STONE AND COMMITTEE MEMBER I AM
CAT K. LURK FOUNDER AND BOARD
CHAIR OF BENEFICIAL STATE BANK
AND IMPACT INVESTOR AND ACTIVE
DONOR ADVISED FUNDS HOLDER AND
PHILANTHROPIST WHO HAS TAKEN
THE GIVING PLEDGE WITH MY
HUSBAND TO GIVE AWAY THE
MAJORITY OF OUR WEALTH DURING
OUR LIFETIME. YOUR TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AND ADDS A SPONSOR OF
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY SIX.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE COULD BUILD
SIMPLY REQUIRED THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO ESTABLISH A
CLASSIFICATION FOR ORGANIZATION
WHO MAINTAIN DONOR ADVISED
FUNDS OR DATA. GAPS ARE
CURRENTLY NOT DEFINED IN
CALIFORNIA STATUTE. PARTMINER
FINANCE LAST WEEK THANK
KNOWLEDGE THAT CALIFORNIA FACES
BILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT THAT
COULD PROMPT DEVASTATING CUTS
FOR SCHOOL HEALTH CARE AND
SAFETY NET PROGRAM.
UNEMPLOYMENT HAS APPROACH GREAT
DEPRESSION LEVEL WE FACE
POTENTIAL REFER TO THE VIRUS AT
THE STRATEGIC RE OPENING OF OUR
ECONOMY GETS UNDER WAY. THE
PANDEMIC IS PUTTING A
MICROSCOPE ON THE ROLE OF
PHILANTHROPY ATTY. WORDS OF
THIS BILL ARE A PART OF A
GROWING MOVEMENT TO HOLD THE
DONOR ADVISED FUND TOOL
ACCOUNTABLE AND TAXPAYERS WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT DAY AFTER
PRODUCING SOCIETAL BENEFIT THE
REFLECT THE SCALE OF NEED AND
THEREFORE. MERIT FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR OF
CALIFORNIA'S REVENUES FOR GONE
THROUGH CHARITABLE DEDUCTIONS
FOR GAP CONTRIBUTIONS.
NATIONWIDE THERE ARE AN
ESTIMATED ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS HELD IN
DOUBT. THE VAST MORE MAJORITY
OF WHICH IT IDLE WHILE PEOPLE
STRUGGLE TO OBTAIN BASIC
SERVICES LIKE FOOD AND HEALTH
CARE. THE FIDELITY CHARITABLE
GIFT FUND THE NATION'S LARGEST
THAT MONSTER AND LARGEST QUOTE
CHARITY PROBABLY HIGHLIGHT
READING POINTED TO THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS TOWARD COVERT
NINETEEN RESPONSE. COMMENDABLE
BUT ACCOUNT FOR ONLY THREE
QUARTERS OF 1% OF THEIR THIRTY
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN TOTAL
THAT ACT THAT. BLACK YOUR
FIDELITY TERRIBLE MADE AN
ESTIMATED ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN PROFITS ADAPT UNDER
THEIR MANAGEMENT. FINANCIAL
STRUCTURE PASSED INCENTIVIZE
ORGANIZATIONS TO KEEP
SIGNIFICANT ASSETS UNDER
MANAGEMENT IN ORDER TO EARN
MORE IN MANAGEMENT FEES NOT TO
GET DOLLARS OUT THE DOOR TO
NONPROFIT PROVIDING IT WILL
BENEFIT FROM THE GROUND. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTABILITY OFFICE SUPPORTED
LAST WEEK THAT THE OPENING
NATURE OF STAFF REPORTING. OUT
FOR ME. VIEW. THAT DOOR
MAGICALLY. CALIFORNIA SURE THAT
THE DOOR THEIR LEVERAGE THE
PROGRAM LEAGUE AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTY SIX TAKE MALIK STEP BUT
A CRITICAL IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION I HOW ASK YOU TO THE
THIS MODEST BUT- ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE. MISTER
DRUMMOND PIE. HM STONE AND THEN
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS DRUM AND PIKE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX I FOUNDED THE TIDES
FOUNDATION AND SERVED AS ITS
CEO FOR THIRTY FIVE LONG YEARS-
HAVING SOME OF THE WONDERS OF
THE HONORED BY FUNDS- CAN
CREATE AND SOME OF THE ABUSES
TO WHICH SOME HAVE PUT THEM.
NONPROFITS OPERATE WITHIN
CATEGORIES ESTABLISHED IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE TAX REFORM
ACT THAT DISTINGUISH BETWEEN
PRIVATE FOUNDATIONS AND PUBLIC
CHARITIES THE PRIMARY FACTORS
SEPARATING THE TWO WITH THE
DEGREE OF DONOR CONTROL OVER
THE ASSETS AND DISTRIBUTIONS
PRIVATE FOUNDATIONS ARE
CHARITIES WERE THE DONOR
RETAINS CONTROL THEY ARE MORE
CLOSELY REGULATED IN GRANTED
SMALLER LEVELS OF DEDUCTION.
IMPORTANTLY THEY ARE REQUIRED
TO MAKE ANNUAL DESCRIPTIONS
ROUGHLY 5% OF THEIR ASSETS.
PUBLIC CHARITIES ARE THE OTHER
HAND SEEM TO BE GOVERNED BY A
BROADLY REPRESENTATIVE BOARD
AND DEMONSTRABLY HAD
DEMONSTRABLY LARGE NUMBERS OF
DONORS THIS WAS TRU OF MOST
OPERATING CHARITIES AND
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AT THE
TIME. BECAUSE DONORS RELINQUISH
CONTROL THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS
WERE AFFORDED HIGHER
DEDUCTIBILITY AND MORE LATITUDE
IN THE USE OF FUN. PUBLIC
CHARITIES ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
MAKE DISTRIBUTIONS AND ONLY
REPORT ON SUCH IN AGGREGATE. IN
PRACTICE. AS PRACTICES EVOLVED
OVER THE PAST FIFTY YEARS.
TELEVISED FUNDS HAVE SERVED AS
A WORKAROUND TO PROVIDE DONORS
WITH THE ADVANTAGES OF GIFTS TO
PUBLIC CHARITIES WHILE
EFFECTIVELY ALLOWING THEM TO
CONTROL GRANT MAKING AND
MANAGEMENT OF THE ASSETS. THEY
RECEIVE HIGHER DEDUCTIBILITY OF
THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS AND THE
AVOID GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT PRIVATE FOUNDATION STATUS
WOULD REQUIRE. AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTY SIX IS IMPORTANT FOR TWO
REASONS ONE IT WILL RAISE THE
VISIBILITY OF C. HINTON DAU S.
AND THEIR SPONSORS AND HOW THEY
OPERATE INTO SUCH REPORTING
COULD REVEAL WHETHER THE
CONDITION OF PUBLIC CHARITIES
THIS ARE EFFECTIVELY BEING MET.
AND WHETHER SOME NUMBER OF
DONOR ADVISED FUND SIMPLY DO
NOT MAKE ANY GRANTS AT ALL FOR.
YEARS WE KNOW THE ACCOUNTING IS
DONE BY SPONSORS THAT IS. DON'T
NOT FOR THEM THE REVISED CAN BE
VERY POSITIVE THING BUT HAVE
SEEN THE CAN ALSO MINUTES THE
SKIRT PUBLIC PURPOSE THAT
JUSTIFIES THE PUBLIC INVESTMENT
OF LOS TAX REVENUE FOR THAT'S
WHAT IT REALLY IS. MORE
VISIBILITY WILL ALLOW THE
PUBLIC TO FULLY EVALUATE THE
COST BENEFIT OF THAT DONOR
ADVISED FUND INVESTMENT THANK
YOU. I THANK YOU. SO IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO OFFER TESTIMONY SUPPORT
THE BILL. RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE LINE WHO WISH TO
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES AND STATE
THEIR POSITION. ON THE BILL. IF
YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. JUST ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE GATHER
THE INFORMATION FROM THE FIRST
LINE.
OKAY. SO WE'RE WAITING
FOR THE RIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN LINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE CARD IN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ADVOCATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GEN MAX OKAY I'M THE CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFIT TIME HERE TO SPEAK
VERY STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY NINE THIRTY SIX THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JIM LIGHTS WITH
VANGUARD CHARITABLE WE DO NOT
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL
TODAY WE DID SEND IN A LETTER
TO THE COMMITTEE HIGHLIGHTED
VARIOUS DATA POINT BUT WANTED
TO HIGHLIGHT JUST ONE AND THAT
IS FROM FEBRUARY TO APRIL
THIRTIETH OF THIS YEAR GIVING
FROM JACK VANGUARD CHARITABLE
IS UP ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
PERCENT. SO MORE THAN DOUBLE
DURING THIS CRISIS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. WOULD
ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO STATE THEIR
TWENTY NINE THIRTY SIX. AND IF
I PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR KAREN NUMBERS DIFFERENTLY
ENTRAPMENT REPRESENTING NEXT
GEN CALIFORNIA AT COKE SPONSOR
OF THIS LEGISLATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE. THE TIME WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU SO NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
NINE THIRTY SIX WE HAVE JAMES
HEAD FROM THE EAST BAY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION. ON THE
TELEPHONE MR HEAD. ONE EIGHT
AND YOU HAVE ME. YES. THANK
YOU- GERMAN STONE MY NAME IS
JAMES HEAD AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT CEO AT THE EAST BAY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AND I'M
ALSO BOARD CHAIR OF THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA NEEDED FOUNDATION.
THE LEAGUE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THE BILLBECAUSE THE THING THE
THING UP OUT DON ADVICE ON SOME
OTHER GIVING WHO'S BUT JUST
PRIVATE FOUNDATION. AND OUT
MEANT AND TERRIBLE TRUST. IN A
WAY THAT WILL HAVE A CHILLING
EFFECT ON COMMUNITY-
PHILANTHROPY AT THE SAME MOMENT
IT IS MOST NEEDED BY SOUTH OF
THE NONPROFIT ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WE'LL GET THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
NEW WITH ALREADY TO REGULATE
THAT. AND DOES NOT LIMIT WHAT
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THE
EIGHTY CHEMICAL MEANT WILD WITH
THAT NEW AUTHORITY. FOR EXAMPLE
THE BILL PERMITS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO ISSUE
CLASSIFICATIONS BUT TRY.
ANOTHER RELATIONSHIPS
CONCERNING PROPERTY HELP A
PURPOSE. BUT ALTHOUGH NATURE OF
ASSETS DURATION OF THE TRUST
THE OTHER RELATIONSHIPS. AMOUNT
OF AT THAT AMOUNT WOULD BE
DEVOTED TO CHARITABLE PURPOSE%
AND OTHERS. AND WE FEEL THAT
THIS WILL HAVE A CHILLING
EFFECT BOTH PHONE DWN AS WELL
IN THAT TO CREATE. ON A FIVE
FUNDING CALIFORNIA. BUT BUILT
UPON HAVE NOT MADE AN EVIDENCE
THEY HATE THAT THERE THE
PROBLEM TO BE FIXED. AT THE AT
THE BAY ASSET THAT THEY- THAT
INDICATE THAT THAT THERE'S A
NEED BUT A ADDITIONAL GRANT
THINKING FROM DON AT FIVE FIVE.
I'D LIKE TO JUST SHARE WITH YOU
WHAT- DONNA BY PLAINTIFF DONE
ESPECIALLY IN THAT MISSION UP
BUT COLBERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
AS AN EXAMPLE. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN PAYOUT RATES BUT ON IT
BY FUNDS HOPE THAT BY THE
MEMBERS HAVE IT'S MORE THAN
FIVE TIMES HIGHER THAN THE
MANDATE IT PAID OUT. OF PRIVATE
FOUNDATIONS. AND WE HAVE SEEN
THAT THAT THE BUT THE ONLY
RATHER THAN THE FLOOR. BY APRIL
THIRTIETH COBRA RELIEF FUND
HOSTED BY THE NUMBER OF RATE
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AFFORDABLE
MILLION DOLLARS. MORE THAN A
QUARTER OF THAT DIRECTED BUT
DON IT BY SPOT. AND I'VE
ALREADY DEPLOYED OVER 40% OF
BOTH FIND THE NONPROFIT-
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED GRANT.
EVERYTHING OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. DONE ADVISED PLAN%
HOLDERS AT AT AT BIG MEMBER
FOUNDATION INCREASE THEIR THEIR
REGULAR GIVE ME BY BUT THIRTY
TWO PERCENT. AND MARK IN APRIL
OF THIS YEAR. AND YET THIS
MONTH MULTIPLE FUND HOLD IT AT
THE EAST BAY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION GRANTED OVER 90% OF
THAT DOWN IF I FIND THE
RESPONSE TO THE COLD BUT CRIED
THAT. OVERALL THE DONOR ADVISED
FUND GRANT MAKING THIS MARKET
APRIL FROM THAT YOU TAKE ME
FOUNDATION IT UP ALL COSTA
3100% OVER THE SAME PERIOD LAST
YEAR. THE LEAGUE BELIEVE THERE
IS A NEED FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO UNDERSTAND HOW DON'T ADVISE
BOND A CONTRIBUTING TO THE LAMP
BUT THE- AND TO SERVICE BUT THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR. HI BUT WE DO
NOT THINK THAT THE BILL THAT
THE WAY TO DO SO. WE THINK THAT
THERE COULD BE DONE AT THE BIO.
TECH TO MEET AND COLLABORATE
WITH THE NONPROFIT SECTOR TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO ADDRESS CRIME BECAUSE LIKE
HOPE IT NINETEEN. BUT WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE WILL BE
OTHER CRACKED WITH THAT AND-
AND PRACTICES WITHIN A
CALIFORNIA THAT WILL NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED. I WOULD THAT I'D
LIKE TO NOW I HAVE BY
COLLEAGUES IN THE CUT THEIR-
ALSO- SPEAK ABOUT. A CALIFORNIA
LEAVE OUT BASIS EXPERIENCE WITH
ON ADVISED BY. LINDA ALL RIGHT
BEFORE WE DO THAT I WANT TO
REMIND. PEOPLE WHO ARE ON THE
PHONE WHEN YOU'RE NOT SPEAKING
PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONE. SO THAT
WE DON'T GET ANY ADDITIONAL
FEEDBACK. ALL RIGHT WE DO HAVE
LINDA BEACH CUTLER. ALSO AS A
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION THIS
COLOR. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
AND THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
AND THE CHAIR OF MY NAME IS
LINDA CUTLER AND I AM THE CEO
OF THE SACRAMENTO REGION
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION. LEAGUE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT AIMS TO CARVE OUT A
SPECIAL CLASSIFICATION FOR
DONOR BY FUNDS TO SINGLE THEM
OUT FROM OTHER GIVING TOOL SH
AND THEREFORE THE BILL OPENS
THE DOOR TO ANY MANNER OF NEW
RECORDING BURDENS ON COMMUNITY
FOUNDATIONS IN THE FUTURE. THIS
WILL DISCOURAGE COMMUNITY
PHILANTHROPY AND ENCOURAGE
DONORS TO LAUNCH MORE PRIVATE
FOUNDATIONS WITH HIGHER
ADMINISTRATION ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS. AND LOWER PAY OUT RATE
AT THE SAME TIME THAT WE NEED
DOLLARS FLOWING INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES MAPS. I ANALYSIS
FOR THIS BILL. THE AG WE ARE.
HAVE FORTY TO ACCOMPLISH WHAT
THE BILL PROPOSED IT. IF THIS
IS THE CASE AND A TIME OF
FISCAL AUSTERITY WHY ADD
DUPLICATIVE AUTHORITY AND OPEN
THE DOOR TO A NEW REGULATORY
BURDEN ON COMMUNITY FOUNDATION.
A COMMON REFRAIN FROM THE
PROPONENTS OF THE BILL IS THAT
WE NEED NEW REGULATIONS TO MAKE
SURE. THAT GAPS ARE THAT MONEY
FROM DAFT ARE FLOWING TO THE
COMMUNITY AS THE BILL- ANALYSIS
ITSELF STATE MANY DONORS DO
DIRECT CHARITABLE CONTRIBUTIONS
FROM BASS TO CHARITY. SHORTLY
AFTER MAKING THE INITIAL
DONATION. THIS IS TRUE AND
NORMAL TIMES FOR EXAMPLE
SACRAMENTO ARE TYPICAL PAYOUT
RATES EXCEED FIFTY PERCENT. BUT
THIS IS MORE TRUE AND A CRISIS-
GRANT MAKING FROM OUR DONOR
ADVISED FUNDS IN SACRAMENTO WAS
62% HIGHER THIS MARKING APRIL.
COMPARED TO THE SAME TIME LAST
YEAR. AT THE AT THE PROJECT ME
FOUNDATION THAT BACK GAS GRANT
MAKING WAS THAT NINETY SIX
PERCENT. AND MONTEREY COUNTY
WAS A 194% SAN FRANCISCO WAS UP
210089% AND AS JAMES JUST
MENTIONED IN THE EAST BAY IT
WAS TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY NINE
PERCENT. IN ADDITION TO THE
DEATHS THAT HAVE COME OUT OF
SACRAMENTO AND- MARCH APRIL
ANOTHER MILLION AND GAS WERE
WERE MADE TO SUPPORT OUR ANNUAL
DAY OFGIVING LAST BIG DAY OF
GIVING LAST THURSDAY. WHICH
REYES NEARLY TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR SACRAMENTO AREA
NONPROFIT MORE THAN A 40%
INCREASE OVER LAST YEAR. THE
GENEROSITY OF OUR FUND HOLDERS
LAST WEEK IT'S JUST ONE MORE
EXAMPLE OF HOW FLEXIBLE AND
IMPACTFUL DON'T HURT BY FUNDS
ARE. BOTH IS GIVING TOOL FOR
OUR DONORS AND RESOURCES ARE.
NONPROFIT AS YOU. HAS SHOWN
THAT MY THE MOST HIS BILL
RESOURCE FOR NOW. DURING THE
FOR THREE REASONS THE DOWNEY
ARE MADE THE RELATIONS WITH NON
PROFITS ARE ALREADY BUILT AND
GAPS MAKE IT EASY AND FAST FOR
DONORS TO GATHER. AS WE LOOK
AHEAD TO THE NEXT WILD PARTIES
AND WE KNOW THE READY TO DEPLOY
RESOURCES AND DONOR ADVISED
FUNDS WILL ONCE AGAIN BE THE
PHILANTHROPIC LIFEBLOOD. SO OUR
HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES. BUT
MARKETS WE CONTINUE TO CATCH
THE STATION ON A TOOL USED BY
SO MANY GENEROUS CALIFORNIANS
FOR STRATEGIC LONG TERM GIVING
IN THEIR COMMUNITY. THE LEAGUE
AND ITS THIRTY NUMBER. NATIONS
SPPORT POLICIES THAT INCREASE
OPPORTUNITIES. AND PROSPERITY
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. THIS BILL
WILL DO THE OPPOSITE. AT A TIME
WHEN CHARITABLE GIVING IS MOST
NEEDED. WE RESPECTFULLY URGE A
NO VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NOW'S THE TIME FOR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES AND STATE THEIR
OPPOSITION. TO AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTY SIX IS THERE. ANYONE
HERE IN PERSON WHO WOULD LIKE
TO DO SO. ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO. IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND STATE YOUR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. WE
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. THE MOMENT
PLEASE ALL TOGETHER WITH
INFORMATION FROM THE FIRST LINE.
LINE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KEVIN ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE ON
THE AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
GIVE ANYBODY ELSE A MAN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO REGISTER
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTY SIX. RIGHT HEARING NONE
OPERATOR THANK YOU YOU MAY
CLOSE THE PHONE LINES FOR AB
TWENTY NINE THIRTY SIX- AND-
THAT WOULD BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THE BILL RIGHT WE DO HAVE A
MOTION IS THERE A SECOND. THANK
YOU ADD A SECOND THANK YOU MS
WORKS TO MAKE CLOTHES THANK YOU-VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
HERE AND I JUST WANT TO ADD-
THIS BILL- REQUIRES NO MANDATED
REPORTING AT ALL AND SO- IT'S A
LITTLE UNCLEAR TO ME HOW WOULD
BE A BURDEN OR A CHILLING
EFFECT ON GIVING AND OBVIOUSLY.
IN THE TIME OF COVERED NINETEEN
RIGHT NOW GIVING TO OUR NON
PROFITS IS REALLY REALLY
CRITICAL ON GIVEN THAT THE ROLE
IN OUR OUR COMMUNITIES- AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THAT MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. HI
GALLAGHER. WELL SHALL I. TWO
FIVE. TO BUY GONZALEZ HOLDEN
KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY. HIGHLY
NO MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE NO
OBERNOLTE NO IS. GALLAGHER
CALDERON. THE BILL HAS FIVE THE
GRAPE SO WE WILL PUT THAT BUILT
ON CALL. RIGHT WELL NOW MOVE TO
AB. THREE OH NINE TWO SO IF YOU
ARE ON THE PHONE AND WANT TO
WEIGH IN ON AB THREE OH NINE
TWO THAT WAS THE TIME TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU ARE CALLING IN.
SO YOU MAY OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR THREE OH NINE
TWO. IS WICKS THANK YOU CAN
MISTER CHAIRMAN PERSON UNDER
CURRENT LAW THE VAST MAJORITY
OF CASES CONDUCTED A START
CONNECTED TO DOCTOR HEAPS OF
PHYSICIAN EMPLOYED BY UCLA WHO
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED OVER TWO
HUNDRED WOMEN. IN THE COURSE OF
HIS THIRTY FIVE YEAR CAREER OUR
TIME BARRED BY THE STATUE OF
LIMITATIONS. LAST YEAR THREE A.
B. FIFTEEN TEN BY AS A MEMORY
AS THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
OPEN A BRIEF ONE YEAR WINDOW
AND THE STATUE OF LIMITATIONS
FOR PATIENTS WHO BEEN SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED BY FORMER
GYNECOLOGIST DR GEORGE. TO
DAHLE OF A U. S. C.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS CHANGE LAW
ONLY APPLIES TO PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS EXCLUDING PUBLIC
ENTITIES LIKE YOU STILL LIVE.
DR HEAT SURVIVORS DESERVE THE
SAME PROTECTION AFFORDED TO.
SURVIVORS TO OBTAIN CARE THREE
U. S. C. A. B. THIRTY NINETY TO
AFFORD THEM THAT PROTECTION BY
PROVIDING A PATH TO JUSTICE FOR
THOSE WHO ARE SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED BY DOCTOR HEAPS.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WOULD
TEMPORARILY RID RID REVIVE
CLAIMS. THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE
TIME ARRED UNDER UNDER THE
EXISTING SUCH LIMITATIONS FOR
ONE YEAR. CLAIMS SUCH AS SEXUAL
ASSAULT OR OTHER INAPPROPRIATE
CONTACT. COMMUNICATION OR
ACTIVITY OF A SEXUAL NATURE
COMMITTED BY A PHYSICIAN WILL
EMPLOYED BY MEDICAL CLINIC.
OWNED AND OPERATED BY UCLA
MAYBE RESTORED. AB THIRTY
NINETY TWO ALSO APPLIES TO
PHYSICIANS WHO WERE. ACTIVE IN
A HOSPITAL OWNED AND OPERATED
BY UCLA BETWEEN JANUARY FIRST
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE AND
JANUARY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. THE SURVIVORS HAVE
BEEN SUFFERING FOR YEARS AND
JUST WANT THEIR DAY IN COURT.
WE TO TELL. AMONG ALL TO WOMEN
WHO CAME FOR. IS JULIE A
WALLICH AND CARA CABLE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES LISTED TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT BOTH OF WHOM ARE ON THE-
ON THE PHONE THIS CABLE. HELLO
I WOULD TELL THE GOOD SECOND
TWENTY TO GO FIRST NOW THE
EITHER WAY IS FINE WITH ME AS
WELL ARE YOU. PREPARED TO GO.
I'M AVAILABLE CAN I BE HEARD
SURE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME TODAY MY NAME IS
JULIE WALLICH AND I'M SPEAKING%
IN FAVOR OF AB THIRTY NINETY
TWO. USING THE WORD HARM DUDE
MISLEADING. THE HARM TO DOCTOR
HE CAUSED ME AND HUNDREDS LIKE
ME IS PERMANENTLY ETCHED IN OUR
PSYCHES OUR BODIES AND OUR
SPIRITS. DOCTOR HE SEXUALLY
ABUSED ME IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT BUT THE HARM HE COST WAS
ON IN THE INTENTIONALLY AND
PHYSICALLY RIGHT NOW. AS I
SPEAK WITH ALL OF YOU. IN MARCH
OF NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT I WAS
REFERRED TO DOCTOR HEAT FOR A
POSSIBLE WE PROCEDURE. I
BELIEVE I COULD TRUST YOU UCLA
AND DOCTOR HEAPS TO PROPERLY
CARE FOR ME. THAT IS NOT AT ALL
WHAT HAPPENED. AFTER HE
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED ME USING HIS
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT BECAUSE SUCH
EXTREME PHYSICAL HARM TO ME.
THAT I COULD NOT HAVE THE
ORIGINAL CHILDBIRTH. HE STROKED
MY **** THE NIPPLE PRODUCTIVELY
TOLD ME I WAS CUTE AND WORKED
HIS HANDON THE INSIDE OF MY
ARMS WILL I WAS ON THE EXAM
TABLE. I HAD ONGOING FLASHBACKS
NIGHTMARES EPISODES OF CRYING
IN INTENSE ANGER AT NOT BEING
HEARD OR CARED FOR. AT THE VERY
AGENCIES THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO
PROTECT ME. IN JANUARY NINETEEN
NINETY NINE I FILED A COMPLAINT
WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA. DETAILING THE
SEXUAL ABUSE ADDITIONALLY AT
THAT TIME I CALLED UCLA'S CHEAP
SHOP ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS TO
DISCUSS WITH DOCTOR HE DID TO
ME. AND NEVER RECEIVED A RETURN
PHONE CALL. AND DOCTOR HE DOES
OFFICE I WAS LEFT ALONE WITH
HER DOCTOR DESPITE LEADING WITH
THE ASSISTANT TO PLEASE TELL
THE DOCTOR TO STOP POLLUTING
BECAUSE PATIENT. RATHER THAN
PROTECT ME SHE LAUGHED AND LEFT
THE ROOM WHEN I ASKED FOR HELP.
PEOPLE REFER TO ME AS A
SURVIVOR NOT A VICTIM. THAT
SOUNDS NICE AND I APPRECIATE
THEIR SENSITIVITY. BUT THE
TRUTH IS I AM A VICTIM OF
DOCTOR HE'D AND UCLA. NO AMOUNT
OF TIME OR HEALING WILL CHANGE
THAT FOR ME OR ANYONE ELSE.
THAT AB THIRTY NINETY TWO WILL
HELP STEER THE SHIP OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT VICTIMS GEORGE JEPSEN.
PASSING THE BILL COULD POSSIBLY
HE'LL AT LEAST SOME OF THE
DAMAGE THAT HAS BEEN DONE TO ME
AND OTHERS LIKE ME. BY GIVING
US CONFIDENCE THAT WE CAN BE
HEARD BELIEVED AND CARED FOR IN
THIS PROCESS. WHY IS IT THE USE
DOCTOR HEAT IS THAT THE RIGHT
TO A FAIR TRIAL BUT A VICTIM OF
CRIME IS IT. AB THIRTY NINETY
TWO WILL STOP ISSUE FOR MYSELF
AND WOMEN LIKE ME DESERVE TO BE
HEARD. NO MATTER WHEN WE
ENTERED. WHERE TO GET THE USE.
TRAUMA DOESN'T CARE ABOUT TIME.
TOM HASNO STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS SO NEITHER SHOULD
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL TRAUMA. THANK
YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
LISTENING TO MY TESTIMONY TODAY.
THANK YOU THIS CABLE. HELLO MY
NAME IS KAREN K. GONE AND I WAS
SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF AB THREE
THERE ARE NONE HERE. FIRST I
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING
YOU FOR WHAT YOU'RE DOING OUR
GREAT STATE COUNTRY. ON MARCH
TENTH TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN I
WOULD ACTUALLY THOUGHT THAT BY
DOCTOR ING HE THANK YOU HELLO.
I REPORTED THIS COMMENT
IMMEDIATELY TURNED OUR STATE
UCLA AND A FORMER NEW ZEALAND
COLLEGES. TEN DAYS LATER I
FOUND A THREE PAGE LETTER TO
UCLA THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
BOARD FORMING AN OF WHAT
TRANSPIRED. AT FORTY YEARS OLD
I WAS DIAGNOSED THE TRIPLE
NEGATIVE BREAST CANCER MICHAEL
ONE POSITIVE. THIS IS A RARE
FORM OF BREAST CANCER. IN THE
FOLLOWING TWO YEARS I WENT TO A
BILATERAL MASTECTOMY
CHEMOTHERAPY RADIATION REMOVAL
MY OVARY BUT YOU.
RECONSTRUCTION AND THIRTY FIVE
RADIATION TREATMENT. IT WITHIN
THE NEXT TO THE TERRIBLE TIMES
THAT I ENCOUNTERED GAVE YOU.
BECAUSE I WENT BACK A ONE
POSITIVE I HAVE A GREATER
CHANCE OF DEVELOPING OVARIAN
CANCER WELL. IT WAS CITED I
WOULD HAVE MY OVARIES THANK YOU
CAN. IN MY YOUTH DELAYED DOCTOR
HAD LIVED IN SANFORD YOUTH THE
LA RECOMMENDED DOCTOR JAMES. TO
PERFORM SURGERY. WHAT WITH THE
CODE COULD BE JUST CONTACT
APPOINTMENT TURNED INTO
HORRIFIC SEXUAL ASSAULT. THIS
ENCOUNTER LET ME IN HERE. IN
SHOCK. VERY MY DECISION FOR ME
LA WITH TO LET THEM KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED AND PREVENT IT FROM
HAPPENING TO SOMEONE OUT. YOU
DELAYED RESPONSE DATED APRIL
EIGHTEENTH TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN INCLUDED THE FOLLOWING
COMMENT. I'M SORRY YOU HAD SUCH
A NEGATIVE EXPERIENCE IF THE
CARD YOUTH THAT WITHOUT
ACTUALLY. THE LETTER WENT ON TO
TELL ME THAT THE EXECUTIVES AND
THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF OBSTETRICS
GYNECOLOGY HAD REVIEWED MY SON.
THANK FADED THEIR FINDINGS ARE
CONFIDENTIAL AND PROTECTING.
THE INSTITUTION I HAD ENGAGED.
THAT ONE AND THERE ARE THE
PERFECT YOU IT. I THINK THAT MY
PART NOTIFYING THEM. I THOUGHT
PRESS STOP LIKE I DIDN'T MATTER.
TO ADD INSULT TO INJURY I'VE
LEARNED THAT IF THE UNIVERSITY
WOULD HAVE ACTED PROPERLY I'M
PARK COMPLAINTS AGAINST DOCTORS
HE I WOULD HAVE NEVER MET THE
MAN. IT DIDN'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
OTHER VICTIMS WERE HURT BY
DOCTOR HE- WHEN I FOUND OUT I
WAS HEART BROKEN IF ONLY YOU
DALY HAD LOOKED INTO ON THE
SOMETHING ABOUT IT. I AM BEING
TOLD THAT YOU FEEL LIKE THIS I
STORY WITH THE COURT SIX YEARS
AGO THAT MY CURRENT. I LOOK TO
YOU FOR HELP. YOU WHY WE OPEN
THE WINDOWS ACTIVE ON THE
PATIENT FOR SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL
ABUSE YEAH THE- WE THANK A
SURVIVOR SEXUAL THAT YOU FEEL
LIKE YOU ARE ONLY HOPE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. I THANK YOU.
NOW IS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES AND STATE THEIR
SUPPORT OF AB THREE OH NINE TWO
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN PERSON
WHO WOULD LIKE TO DO SO. PLEASE
COME TO MY PHONE. REBECCA MARK
AS REPRESENTING THE CENTER FOR
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE HEARD
HERE PERSON. RIGHT SEEING NONE
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES WHO WOULD LIKE TO
IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND STATE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI THREE OH
NINE TWO. YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE GATHER
INFORMATION FROM THE FIRST LINE.
FIRST COMMENT COME FROM LINE
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JANUARY CARILLO BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE. COMMENT FROM
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR TURN
MEMBER JACQUI TURN ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS IN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY NINETY TWO
AND E THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR IMPORTANT WORK ON THIS
ISSUE AS IT CONTINUES SOME OF
THE WORK CONSUMER CARE A BIT
LAST YEAR WITH IF YOU FIFTEEN
TEN REYES. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE KNOW
REMOTE YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT TAKING
IT IS NOT. GO AHEAD. LOOK NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU. RIGHT THANK YOU SO
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION
AND WE HAVE NONE REGISTERED. TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE OPPOSITION.
FOR THREE OH NINE TWO. RIGHT
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO.
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION TO AB
THREE OH NINE TWO. I WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. NO COMMENT AT THE
TIME ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SO WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND SERVICE
TOGETHER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING FOR THIS
BILL. BECAUSE IT DIDN'T ZERO
SAN ON SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN
VERY CONCERNING TO ME OVER THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS WITH
LEGISLATION THAT WE HAVE PASS.
THAT SPECIFICALLY EXCLUDES
GOVERNMENT. FROM THESE
PROTECTIONS- AND IT WAS ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT CONCERN ME AS I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
WOULD INCLUDE BOTH PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC ENTITIES BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T MATTER. WHAT TYPE OF
ENTITY YOU ARE IF YOU ALLOW
THIS TO GO ON. THERE NEEDS TO
BE JUSTICE ASSOCIATED THERE
WITH. AND WE ACTUALLY SAW MANY
THINGS. THAT INVOLVE GOVERNMENT
YOU KNOW. PROBABLY MOST NOTABLY
MICHIGAN STATE AND WHAT THEY
DID TO OLYMPIANS AND WHAT THEY
ALLOWED TO BE DONE- TO
OLYMPIANS OVER YEARS AND YEARS-
WAS PUT ON A FULL VIEW FOR
EVERYONE SO I DON'T THINK WE
CAN CONTINUE TO GO ON I DON'T
THINK WE SHOULD HAVE IN THE
FIRST PLACE. GO ON EXCLUDING
GOVERNMENT FROM THESE
PROTECTIONS- WHEN ACTUALLY
GOVERNMENT IN MANY CASES HAS
BEEN ONE OF THE GROSSEST.
ABUSERS AND HAS TURN THE OTHER
WAY- IN MANY WAYS OF OVER THE
YEARS- HOLLYWOOD. YOU KNOW
BEING ONE OF THE MOST NOTABLE-
THE- FOR THESE TYPES OF
PRACTICES THAT ALLOWED THINGS
TO GO GO ON AND TURN A BLIND
EYE WE GIVE THEM A TAX CUT. OR
A TAX CREDIT A COUPLE YEARS
AGO- WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS JUSTICE ACROSS THE
BOARD THERE SHOULD BE AN
EXCLUSION. FOR A GROUP NOW A
LOT OF PEOPLE BRING UP WELL
IT'S GOING TO COST US MONEY.
WELL LAST I CHECKED JUSTICE
SHOULDN'T BE COMING WITH A
DOLLAR SIGN ON IT AS TO HOW
MUCH IT'S GOING TO COST YOU
IT'S EITHER JUST FOR ITS NOT.
AND IS NOT JUST TO ALLOW THE-
THESE GROUPS JUST BECAUSE
THEY'RE PUBLIC IN JUST BECAUSE
THE STATE MIGHT HAVE LIABILITY.
ALTHOUGH I THINK THE UC HAS AN
INSURANCE POLICY AND I THINK
VERY MUCH VERY MUCH OF. THESE
CLAIMS SHOULD COME OUT OF THEIR
BUDGETS AND THEIR INSURANCE
POLICIES BUT CERTAINLY THE
STATE DOES HAVE RISK BUT THAT
THAT COMES WITH OPERATING STATE
GOVERNMENTS AND WHEN PEOPLE
HAVE DONE WRONG AS IS VERY
CLEAR IN THIS CASE. IN THE CASE
OF UCLA AND I AND I DON'T KNOW
IT. THE OTHER CONCERN I WOULD
SAY IS RIGHT NOW ARE ONLY
FOCUSING ON ONE. AND MAYBE AS A
PRACTICAL MATTER THAT'S- YOU
KNOW WHY WE'RE FOCUSING ON UCLA
BUT I THINK EVERY PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY. THAT DID THESE KIND
OF THINGS WHEN THEY WERE
COMPLAINTS FILED INVESTIGATIONS
THAT WERE NOT SHARED WERE HEADS
WERE TURNED THE OTHER WAY AND
THEREBY VICTIMS- STATUES
LIMITATIONS PASSED. JUSTICE
REQUIRES THAT THEY FACE THAT
THAT THEY HAVE THE EXTENSION
AND THE ABILITY TO BRING THEIR
CLAIMS. THEIR RIGHTFUL CLAIMS.
AGAIN SEIZE ENTITIES AND JUST
BECAUSE OUR PUBLIC IT MIGHT
COST THE STATE MONEY. SHOULD
NOT BE A JUSTIFICATION TO STOP
THAT. AND SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY AND
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANTED TO
MAYBE SPEAK TO SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES. WELL AT MISTING X. BUT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
I CERTAINLY THINK- IN ANY TIME
IF SOMEONE'S IN A POSITION OF
POWER IN ABUSING THAT POWER THE
TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE. AND THE
VICTIMS OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES
NEED TO HAVE THEIR DAY IN
COURT- AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILLS ABOUT REGARDLESS OF WHO
THEY WORK FOR. I THANK YOU
MISTER. I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE TWO WITNESSES FOR COMING
FORWARD TODAY TO A TESTIFIED
MUST BE A VERY DIFFICULT FOR
YOU TO RELIEVE YOUR- TO A
TRAUMA SO I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL AS WELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THE KID OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
RIGHT SYNONYMOUS WITH TO MAKE
CLOTHES THANK YOU I THINK- MY
WITNESSES AND CAPS LATE THE
NEED FOR THIS BILL ON WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THAT MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
KALRA TAKES. MARK STONE HI.
STONE HI GALLAGHER. THE OLDER I
CHAU SHALL I TO- TO BUY AND
SALAS HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA AYE
KILEY KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
OBERNOLTE. RAY IS REYES I. IT
HAS SEVEN BUT RIGHT THE BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU AND NOW WILL MOVE
TO AB THIRTY TO SIXTY MINUTES
WORKS THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS WILL IF
ANYBODY WANTS TO CALL IN ON AB
THIRTY TO SIXTY THIS IS NOW
YOUR OPPORTUNITY. GREAT THANK
LAST PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURST. IN NEARLY ONE
IN FIVE CALIFORNIANS HAVE FILED
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT WITH MILLIONS
OF RESIDENTS WONDERING WHERE
THEIR NEXT PAYCHECK WILL COME
FROM. MYSTERY MISSED RENT
PAYMENTS ARE PILING UP AND
EVICTIONS ARE INEVITABLE ONCE
GOVERNOR NUISANCE EXECUTIVE
ORDER HALTING EVICTIONS.
FICTION PROCEEDINGS FOR NINETY
DAYS IS LIFTED. IN YOUR OWN
ANALYSIS ON PAGE FOUR THERE'S A
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE FACT THAT
WE MAY SEE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IF NOT
MILLIONS FACING EVICTIONS. AND
WHAT IS THAT GOING TO MEAN FOR
OUR TENANT COMMUNITY AND OUR
LAND LORD COMMUNITY. FOR
RENTERS TRAINING THEIR SAVINGS
ON ENVIRONMENTAL. FOR RENTERS
READING THEIR SAVINGS ON
EMERGENCY RELATED EXPENSES.
THERE WILL BE VERY LITTLE MONEY
LEFT. TO PAY UP FRONT COST TO
SECURE HOUSING. LIKE A SECURITY
DEPOSIT. EXISTING LAWS FOR
MIDDLE AND LOWER TO REQUIRE TWO
MONTHS RENT A SECURITY FOR AN
UNFURNISHED RENTAL PROPERTY. OR
THREE MONTHS RENT AS AS AS
SECURITY FOR FINISH RENTAL
PROPERTY. THE AVERAGE RENDON
OAKLAND IS THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. IF EXISTING LAW ALLOWS
WHEN THEY'RE TO CHARGE UP TO
THREE MONTHS' RENT A SECURITY
DEPOSIT. THIS MEANS A RENTER
COULD POTENTIALLY PAY UP TO
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN UP
FRONT COSTS. PRE PANDEMIC FORTY
THOUSAND. 40% OF AMERICANS NOT
HAVE MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN SAVINGS. WITH OVER
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
RESIDENTS UNEMPLOYED IT IS SAFE
TO ASSUME THAT TENANTS WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO AFFORD RENT. AND
EXHAUST WHATEVER'S LEFT THEIR
SAVINGS ALL SHELTER IN ORDER
PLACES ARE ENACTED. IN ORDER TO
DELIVER UP FRONT MOVE IN COST
RELIEF AB THIRTY TO SIXTY
REQUIRES LANDLORDS TO PROVIDE
TENANTS WITH THE CHOICE OF THE
ONE OF THE FOLLOWING. THEIR
SECURITY DEPOSIT IN FULL WHICH
IS THE CURRENT LAW. IN ONE
IMMEDIATE PAYMENT. THE SECOND
OPTION WOULD BE- SIX MONTHS SIX
PAYING OVER SIX MONTHLY
INSTALLMENTS UNLESS THE TERM OF
THE LEASE IS LESS THAN NINE
MONTHS IN WHICH CASE THE NUMBER
OF MONTHLY INSTALLMENTS WOULD
BE IN A WRITTEN AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE LANDLORD AND THE
TENANT OR PURCHASE SECURE
DEPOSIT INSURANCE OR ASSURE THE
BOND. THE BILL CREATES AN
OPPORTUNITY PROVIDE FINANCIAL
FLEXIBILITY AND ALTERNATIVES
INDIVIDUALS WELL FAMILIES. AND
FAMILY SWELLED NOT
DISADVANTAGING PROPERTY OWNERS.
AND I'VE SPOKEN WITH MANY OF
YOU ABOUT THIS BILL AND IT-
DAYS LEADING UP TO THIS
HEARING. INCLUDING
CONVERSATIONS WITH MISS REYES-
WHERE I HAVE AGREED TO WORK
WITH HER ON HOW WE ADDRESS-
MONTH TO MONTH LEASES BECAUSE I
DO THINK THAT'S A SEPARATE
CATEGORY- AND I'VE ALSO LOOKED
AT. DEEPLY THE COMMITTEE NOW
SAYS AND THERE ARE SOME.
LEARNINGS I THINK WE CAN TAKE
FROM THE STATE OF VIRGINIA IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEY'VE DONE-
WHICH I'LL BE EXPLORING THOSE
MOMENTS OF ALSO THIS IS VERY
MUCH STILL WORK IN PROGRESS
BILL. BUT IT'S A BILL THAT IS
INTENDED TO. ALLEVIATE SOME OF
THE FINANCIAL BURDEN THAT
RENTERS HAVE WILL STILL
PROTECTING LAMB OR TO THE SAME
TIME A GIVEN THE CRISIS THAT
WERE ABOUT TO BE FACED WITH.
AND I WOULD THE. I'M SORRY- SO
THE BILL SPONSORED BY
CALIFORNIA BE. A SORRY
SUPPORTED BY CALIFORNIA BE. THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. AND THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION. I'D ASK- LOUISE
CIMARRON DAY FROM CALIFORNIA BE
TESTIFYING ASKED SPECIFICALLY
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SO WE DO HAVE ONE WITNESS
IN SUPPORT MYSTERON SAY WHO'S
HERE IN PERSON. PLEASE ONE OF
THE MIKE PICKED ME UP. FROM
HERE YES OKAY. A GOOD MORNING-
THIS RICHARD THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY TO SUPPORT AB THIRTY SIX
THE MOTHER THE TREMENDOUS
CRISIS NUMBER SETTING THE STATE
WHEN I'M SURE IS AN IMMEDIATE
PRESSURE ON YOUR PERSONAL TIME.
MY NAME IS LOUIS MONTANA
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA BE- KEEPING MY
REMARKS BRIEF BUT WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. HOW
CALIFORNIA BE ADVOCATES FOR AN
END TO CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
CRISIS- ONE ROUND NOW RENDERED
IN STARK CLARITY BIKE OF THE
NINETEEN. SB THIRTY TO SIXTY
HELPS US ADVANCE OUR MISSION BY
GIVING FINANCING OPTION FOR A
COMPLY. WITH THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROVIDE A
DOWN PAYMENT. THE CIVIC WERE
MOST EXCITED ABOUT THE ON. TO
PAY FOR SECURITY DEPOSIT FOR
PAYMENT PLAN. AS PART OUT OVER
SIX MONTHS. CALIFORNIA LAW DOES
NOT REQUIRE THE IMMEDIATE
REPAYMENT OF A SECURITY DEPOSIT
AT THE END OF THE LEASE SO MANY
TENANTS ARE EXPECTED TO PAY FOR
THEIR NEW SECURITY DEPOSIT.
WELL THEIR PREVIOUS LANDLORD
HOLDS THE PREVIOUS DEPOSIT
INSURE THAT THE UNIT IS
RETURNED IN A CONDITION IN
WHICH IT WAS LEAST. THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW TENANTS TO USE
THEIR PREVIOUS DEPOSIT TO PAY
FOR SOME OF THEIR NEW DEPOSIT
WITH GREATER EASE. THROUGH THE
REPAYMENT PLAN. I CAN TELL YOU
THAT AMONG OUR STAFF INVOLVED.
THIS BILL IS A LIST OF
PARTICULAR EXCITEMENT ONE OF
OUR CURRENT STUFF MEMBERS
RECENT GRADUATE OF UC BERKELEY.
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS WILL
STAND THERE. TODAY HE IS ONE OF
OUR MOST VALUABLE TEAM MEMBERS.
BUT IN COLLEGE HE WAS ALMOST
UNABLE TO FIND HOUSING FOR A
LARGE PERIOD OF TIME. AND THEN
THE BALANCE IS FROM THE
PRESSURES OF STUDYING. WORKING
FULL TIME AND MOVING TO A NEW
AREA OF CALIFORNIA. WELL LIVING
ON THE COUCHES OF FRIENDS AND
IN THIS CAR. IN HIS OWN WORDS.
THE REASON WHY I WAS ALMOST IN
THE BAY AREA FOR SO LONG WAS
BECAUSE OF THE HIGH SECURITY
DEPOSITS. AND THE FIRST MONTH
RUN REQUIREMENT. FOR MOST FAIRY
APARTMENTS. THIS BILL HELPS
RELIEVE THE PRESSURE THAT MANY
IN CALIFORNIA. SUCH AS MY
COWORKER MOHAMMED FIXED. FOR
THAT REASON CALIFORNIA BE URGES
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TO
SIXTY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
WAS THERE ANYONE. ON THE PHONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
THEIR SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TO
SIXTY. TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN YOU'RE ON YOUR
PHONE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE ALL
GATHER INFORMATION FROM THE
FIRST LINE. THANK SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
TRYING TO GOT TO ON BEHALF OF
THEIR CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION OF
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MORE INCLINED TO
THE LEGAL AID ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA QUIRK. THANK YOU. AT
THE TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT CAN CUTE OKAY WILL THEN
MOVE TO OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE
RUN KINGS THAT HERE IN PERSON
TO. GIVE TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTY TO
SIXTY. BUT PLEASE. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AROUND KINGSTON I
REPRESENT- SERVER REGIONAL
APARTMENT ASSOCIATIONS IN THE
BAY AREA ORANGE COUNTY
RIVERSIDE AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA- AS WELL AS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MANAGEMENT-
SO SEE ASIANS WHICH ARE HAVE TO
CREDIT QUALIFIED AND HAVE VERY
LIMITED. TENANTS OF QUALIFY FOR
THAT TYPE OF HOUSING BECAUSE
IT'S ALL DEED RESTRICTED FOR
NUMEROUS DECADES WE'RE HERE TO
URGE- THE COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER
SOME OPTIONS. AND THE REASON
WHY WE SAY THAT IS THAT THE
OPTIONS ARE REALLY IMPORTANT WE
HAVE LOOKED AT EVERY- INSURER
IT PROVIDES THIS TYPE OF
INSURANCE. MOST OF THEM REQUIRE
ONEROUS BURDEN SOME CREDIT
QUALIFICATIONS WHICH WE DON'T
GENERALLY IMPOSE. ARE FOUR OF
THEM OF THE COMPANIES THAT
OPERATE IN CALIFORNIA DON'T
ALLOW YOU TO HAVE A BANKRUPTCY
AND AFFECTION REQUIRE YOU TO
HAVE RECENTLY HIGH CREDIT
SCORES- HAVE TO CREDIT QUALIFY
ON TWO POINT FIVE TIMES. FOR
INCOME TO THE RANK STRUCTURE WE
FIND THAT TO BE VERY VERY
PROBLEMATIC. SOME OF THE OTHER
INSURERS DON'T EVEN OPERATE IN
CALIFORNIA SURE THE BOND
COMPANIES THE SAME THING WE
SOME OF THE COMPANIES SAY YOU
HAVE TO HAVE AT LEAST A HUNDRED
UNITS OR ALL OF THE ENTIRE
BUILDING FOR THE US SO IN MANY
WAYS WE FIND THAT THE INSURERS
THAT OFFER THIS. HAVEN'T REALLY
ENTERED THE CALIFORNIA MARKET
REALISTICALLY AND WE WOULD
WORDS. CONSEQUENTLY WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE TYPE OF INSURANCE
TENANT INSURANCE IN THIS CASE.
THAT THIS PROGRAM TO BE MADE
OPTIONAL NOT MANDATORY AND WE
THANK THE AUTHORS OFFICE. TO
HAVE ENGAGED IN THAT TYPE OF
DISCUSSION. DOES THIS- DOES IT
OPTION BECAUSE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEEKS HAS SUGGESTED THEY LOOK
AT. THE OTHER PART WE WANT TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT IS WHAT
HAPPENS IF THE LANDLORD DOESN'T
FIND INSURANCE PLANS TO BE
ACCEPTABLE AS WE HAVE. OUTLINED
HERE THAT THEY- THAT THEY DO
ACCEPT TENANTS THAT HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED THEY DO ACCEPT TENETS
THAT HAVE RECENTLY BEEN- IN
DECLARE BANKRUPTCY THEY DO
ALLOW TENNIS TO HAVE- NOT AS
MUCH INCOME IS- SOME OTHERS.
THE OTHER OPTION OF COURSE IS
THE SIX MONTH PLAN IS THE
AUTHOR HAS SUGGESTED. THAT IS
PROVED TO BE VERY PROBLEMATIC
FOR US- THROUGHOUT. OUR%
CALIFORNIA HIM HERE'S ONE IS
BECAUSE- IF THE TENANT STOPS
PAYING THAT. AMOUNT THEN WE ARE
FACED WITH A VERY SMALL AMOUNT
OF SECURITY DEPOSIT SECOND MOST
IMPORTANTLY WHETHER. IT CAN
HURT THE LOW INCOME TENANTS TO
QUALIFY TO MOVE INTO AN
APARTMENT WHY IS BECAUSE IF THE
RENT IS FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
A MONTH. AT THE SECURITY
DEPOSIT- PAYMENT IS ANOTHER
THREE HUNDRED TO FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH THEY WON'T
QUALIFY BECAUSE THEY'RE
STRETCHED TO THE MAX JUST TO
MAKE FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH. SO WE FIND THE SIX MONTH
PLACEMENT PLAN NOT TO
EFFECTIVELY WORK SO AS WE LOOK
AT THESE OPTIONS WHETHER TO
SURELY BOND COMPANY KNOCKING
CALIFORNIA AS YET INSURERS
PLACING A BURDEN SOME CREDIT
QUALIFICATIONS OR THEIR SIX
MONTH PAYMENT PLAN NOT TO
EFFECTIVELY WORK WE WOULD URGE
THAT THIS BILL- TO BE AMENDED
TO DO JUST ONE THING MAKE AN
OPTION SEE HOW IT WORKS. SEE
THE INSURERS. AND EVERY ENSURE
WE HAVE LOOKED AT- AT THE END
WE'RE MORE THAN HAPPY TO SHARE
THAT WITH THE COMMITTEE AS WE
HAVE OFFERED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS- AS WE HAVE. I HAD SOME.
PREVIOUS ENGAGEMENT AND WE
WOULD URGE THE COMMITTEE TO.
AMEND THE BILL. FOR BEFORE IT
GETS TO THE FOR. AMEND THE BILL
AND- WITH THAT WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO OPPOSE THE BILL
WHAT'S THAT IS AMENDED THANK
YOU THANK YOU AND WE DO HAVE.
ONE OPPOSITION ON THE LINE THE
RECALLS AND- I YEAH CAN YOU
HEAR ME SIR YES. AT MONEY TO
GIVE A CALL TO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION YOU KNOW WE
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT AB
THIRTY TO SIXTY IS ATTEMPTING
TO RELIEVE TENANTS OF THE UP
FRONT COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
RENTING BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE
BILL WILL BE MORE EXPENSIVE IN
THE END FOR TENANTS AND PERHAPS
FOR OWNERS AS WELL. SO FIRST
LET ME START WITH THE SIX MONTH
SECURITY TO PAYMENT
REQUIREMENTS AB THIRTY TO SIXTY
WILL COST OWNERS WE BELIEVE TO
CHARGE HIGHER SECURITY DPOSITS
IN THE OTHERWISE WOULD. IN
ORDER TO COVER THE UP FRONT
SITUATIONS WERE TENANTS LEAVE
EARLY AT THE END- OR BEFORE THE
SIX MONTH PERIOD AND THEY LEAVE
ONLY RENT AND OR THEY DAMAGE
THE UNIT. TODAY MOST OWNERS DO
NOT CHARGE THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT
ALLOWED UNDER THE LAW IN FACT
THEY REQUIRE A LOWER DEPOSITED
GENERALLY THE APPLICABLE TO
MONTH LIMIT. AB THIRTY TO SIXTY
UNFORTUNATELY WE BELIEVE WILL
CHANGE THAT PRACTICE AND NOW
FOR THE SECURITY DEPOSIT
INSURANCE HERE ARE THE
CHALLENGES FOR THE TENANT AND
THE OWNERS. OF MOST OF THESE
WORK LIKE A BALL AND IT
ESSENTIALLY GUARANTEES THE
TENNIS PERFORMANCE UNDER THE
LEAST THE MONTHLY PREMIUM WHICH
CAN RANGE FROM TWENTY DOLLARS
TO FIFTY DOLLARS PER MONTH IS
NON REFUNDABLE TO THE TENANT
WERE OUT OF COURT THE
TRADITIONAL SECURITY DEPOSIT IS
REFUNDABLE. KENNETH FULFILL
THEIR OBLIGATIONS UNDER THAT
THE LEAST IN THE END DEPENDING
UPON THE STATE A TENANT AND
THAT MUCH. MORE THEN THE-
EIGHT. FORWARD TO SECURE
DEPOSIT. AT AND IT DOES NOT
COME THE ENTIRE DAMAGING IN THE
TEN. IS RESPONSIBLE. FOR
REPAYING THE COPPER THE DAMAGE
TO THE IN. COMPANY THE COMPANY
CAN THAT FOR THE COMPANY PAID
FOR THE DAMAGE CAUSED BY THE
TENNIS. AND EVEN SURE THE BOND
DO NOT TYPICALLY COVER UNPAID
READ LIKE A SECURITY DEPOSIT
DOES. AFFECT INSURANCE OF BONDS
ARE NOT HELPFUL FOR RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS WHO ARE TRYING
TO PAY THE EXPENSES. FOR CLEAN
THE POT THAT THE UNIT AT THE
END OF THE TENDENCY. ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT KIND OF DOES NOT
FULFIL THEIR RENTAL
OBLIGATIONS UNDER THE LEASE. NO
WE'RE CERTAINLY WILLING TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR. HOWEVER CAN
MAKE CLEAR UNDER THE LAW BUT
THESE INSURANCE BONDS ARE
VOLUNTARY- BUT WE DO NOT WISH
THIS TIME TO MAKE THE MANDATORY
FOR MANY THE REASON STATED BY
THE PREVIOUS WITNESS- AND FOR
THESE REASONS TODAY. WE OPPOSE
EIGHTY THREE TO SIXTY AND WE
ASK THAT YOU VOTE NO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. SIR ON THE
LINE WHO WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL IF YOU
COULD GIVE US YOUR NAME. AND
THAT YOU OPPOSE THE BILL THIRTY
ONE IN THE QUEUE. LINE EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS PACKED MORE
IN THERE AND WE CAN ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION. OPPOSED TO THE
BILL FOR THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY
STATED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONES WOULD
LIKE TO REGISTER OPPOSITION.
YOU'RE GETTINGINFORMATION
RENDITION ONLINE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. WHEN EIGHTY TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
STEEP CARLSON WITH THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION OF
GREATER LOS ANGELES FOR THE
REASONS STATED WE- RESPECTFULLY
MUST OPPOSE. THANK YOU. NINE
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SECURE MEMBERS GINGRICH CEELO
WITH THAT CALIFORNIA MENTAL
HEALTH ASSOCIATION YEAH
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE TWO SIX
ZERO THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS IN OPPOSITION. AT
THE TIME THEY'RE NOT
PREDICAMENT IN Q. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU ARE PRETTY MAY CLOSE
THE PHONE LINES ON A. B. THIRTY
TO SIXTY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
MISTER OBERNOLTE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ASSEMBLY WOMAN YOU
WHAT I HAD A DISCUSSION ABOUT
THIS BILL OVER THE WEEKEND I
JUST WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON ONE
OF THE QUESTIONS I HAD ABOUT
IT- IF A TENANT ELECTS TO
PURCHASE AN INSURANCE POLICY IN
LIEU OF A SECURITY DEPOSIT-
OBVIOUSLY THAT INSURANCE POLICY
IS GOING TO REQUIRE RENEWAL IF
THE TENANT. STAYS IN THE UNIT
BECAUSE THE EXPOSURE TO RISK OF
THE INSURANCE COMPANY IS BASED
ON THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT THAT
THE- THE TO THE TENETS OF THE
UNIT SO. NOT IN THE EVENT THAT
THE TENANT FAILS TO RENEW THE
INSURANCE POLICY WHAT WHAT THEN
HAPPENS BECAUSE THE BILL REALLY
DOESN'T TALK ABOUT THAT YEP.
AND I APPRECIATE OUR
CONVERSATION I BE ONE TO WORK
WITH YOU ONCE AMENDMENTS TO
CLARIFY THAT IF. OTHER TEN DOES
NOT PAY THE SECURITY DEPOSIT
AND THEY WOULD BE THE- M. THEY
BE REQUIRED TO PAY THE SECURITY
DEPOSIT. FOR SOMETHING THAT IF
OKAY THEY WERE. ON IF THEY
DON'T THEN WHAT. LEADING BY OF
THE LEASE TERMS DOWN. THEY BE
AFFECTED. ACTUALLY IF THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO PAY THE INSURANCE
ARE NOT GONNA BE THE SECURITY
DEPOSIT THE LAND THERE DOES
NEED SOME KIND OF PROTECTION
THERE BUT SIDE BE WILLING TO
WORK WITH YOU ON SOME LANGUAGE
THAT EFFECT OKAY I APPRECIATE
THAT I HAVE THAT'S MY CONCERN
ABOUT THE BILL IS THAT. THE
REASON WHY SECURITY DEPOSITS
EXIST YES TO PROTECT THE
LANDLORD FROM POTENTIAL DAMAGE
THAT THE TENANT DOES TO THE
UNIT SINCE THE TENET DOESN'T
ONLY UNIT. YEAH I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE PRESERVE THAT
PROTECTION YEP- I FEAR THOUGH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE FORCED
TO GO TO VERY PROBLEMATIC
DIRECTION BECAUSE- THERE'S NO
GETTING AWAY. FROM THE NEEDED
TO EFFECT THE TEN AND IF THEY
FAIL TO MATERIALLY ABIDE BY THE
TERMS OF THE LEASE. RIGHT NOW
AND IF THE TERMS OF THE LEASE
SAYS. YOU DON'T HAVE TO PROVIDE
A SECURITY DEPOSIT BUT YOU DO
HAVE TO HAVE THIS INSURANCE
POLICY IN PLACE. AND IF YOU
FAIL TO DO THAT YOU COULD BE
AFFECTED THEN WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO ENFORCE THAT AFFECTION.
YEAH UNFORTUNATELY IF YOU LOOK
AT- YOU KNOW THE DIRECTION THAT
CALIFORNIA STATE POLICIES BEEN
GOING OUT OF PATIENTS. WE'RE
GOING THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION
WERE MAKING IT HARDER AND
HARDER AND HARDER. FOR TENNIS
TO GET INFECTED. OUT OF
CONCERN. THAT WE DON'T WANT
PEOPLE TO BE HOMELESS SO- I'M
JUST AFRAID THAT THAT- THAT'S
GOING TO BE JUST AN UNWORKABLE
PROVISION OF THIS BILL. SO I
I'D LIKE TO THINK ABOUT- WHAT
SOME OF THE OPPONENTS HAVE THAT
ADDRESS SURE. TO MAKE THE BILL
BUT TO MAKE A BILL PERHAPS
OPTIONAL. DID YOU PILOT PROGRAM
TO SEE HOW. CNN TENNIS TAKE
ADVANTAGE IT. SEE IF IT CAUSES.
IF IT CAUSES EVICTIONS. AND
THEN- YOU KNOW MAYBE WE CAN
MAKE AN INFORMED DECISION IN
THE FUTURE. THAT'S THE
DIRECTION I'D LIKE TO SEE THE
WELCOME. WELL SO COUPLE
THOUGHTS ON THAT THE BILL IS
ABOUT OPTIONS RIGHT IT'S ABOUT
OPTIONS THAT BOTH PROTECT THE
LANDLORD- AND I AGAIN I DO WANT
TO WORK WITH YOU ON THE
SCENARIO IF. ATTENDED TO. PAY
THEIR PREMIUM. THAN THEY WOULD
BE EXPECTED TO PAY THEIR
SECURITY DEPOSIT IF THEY
COULDN'T. BE VIOLATING THE
TERMS OF THE LEASE AND- COULD
FACE EVICTION POTENTIALLY-
ABOUT MAKING THE ENTIRE BILL
OPTIONAL- THAT'S EFFECTIVELY MY
OPINION GETTING THE BILL- AND
IT'S OPTIONAL RIGHT NOW. SO
LANDLORDS RIGHT NOW COULD DO A
SIX MONTH PAYMENT PLAN IF THEY
WANTED TO. ON THE COULD YOU
SOME OF THE STUFF SO THIS BILL
IS REALLY ABOUT. GIVING OPTIONS
FOR THE TENANTS WHO. ARE GOING
TO NEED THEM DESPERATELY
SPECIALLY WHEN HE FACES MASSIVE
WAVE OF ACTIONS BUT- AGAIN I'M
WILLING TO WORK WITH YOU ON
SOME OF THAT LANGUAGE BECAUSE I
THINK YOU RAISE SOME GOOD
POINTS. AND WE TALK TO THE
OPPOSITION QUITE A BIT. I'M
ALSO HAPPY TO RESPOND TO SOME
OF THE COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE
IF THAT'S ALL. FOLKS YOU KNOW
WE CAN FIX FOR THE MISTAKES
SURE OR CAN TO RESPOND YEAH YOU
SURE HANDLE IN YOUR OR YOU PASS
TURF AND EVERYTHING YOU WHAT
THANK YOU VERY YOU KNOW I THE I
THINK THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
FACED WITH WHEN WE TRY TO
CODIFY WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU
DON'T RENEW YOUR POLICY IS THAT
THE EVICTION PROCESS TAKES A
WHILE SO YOU KNOW WHAT DO WE DO
FOR A LANDLORD WHO HAS ATTENDED
THE FILTER TO THE POLICY MAYBE
THE POLICY HAS A PROVISION THAT
THE LANDLORD GETS NOTIFIED TO
LANGUAGE BECAUSE NOTIFIED. THE
WEEK BEFORE THE POLICY IS DUE
TO EXPIRE THAT THE TENANT HAS
NOT RENEWED IT SO THE- TENET
DOESN'T REALLY WHAT THE
LANDLORD PROCEEDS WITH AND IF
THEY DON'T GIVE THEM THE OPTION
TO PROVIDE A SECURE DEPOSIT
REPLACEMENT POLICY THE TENET
FAILS TO DO THAT WE- FINALLY
THE LANDLORD IS FORCED TO
BRITISH EIGHT UNLAWFUL DETAINER
PROCEEDING AGAINST THE TENANTS
YEAH YEAH THE TENETS EVICTED
AND THE LANDLORD GOES AND FINDS
A BUNCH OF DAMAGE TO THE UNIT
WHICH IS NOT COVERED BECAUSE
THE CURRENT POLICY. IS WHAT YOU
KNOW THAT THAT'S WHAT THE
PROCESS IS SUPPOSED TO BE SURE
I THINK IT'S COULD BE DIFFICULT
TO TRY AND- TO TRY AND- HOW TO
FLY AROUND THAT THAT. FOR BUT
CERTAINLY WILL MINDED BUT THE
OPPOSING TODAY OF LOVE TO WORK
WITH YOU ON WHAT WE CAN COME UP
WITH SURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER KILEY THE MISTER TO.
IT'S KILEY. I THIS IS THE
REASON THAT I'M SORRY MR KILEY
YOU THE MASK IS OUT YOUR HEART
OF THE DRAW I'M SPEAKING IT'S
OKAY IF YOU WANT TO BE PROPERLY
ATTIRED AND OTHER PROTOCOLS.
WELL SO IS THERE A REASON THAT-
SECURITY DEPOSIT LOANS ARE NOT
A VIABLE ALTERNATIVE IT SEEMS I
CAN GET A PETTY GOOD AT PRETTY
DECENT INTEREST RATES AND SOME
YOU. BY SECURITY DEPOSIT ITSELF.
I BE INTERESTED EXPLORE THAT. I
MEAN I JUST GO ON AND I SEE
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF PROVIDERS
OUT THERE SO I'M WONDERING IF
THERE ARE THERE YEARS TO
GETTING ONE OF THESE LOANS THAT
MAKES- THIS POLICY SOLUTION.
NECESSARY I'M I'M HAPPY TO
EXPLORE AND. AGAINST ABOUT
SPREADING OPTIONS FOR FOLKS.
THANK YOU IT'S TRUE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- LET ME FIRST
START BY THANKING THE AUTHOR
FOR. STARTING TO THINK THROUGH
A VERY VERY CHALLENGING
SITUATION FOR US RIGHT NOW AND
THAT IS THE FACT THAT. 40% OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS CAMP BEFORE
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS IN ANY
ADDITIONAL EXPENDITURES DURING
THE MONTH. SO THE SCENARIO THAT
WE HAVE IS WE KNOW THAT AND
POTENTIALLY A FEW MONTHS WE MAY
SEE A WAVE OF INFECTIONS. WE
VERY LIKELY WILL HAVE. HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OFNOT MILLIONS OF
TENANTS TRYING TO LOOK FOR IN
PLACE AND THEY DON'T HAVE THE
SAVINGS TO. QUALIFY FOR SECURE
DEPOSITS ON A LOT OF WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW SO I APPRECIATE THE
OPPOSITION'S PERSPECTIVE THAT
THIS IS CERTAINLY NOT BUSINESS
AS USUAL- BUT I THINK GIVEN THE
HOUSING HOMES IS CRISIS ON TOP
OF THE CORONAVIRUS PRICES. ON
TOP OF THE KLAY FICTION OF.
MONTHS WE HAVE TO THINK THINGS.
I WAS LISTENING TO INTENTLY TO
THE OPPOSITION I JUST WANNA
MAKE A FEW POINTS ABOUT THE
OPPOSITION. OF SOME THE
OPPOSITION ARGUMENTS AS A WAY
OF JUST CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION. I HEARD MR
KINGSTON REFER TO THE FACT
THAT. WE VERY LIKELY MAY SEE A
TENANT WHO CAN'T AFFORD. THE
SAY THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS ON
TOP OF THE FIFTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS. AND I THINK THAT VERY
WELL COULD BE TRUE. I THINK THE
QUESTION IS HOW WILL THAT
TIENEN. GET THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THE FIRST PLACE TO
COBBLE TOGETHER SECURE DEPOSIT
EVEN RENT IN THAT SPOT AND WE
ALL NEED TO FIGURE OUT. HOW TO
HOW TO SOLVE THAT SHEET CAA'S
CONTENTION THAT RIGHT NOW. A
LOT OF LANDLORDS ARE NOT
CHARGING TWO X. OR THREE X.
KERN DEPOSIT. IF THAT'S THE
CASE I MIGHT SUGGEST ANOTHER
RAP FOR THIS IS WE CAN ACTUALLY
REDUCE THAT TWO X. OF THREE X.
MARK. BUT IF I'M NOT PREPARED
TO DO THAT WE HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT. CREATIVE SOLUTIONS LIKE
THIS- I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
IDEA THAT POTENTIALLY WE CAN DO
THIS IN A VOLUNTARY OPTIONAL
WAY. BUT WE KNOW THE REALITY
IS. THAT'S JUST NOT GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF LANDLORDS ARE CAN
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF. AS EVIDENCED
BY THE OPPOSITION TODAY AND SO.
MAILLET ASK OF ALL PARTIES IS
TO CONTINUE TO MOVE THIS
CONVERSATION- ARE WE HAPPY TO.
ENGAGE WITH MISS WORKS ON THIS
AS WELL- BUT WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO SOLVE THIS- BECAUSE
IT IS VERY LIKE. A COUPLE
MONTHS. THE VAST MAJORITY OF
TENANTS. WHO WILL KNOW. TO
PREPARE. BE ABLE. TO SAVE. TO
COST. WAS AND THEN ALMOST START
AND SO WITH THAT. AGAIN
APPRECIATE THE CREATIVITY. I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD AND- CALL.
WITH FOR. I THINK THAT WHAT
WEEK'S IS PROPOSED. MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE TO ME AND WITHOUT A
HAPPY TO MAKE A MOTION TO WITH
THIS BILL. I THINK IT WOULD A
MOTION IS THERE A SECOND. AND
THE SECOND THING YOU VERY MUCH
GALLAGHER. RIGHT THIS CALL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THE
THINK USER WEEKS FOR BRING THIS
FOR AND TO THE SERVER SHOES
POINT YOU KNOW THE MEDIAN RENTS
SOUNDS DAYS OR THREE THOUSAND A
MONTH AND SO IT. I THINK WE
NEED TO BE CREATIVE RATHER THAN
HAVING FOLKS EVEN IF IT'S A ONE
X. SECURITY BUSCA SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS. IT IS TWO X. OBVIOUSLY
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS AND WE'RE
ASKING A LOT. OF TENANTS TO BE
ABLE TO COME UP WITH HAT. AND
PARTICULARLY IN THE MIDDLE THIS
CRISIS AND THIS IS A CRISIS
WHERE. ALL OF US HAVE TO COME
TOGETHER DISNEY'S SACRIFICES
DOES BEEN DOING THINGS
DIFFERENTLY WE'VE BEEN
ACCUSTOMED TO DOING. AND IN
THIS CASE I THINK THE RISKS TO
THE REAL NOT JUST REST WITH THE
REALITY THAT. WE'RE GONNA SEE
AN EXPLOSION AND HOMELESSNESS
OR AT LEAST A HOUSING AND
SECURITY EVEN BEYOND WHAT WE
WERE. IN THE MIDDLE. OF A
BOOMING ECONOMY. AND SO I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR WORKING-
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
PARTIES. TO TRY TO CREATE AS
MUCH FLEXIBILITY AS POSSIBLE.
BUT I AGREE THE SUMMERS YOU
THAT IT CAN'T JUST BE AN
OPTIONAL PROGRAM. BECAUSE IT IS
AN OPTIONAL PROGRAM AGAIN THEN.
I'M SO THE PROOF YOUR ALLOW. TO
DECIDE WHAT IT'S GOING TO OCCUR
OR NOT. AND I WOULD ADD MORE
THING IN TURN OF UP TO TEN
LOOPHOLE THAT. IF A TENANT.
CHOOSES RIVER OPS TO DO IT IS
TO A SIX MONTH PAYMENT OR ALONE
OR HAVE YOU. THAT THEY NOT BE
BIASED AGAINST. A FOR MAKING
THAT CHOICE SO COULD VERY WELL
BE THAT ONCE IS AN AGREEMENT ON
A LEASE AGREEMENT. THEN THE
TENANT. IT WILL DECLARES WHAT
MANNER THEY CHOOSE TO PAY THIS
KERN ABBAS THERE'S GOT SOME
PROTECTION ON THAT AND-
OTHERWISE I THINK YOU'LL START
TO SEE BIASES AGAINST- THOSE
TENANTS AND IT'LL END UP AGAIN
BEING A SITUATION WHERE THE
TENANT WOULD DECIDE NOT TO DO
IT. BECAUSE THEY'RE GONNA BE
COMPETING AGAINST. OTHER
TENANTS THAT HAVE THE ABILITY
TO PAY SCRIPT HAS UP FRONT SO-
FURTHER CONVERSATION ON HOW WE
CAN HAVE. THE PROTECTION OF
THOSE OPTIONS SO THE OPTION
EXISTS HOW CAN WE MAKE IT
PALATABLE TO ALL PARTIES TO THE
BEST EXTENT POSSIBLE. AND HOW
DO YOU MAKE IT A REAL OPTION
FOR TENANTS IN AGAIN THIS
CRISIS SITUATION WHERE WE HAVE
TO ALL COME TOGETHER IS
CALIFORNIANS. AND MAKING SURE
THAT EVERYONE HAS A HOME SHOULD
BE A PRIORITY FOR EVERYONE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THIS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU MS WE I AGREE WITH THEM
CHIU THAT THIS IS THAT NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED THERE'S NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT I THINK THAT
THINGS ARE VERY DIFFERENT IN
OAKLAND WHEN YOU COMPARE TO MY
ARIENS SAMPOERNA DINO IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO MOVE INTO TO AN
APARTMENT. AND SO I WANT TO
CONTINUE OUR CONVERSATION IN
THAT REGARD- AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR WILLINGNESS ALSO TO
DISCUSS. THOSE WHO ARE RENTING
MONTH TO MONTH. IF THEY'RE-
GIVEN SIX MONTHS TO GIVE THE
DEPOSIT. IT'S IT ISN'T
SOMETHING THAT THAT WILL WORK
FOR THOSE LANDLORDS. I THINK
TRYING TO FIND A SOLUTION THAT
IS GOOD FOR OUR TENANTS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. AND IF YOU
HAVE TO REMEMBER ALSO THAT MANY
OF THESE LANDLORDS THEY'RE NOT
THE HUNDRED APARTMENT UNITS
MANY OF THEM ARE MOM POP WHO'VE
INVESTED THEIR ENTIRE LIFE
SAVINGS INTO BUYING THESE
RENTALS- AND MAKING SURE THAT
THERE ARE PROTECTIONS SO THAT
THEY ARE NOT THE ONES THAT ARE
SUBSIDIZING. I THINK FINDINGA
WAY TO GET THE IMPACT ON THOSE
SMALL- POP LANDLORDS IS GOING
TO BE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. BUT
THE CONCEPT OF YOUR BILL I
APPRECIATE TRYING TO FIND
SOLUTIONS AND TRYING TO FIND
OPTIONS SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL. THANK YOU. COMMENTS
FROM THE DIE. RIGHT SEE THAT IS
WHAT TO MAKE OF THIS THANK YOU
MR TO A ADDRESS A LOT OF THE
THINGS I WAS GOING TO RAISE A
IN TERMS OF SOME OF THE
COMMENTS BY THE OPPOSITION- BUT
I WILL SAY YOU KNOW MY THE GOAL
HERE IS TO IS TO WORK WITH ALL
PARTIES TO TRY TO FIND MORE
SOLUTIONS THAT WORK FOR
EVERYONE. ESPECIALLY IN THIS
PANDEMIC THAT IS GOING TO CAUSE
UNPRECEDENTED EVICTIONS THAT
WE'RE GONNA SEE ACROSS THE
STATE BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
EXPLORE THAT- ADDING SENTIMENTS
TO ADDRESS MR COLORS CONCERN
WHICH TO SHARE AS WELL. WE
WOULD MAKE SURE NOT AS- RATING
A LAW THAT WILL CONTINUE ANY
KIND OF FURTHER DISCRIMINATION.
OR SCRATCH I PRACTICES.
LOBBYIST EVEN THOUGH. MISTER
WHAT IS GOING TO POSE A BILL
THAT I WOULD BE. HAPPY TO SIT
DOWN WITH HIM AND KEEP WORKING
FOR SOME OF THE CONCERNS YOU
RAISES WALLS. I'M IS REYES. AND
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF I
THINK A CONVERSATION I SAW
SOMETHING THERE'S OUTSTANDING
QUESTIONS THAT MR SHE RAISED
AROUND. THE FACT THAT THE CAPS
ARE. PRETTY HIGH. YOU KNOW I
THINK WE CAN TALK THROUGH ALL
THESE THINGS IN THE COMING-
DAYS AND WEEKS AND MONTHS- AND
I AM ALSO COMMITTED. THIS BILL
OPPOSED TO BE DOUBLE REFER TO
GO TO INSURANCE AS WELL.
BECAUSE OF THE- PANDEMIC IT'S
NOT AND SO I. GAVE MY
ASSURANCES TO MR DAILY THAT I'D
WORK WITH HIM AS WELL AND HIS
COMMITTEE STAFF ON. ANY ISSUES
THAT THEY RAISED AS WELL SO.
WOULD LOVE TO KEEP THE BILL
MOVING FORWARD I THINK OUR
TENNIS NEEDED I WANTED TO DO.
ALSO HER LANDLORD. SO ASK FOR.
A VOTE. THANK YOU WE NEED HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND THE MOST
IS TO PASS ROLE PLEASE. YEAH I
LIVE ABOUT THAT. HI LIVE
DOLLARS RIGHT. YEAH. HI. THE
BILL IS APT THANK YOU MUCH.
THANK YOU EVERYONE THANK YOU
WELL AS MISC COMES UP. TAKE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
SO MOVED BY MISTER OBERNOLTE
AND SECOND BY MISERY S. THANK
YOU CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. YEAH
HI. IT'S A. YOU RIGHT.
FIVE
FIVE. OKAY THOSE BILLS ARE ALL
OUT THAT IS AB TWENTY THREE
NINETEEN BERMAN AB TWENTY SEVEN.
SEVENTEEN CHAO AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY THREE TWO AB TWENTY
EIGHT OH FIVE EGGMAN EASIER ONE
SEVENTY THREE GALLAGHER AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY THREE
OBERNOLTE. AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY FOUR OBERNOLTE AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE OBERNOLTE AB
THREE OH SIX TWO OBERNOLTE AB
TWO OH FIVE ONE NOT OBERNOLTE
BUT HIS RANTS. AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY FIVE ROBERT RIVAS AB ONE
TWENTY TWO AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
THREE STONE AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY EIGHT TANG. AND THEN AB.
336-333-6430 THREE SIXTY FIVE
ALL OUR COMMITTEE BILLS. ARE
ALL OUT OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU. SO HARD LET'S SEE YOU CAN
CHANGE YOUR VOTE HOWEVER IF YOU
WOULD LIKE. ALL RIGHT SO
OPERATOR OPEN THE LINES FOR AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE. THIS
CARILLO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF HER 2% AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE WHICH ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS TO SUSPEND THEIR
CHILD SUPPORT ORDERS WELL
INCARCERATED OR INVOLUNTARILY
HELD IN AN INSTITUTION FOR MORE
THAN NINETY DAYS BEFORE JANUARY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA
PROVIDED AN AUTOMATIC PROCESS
FOR THE TEMPORARY SUSPENSION.
OF CHILD SUPPORT ORDERS FOR
INCARCERATED PARENTS
UNFORTUNATELY THE STATE LAW HAS
EXPIRED MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT
AND COSTLY FOR LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCIES AND THE COURTS
TO COMPLY WITH THE FEDERAL
RULE. THIS EXPLORATION HAS
RESULTED IN THE CONTINUED A
CRUEL FOR STAGGERING AMOUNT OF
CHILD SUPPORT THAT MOST OF
WHICH IS TO BE PAID WITH A 10%
INTEREST RATE. THE CHILD
SUPPORT DEBT IS IN ADDITION TO
RESTITUTION AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE FINES AND FEES IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE OVER FORTY TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN PRISON
EARNED EIGHT CENTS AN HOUR FOR
THEIR WORK FOR MUCH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
THE DUCKS A MANDATORY. 55% FOR
RESTITUTION AND ADMINISTRATIVE
FEES LEAVING NO MONEY FOR CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS. THIS BILL IS
VITAL TO ENSURING CAR SERRATED
PARENTS HAVE SUCCESSFUL RE
ENTRY AND YOU REUNIFICATION
WITH THEIR CHILDREN. AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE RESTORED TO
THE STATUE THAT A FIVE YEAR.
ALLOW AUTUMN TO SPEND OF TO
ORDER OF THE PARENT WHO IS
INCARCERATD FOR AGAIN MORE
THAN NINETY DAYS. I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS
BILL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AS A BILL THAT WAS
FORWARD. OVER THE PHONE TO
TESTIFY AS VICTOR RIO WITH THE
CHILD SUPPORT DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND JUST A COUPLE
OF LOW WITH THE CENTER FOR LAW
AND POVERTY. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND. WE
HAVE TO. WITH THIS IS IN
SUPPORT BOTH OF WHOM ON THE
TELEPHONE FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING THE ONLY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
VICTOR RIGHT AND I'M SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE CHILD SUPPORT
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA- WE REPRESENT THE
DIRECTOR OF THE COUNTY CHILD
SUPPORT ATP DINNER THE PROGRAM
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. AN
IMPORTANT PROGRAM GOAL FOR A
YOU CAN MAKE SURE THAT ALL
CHILD SUPPORT ORDERS. THE
AMOUNT OF THAT ON THE ORDER
THAT THEY ON A NON CUSTODIAL
PARENT ACTUAL INCOME. AND
THEREFORE THEY HAVE THE ABILITY
TO PAY THAT ORDER. WHAT IF HE
PAYS OR INCARCERATED THEY%
OBVIOUSLY WITH THEIR INCOME AND
THEY LOSE THEIR ABILITY TO MAKE
THAT CHILD SUPPORT OBLIGATION.
AND WITHOUT INTERVENTION OF
FUNDS FOR LARGER WORDS BALLOT
OR GOING TO ACCUMULATE. ON
THOSE- CHILD SUPPORT ORDERS.
NOW WE KNOW. PREPAID OTHER ONE
REENTER I AND TO TELL SUPPORT.
LEADERS WE HAVE THE END THE-
LADY COME OVER. WHEN THEY HAD
REACHED SUPPORT THAT. WE OFFER
A FAIRLY AND FORTUNE THIRTY
WHERE WOULD THAT HAVE BUT NOT
THE TIRTY PARENTS ANYTHING
HE'S WELL ATTENDED THE- FROM
THE PROPER THEY FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE- KIND OF HOPE LOOK FOR
THAN THAT THEY'LL NEVER BE ABLE
TO PAY OFF ALL THEIR DEATH CAN
FORTY. SOME OF THE A LOT OF THE
CHEESE IS. BASICALLY GIVE UP
NOT MAKING ANY PAYMENTS AT ALL-
IN THAT IT WILL WORK WITH A LOT
THE NOT THAT THE OF PARENTS OF
IN THE SITUATION. AND OFF THERE
TOO. IN TERMS OF THE COPY OF
THE CHECK. AND BECAUSE OUR-
PAYING. UPS LESS TO THE
CHILDREN TOOK MAKES ABOUT
PARTICULAR WORKS. SPENDING
ORDER CA YOUR HERE THEY
CARTER TO HAVE. BENEFIT OF
HELPING A TO AVOID THE AREA.
WHICH ACTUALLY FOR A LOW THIRTY
FIVE WITH THE THEY WOULD BE A
POINT APPROACH TO HOW THE
SITUATION FOR HIM THE ROUND
STATE. BUT WHEN A LOT BETTER
LOCAL TO FOR EIGHT CITIES. ALL
THAT KIND OF GOING TO FROM
DIFFERENT. FROM HAVE TO
STANDARD LANGUAGES ALL OTHER TO
ASSIST ARREARS SOME OTHER HAVE
STAND LANGUAGE BUT IT PUT IT
DOWN THE- OTHER COUNTY LANGUAGE.
AN INSTALLER COUNTY DON'T HAVE
EIGHT. FOR THEIR WHICH WILL
BRING. GOING THROUGH THE-
POSSIBLY IN HIGH AGREE TO BEING
BORDER MODEST. PROCESS INVOLVED
COURT. DELIVERED IS THAT IF
YOU'RE- THE CARD THREE TODAY HI
YOUR CAKE GOING TO BE. WILL
DEPEND ON WHAT COUNTY MANAGING
THE K. REINSTATE INSPECTIONS
FOR BOTH THE POINT. WILL BE
STORED AT YOU KNOW STATE
APPROACH. WELL INSURE IT IN PPO
BETTER THERE IS THE THEIR CHILD
FOR THE MERRILEES FROM BECAUSE
ATION. TO REMOVE THAT AREA THAT
NEARLY REAL IN THE PEOPLE ARE
ABLE ONE THE OTHER WAY ABLE TO
PAY AREA TO THEIR READ. NEEDED
CHILL. ANOTHER DAY OF BUT
THEY'LL THE HAS BUILT A TAKE
THAT WENT OUT THE OTHER THING
WOULD BE TO NAY A- HEALTH A JOB
BUT CHAO CLICK ABOUT. IT EITHER
PART TO PARA EL CONCERN ABOUT
THE COULD PETITION THAT WOULD
BY THE. AND ANOTHER BENEFIT
VERY YET LITTLE OUT FOR GREATER.
THE BALL LOCAL COURT AND A LOT
CHILD ONE EIGHTY THREE. FIRING
REDUCING THE NEED TAKE EVERY
MARKET REQUEST TO COURT. OVER
THE THREE CST PORT BUT THEY'LL
LET HER GET THE LIFE OF. THE
COURT AND THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL COLLECTORS AND I'M NOT
POVERTY AND- OTHER. AND I THINK
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE GOAL OF
THAT TALK ABOUT TO SEND IT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE ORDERS THAT
ARE CHARGED TO THE NON
CUSTODIAL PARENT REFLECT THE
ACTUAL ABILITY TO EARN. YOU
HAVE THAT MICHAEL PRESENTER AT
THAT IN ORDER TO COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL LAW THAT THE ORDER. WE
FLEXIBILITY GET EARNED- THAT WE
NEED TO TAKE SOME KIND OF
ACTION FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
PRISON- IT'S NOT AN AUTOMATIC
EXTENSION THAT DOES NOT REMOVE
THE PERFECT RIGHT TO APPEAL
THEIR ORDER AND TO GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS WITHIN THE COURT.
TO GET AN ORDER THAT REFLCTS
THEIR ABILITY TO EARN- THIS IS
A LOT THIS IS THE RIGHT AND
THEY HAVE UNDER THE LAW UNDER
THE REGULATION- WHAT IT DOES IS
NOT HAVING IT AND I TO FIND
THAT THEY PUT. OWNERS ON THE
LOCAL AGENCY TO A COURT AND
THAT AND THE PUBLIC SAFETY
SYSTEM TO INFORM THE PERSON WHO
IS INCARCERATED OF THEIR RIGHT
AND TO PROFIT. DOES APPEAL.
WHETHER THAT THE ORDER IS AUTO.
WE COULD SPEND IT DOESN'T PRIOR
TO JANUARY ONE OR OR DOWN TO
THE COURT. AT THE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THE CRYSTAL
PARENT WHO. IS BLOWING JUST BY.
OF BEING IN A FAMILY WITH A PER
GOOD KNICKS. THOSE PEOPLE OFF
HAVE THE RIGHT TO A APPEAL I
REQUEST FOR OR- SO IF THE CASE
WAS THAT SOMEBODY WHO WAS IN
PRISON HAD ADDITIONAL WEALTH OR
INCOME. AT THAT THOSE ORDERS
WOULD BE REDUCED IF THAT WERE
THE CASE. THE OTHER THING
THAT'S IMPORTANT AND THIS IS
THE PART THAT REALLY- I THINK A
LOT OF PEOPLE MEANT. IS THAT
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE AS I SAID
BEFORE WHO ARE INCARCERATED
THEY WERE POOR BEFORE THEY
BECAME INCARCERATED AND THEIR
CHILDREN AND ARE COMFORTABLE
PARENTS ALSO CORPS- LOOK AT
DON'T KNOW PARENTS WHEN THEY
APPLY FOR PUBLIC BENEFITS THEY
ARE REQUIRED BY FEDERAL LAW TO
OPEN A CHILD SUPPORT ORDER.
THIS IS EVEN IF THEY DON'T WANT
TO. AND OFTEN TIMES EVEN THOUGH
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE AN
OPTIONAL RELIEF FOR PEOPLE WITH
DOMESTIC ABUSE. OR OTHER
THINGS- AND OTHER SITUATIONS.
THEY THEY DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT
TO NOT. OPEN A CHILD SUPPORT
ORDER. THE MONEY EACH MONTH
THAT- THAT IS- DOING CAPITAL
ORDER THAT'S NOT PAID EACH
MONTH THAT IS NOT PAID WHEN THE
FAMILY. OF A BENEFIT. IT NEVER
GETS RETURNED TO THAT YOUR
PARENTS. WANTED NOT PAID IT
BECOMES DEBT- TO THE STATE
FEDERAL. AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND SO ONLY A TOPIC ORDER. IN
THE MY THAT IT DO. ONLY THEN
DOES THE MONEY GETS PASSED
THROUGH FIFTY DOLLARS OF IT- AS
PER STATE LAW. TO THE CUSTODIAL
FAMILY. SO WE'RE NOT DOING
BECAUSE THERE'S A FAMILY AND
YOU ANY FAVORS HERE WHEN WE-
WHEN WE REQUIRE. A JET TO BE
BILLED TO THE NON CUSTODIAL
PARENT WHILE THEY'RE IN PRISON.
THAT'S IMPORTANT THE LAST THING
I WANT TO POINT OUT. IS THAT
MANY CONSIDER MANY NON
CUSTODIAL PARENT. THE ONLY
REASON THEY ARE A NONCUSTODIAL
PARENT WHETHER IN PRISON IS
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN PRISON. THE
MAJORITY OF 84% OF WOMEN WHO
ARE PREGNANT. WE TURN TO THEIR
CHILDREN WHEN THEY WERE
RELEASED FROM PRISON. AND OVER
50% OF MAIL TO RETURN FROM
PRISON- INTO THE COMMUNITY WE
TRY TO THEIR CHILDREN. THEY ARE
NOT BECAUSE THEIR PARENTS
BECAUSE THEY WERE SENT TO
PRISON. AND THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPRISONMENT
OF PEOPLE OF COLOR AND LOW
INCOME PEOPLE CAN'T BE DENIED
IN. CALIFORNIA AND CONTRIBUTE
TO THIS WAS TAKING OF WELCOMING
COMMUNITIES IT DOESN'T HELP THE
NOCTURNAL PARENT IT DOESN'T
HELP THE CUSTODIAL PARENT. AND
YOU HEARD BEFORE BUT I CO
PRESENTED IT OFTEN HARM TO THE
CHILD UPON RETURNED TO THE
COMMUNITY. DOCTOR THESE REASONS
WE ARE HERE I THOUGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYONE HERE
A PERSON WHO WOULD LIKE TO
IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND OFFER
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. THIS IS
AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE.
RIGHT SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND
SAY THAT YOU SUPPORT AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE. COMPLAIN
ONLINE SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MARGOT GEORGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION A WE SUPPORT AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. COMMENT FROM THE
LINE OF NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
DEMOCRAT LESS FROM MARYLAND
BATES YEAH YOU OF CALIFORNIA IN
THE FOR THE BABY. I THANK.
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE EIGHTY NINE. NINE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN IT BE CHAIR OF ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT. AS
A REMINDER OF A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE I'LL GATHER
INFORMATION FROM THE LINE THE
QUEUE TO. LINE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE ONLY BE A
LITTLE BIT BETTER FOR
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES A
PROUD SPONSOR OF. THANK YOU.
BUT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
REGISTERED OPPOSITION ON AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE BUT
WOULD ANYONE. ON THE PHONE LIKE
TO IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND
REGISTER OPPOSITION. RIGHT
OPERATORS THIRTY ONE IN THE
QUEUE. THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS IN Q. RIGHT THANK YOU
OFFER YOU CAN CLOSE THE PHONE
LINES THAT FOR AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FIVE. QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MUST KILEY.
I HAVE MIXED FEELINGS ABOUT
THIS BILL I WANTED TO ASK
THERE'S A AN EXEMPTION OR
EXCEPTION OR THE BILL DOESN'T
APPLY- FOR FOLKS WHO'VE BEEN
CONVICTED OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
OR FAMILY TO PAY CHILD SUPPORT
ITSELF. I CAN I JUST ASK WHY IT
WHY IS AN EXCEPTION THEIR WHITE
WHY IT IS THE LOGIC OF IT ON A
PLATE OF THOSE CASES. A CERTAIN
WITH YOUR QUESTION YEAH WELL I
AM THIRTY THE EXCEPTION FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE US CENSUS.
WHY IS THERE NOT OR LINE WHY IS
THAT. HY THEY'RE NOT AN
EXCEPTION LIKE IS THERE AN
EXCEPTION. WHY IS THERE AN
EXCEPTION I DON'T HAVE THAT
ANSWER FOR YOU NOW I'M
WONDERING IF ANYBODY THE
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE TWO. HI
THIS IS VICTOR A WITH THE CHILD
SUPPORT DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
AND I THINK THE PURPOSE- BUT
THE EXCEPTION IS TO- SAY IF.
YOU ARE CARDS RATED BECAUSE YOU
CAN IN A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
BARBIE AGAINST YOUR SPOUSE OR
YOUR CHILD. OR YOU HAVEN'T PAID
YOUR CHILD SUPPORT THAT WOULD
NOT BE. OKAY YOU COULD DO AND
THEN- RECEIVE THE BENEFIT- THAT
THEY- CHILD SUPPORT ORDER SHALL
I TAKE IT. INTENDED TO NOT
REWARD- AN INDIVIDUAL FOR
HIDING AGING IN THOSE BEHAVIORS.
SO I GUESS THAT'S SORT OF MY
POINT IS THAT WHY DOESN'T THAT-
PREMISE APPLY FOR ALL CLASSES
OF OFFENSES. THIRTY ONE ANSWER
THAT. HI MICHAEL YEAH BUT COULD
YOU JUST REPEAT THE QUESTION
AND THE THIRTY ONE AFTER THAT.
THE OTHER QUESTION WAS- YOU
KNOW THE IDEA THAT THAT WAS
JUST STATED AS WE DON'T WANT TO
REWARD FOLKS FOR HAVING
COMMITTED PARTICULAR OFFENSES
AS THE WIND IS NOT LOGIC NOT
APPLY TO- ALL OFFENSES FOR
WHICH YOU MIGHT BE INCARCERATED.
YEAH GOOD DID YOU WANT TO
ANSWER THAT. AS I UNDERSTAND
YOU MIGHT BE MORE- ABLE TO
RESPOND TO IT BUT AS I
UNDERSTAND IT THAT THE DARK-
THE SPECIFIC ALLOW ME TO
PROVIDED FOR UNDER FEDERAL.
GUIDE AND YOU KNOW GOING BACK
TO THE ORIGINAL CONTACT THE
CHILD SUPPORT IS THAT CHILD
SUPPORT IS THAT THE ORDERS ARE
SUPPOSED TO REFLECT THE EARNING
AT A ABILITY OF THE PERSON AND
I THINK THAT BURNING ABILITY
RIGHT SO FOR EXAMPLE IF THE
PERSON IS OUT OF PRINT AND IF
THE PERSON IN THE COMMUNITY
AND- I WILL HAVE NEVER GOT
PREVENT ANY SIMPLY CHOOSIN NOT
TO WORK EARN MONEY BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO PAY CHILD
SUPPORT- THAT PERSON HAS EIGHT
EIGHT IF THEY'RE ABLE BODIED
ANY DEEMED TO HAVE THE ABILITY
TO WORK. THEN AND THEIR ORDER
CAN BE SET APPROPRIATELY- BUT A
PERSON IN PRISON DOESN'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO WORK OR IF THEY
DO WORK THEY ARE THEY ARE
EARNING 8% TO A 30% TAKEN
ALMOST 50% AGAIN OUT QUIRK OVER
50% KICKING OUT CORRECT
ACCUSED- SO THE ORDER. IT'S
PHOTO. THE EARNING ABILITY OF
THAT PERSON. IT LOOKS TO CARVE
OUT ARE ALLOWED AND ENCOURAGED
EITHER. THE FEDERAL LAW THERE
ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD THE. TWO
NO I THINK THE I YOU. IT AND
COULD AND I THINK THAT THE INTO
IS TO. AT THE- HOLD BILL'S
PROVISIONS IS TO PUT. I'M NOT
PROVIDE ANY TYPE BUT THE CHANGE
OF NOR ANYTHING LIKE THAT OR
BENEFIT FOR INDIVIDUAL GAUGING
IN THAT KIND OF BEHAVIOR. THANK
YOU. I OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
THE DIVES WITHOUT THIS KIND I
THINK YOU RAISE IT AN
INTERESTING QUESTION AND IT HAS
TO DO I THINK MORE. OKAY WELL
ME LET ME JUST FINISH THIS
THOUGHT THAT MORE WITH THE
POLITICS OF HOW WE PUNISH OR
NOT OFTENTIMES WHEN WE'RE
TRYING TO GIVE RELIEF FOR
SOMEONE WHO IS INCARCERATED
THERE WILL BE A LOT OF PUBLIC
BACKLASH FOR ALL MY GOSH THIS
IS A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
PERPETRATOR WAR THIS SOMEONE
WHO HASN'T PAID CHILD SUPPORT
BEFORE SO WHY WOULD WE GIVE
THEM THE BENEFIT OF THE BILL
IT'S REALLY AN EMOTIONAL
RESPONSE AS OPPOSED TO ANY
ECONOMIC OR RATIONAL RESPONSE
BECAUSE YOU CORRECT. RATIONALLY
ANYONE WHO DOES NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PAY. WE SHOULD BE
ESSENTIALLY HOLDING THE
OBLIGATIONTO PAY CHILD SUPPORT
BECAUSE W'RE JUST EXACERBATING
THE SITUATION SO THAT SAME
LOGIC WOULD IMPLY. BUT OFTEN
TIMES THAT I THINK THERE THIS
DOES HAVE MORE TO DO WITH WITH
SOME OF THE EXCLUSIONS AND
FEDERAL LAW. BUT A LOT OF THAT
COMES FROM. THIS IS THIS IS A-
HEINOUS ENOUGH RYAN OR THIS IS
AN ON POINT CRIME SO WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GIVE THEM THE BENEFIT
OF IT. AND UNFORTUNATELY. THE
SAFETY LAW CRIMINAL LAW AND
WHEN WE LOOK AT PUNISHMENTS AND
RELEASES REPLETE WITH THESE
KINDS OF. NOT NECESSARILY
RATIONAL POLICY DECISIONS BUT
EMOTIONAL POLICY DECISIONS
BASED AROUND THE- THE TYPE OF
OFFENSE AND SO I THINK THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS THAT. THAT
YOU THAT WE SEE THOSE KINDS OF
DISTINCTIONS BEING MADE
OTHERWISE YEAH THERE'S NOT.
NECESSARILY RATIONAL RESPONSE.
THIS IS A- THANK YOU KNOW AND
I'M SO SORRY WE HAVEN'T HAD A
CHANCE TO EVEN SPEAK ABOUT THIS
BILL IN NAME BEEN MEANING ALL
WEEKEND TO CALL YOU AND I DID
AND SO I APOLOGIZE IF THIS
NEEDS MY VOTE TODAY TO MOVE IT
ON I WILL VOTE FOR IT I'M
POLICY REASONS BUT I REALLY
HOPE TO STOP IN A MINUTE. ECHO
THE SAME THING I SAID NOW FOR I
THINK WE'VE SEEN THIS BILL
THREE TIMES. MY CONCERN WITH
THIS BILL IS NOT THAT. THE OVER
REACHING POLICY THAT OF COURSE
OF SOMEBODY CAN'T PAY IT MORE
PUTTING SOMEBODY FURTHER IN
DEBT IT DOESN'T MAKE A LOT OF
SENSE- I DO LIKE THE EXCEPTIONS
AND I'M NEXT I THINK QUITE
FRANKLY THAT THERE ARE RANT BUT
RARE SITUATIONS. WHERE COUPLES
CAN DEVOLVE SO BADLY IN A
RELATIONSHIP THAT SAYS THAT-
OFTEN I'M HAND. WILL RIGHT
WOULD RATHER GO TO JAIL THEN
PAY CHILD SUPPORT AND IS ABOUT
ABUSE AND IT IS ABOUT- CONTROL
OVER A SITUATION THOSE THINGS
ACTUALLY HAVE HAPPENED. BUT
THAT BEING SAID MY CONCERN IS
THIS POLICY DOESN'T FOCUS ON
THE CHILD WE BENEFIT- THE
SITUATION MAYBE THE
INCARCERATED- BY RELIEVING OF
THIS UNREALISTIC PRESSURE TO
PAY CHILD SUPPORT WHERE IN
PRESENT. BUT IT DOESN'T BENEFIT
THE CHILD AND WHAT I'D LIKE TO
SEE IN THIS BILL AND I'VE ASKED
FOR NOW IF MULTIPLE TIMES. IS
SOME SORT OF- PARENTING CLASS
OR INVOLVEMENT CLASS THAT THE-
THE INDIVIDUAL WOULD HAVE TO
TAKE WHILE THEY'RE INCARCERATED
SO ALTHOUGH THEY'RE NOT
PROVIDING ANYTHING FINANCIALLY
TO THEIR CHILD DURING THAT
TIME. WHAT ELSE CAN WE DO OR
REQUIRE IN ORDER THAT THEIR-
THAT CHILD IS GOING TO
ALTERNATELY HAVE A BENEFIT. OF
THAT REALLY FOR PAYMENT AND SO-
THAT'S SOMETHING I ASKED FOR I
HAVEN'T EVER SEEN AND I KNOW
THERE'S SOME. SOME OF THESE
TYPES OF- OF CLASSES THROUGHOUT
OUR OUR SYSTEM. AND I THINK
THAT- THAT WOULD MAKE ME FEEL
MUCH BETTER ABOUT THE PROSPECT
OF LEAVING EVEN FOR MONTHS OR
YEARS- CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS
THAT ARE COMING ANYWAY YOU KNOW
WHERE WE WERE ALL VERY
REALISTIC. BUT IF WE'RE TRULY
CHILD'S CENTRIC AND HOWARD
VIEWING CHILD SUPPORT AND THE
NECESSARY- NEEDS OF A CHILD.
THEN SOMETHING THAT FIRST RATE
INDIVIDUAL SHOULD BE DOING. IN
ORDER TO. VIRGINIA WITH WITH
MORE DEBT AND I JUST MY FIRST.
ON A BILL LIKE THIS I SAID I
DON'T PLAN TO VOTE FOR TODAY I
WILL NECESSARY GET OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU THIS RACE.
I THINK THE BENEFIT THERE IS I
THINK THE BENEFIT TO THE CHILD
I THINK THAT TO WIN. THE
CHARACTERS INCARCERATED FOR
SUCH A LONG TIME AND IS THEN.
RELEASED THE CHANCES OF
RETURNING TO THEIR CHILD AND
BEING INVOLVED IN A CHILD'S
LIFE IS GREATER AND THEY DON'T
HAVE THE DEBT ON TOP OF THEM. I
DO APPRECIATE APPRECIATE THAT
SAM TO DINO FATHERHOOD TOOK A
STAND ON THIS IS WORLD ARE VERY
IMPORTANT ORGANIZATION IN MY
COMMUNITY AND HAS BEEN WORKING
WITH FATHERS FOR YEARS TO GET
THEM INVOLVED IN THEIR CHILD'S
LIVES- AND MAKING SURE THAT
EVERY POSSIBILITY WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT RECIDIVISM. WE
WANT TO DECREASE RECIDIVISM WE
WANT TO DO WHATEVER IT IS IT'S
POSSIBLE TO. RE INTEGRATE
SOMEONE IS INTO SOCIETY AS BEST
AS POSSIBLE BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY TO RE INTEGRATE
THEM INTO THE LIFE OF THE
CHILD. AND IF HAVING THIS.
TAKEN CARE OF BECAUSE THEY
CANNOT PAY THIS IT THE OF A
CHILD SUPPORT ORDER THERE'S NO
WAY FOR THEM TO PAY IT. AND ALL
WE'RE DOING IS INCREASING THE
DEBT UNNECESSARILY. I DO
APPRECIATE THE COMMENT FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AND IF
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
ADDED I THINK THAT WOULD BE A
WONDERFUL IDEA SO THAT- THAT IT
IS. A FORM OF PAYING A DEBT TO
THEIR CHILD BY. MAKING
THEMSELVES BETTER PARENTS BUT
THE BILL AS IT STANDS ALSO
WE'RE WE'RE STANDING SOMETHING
THAT SOMETHING THAT SUNSET SOON
AND I APPRECIATE TO- IS CARILLO
YOU BRINGING IT FORWARD THANK
YOU. YOU HAVE N. BITS GONZALEZ
I JUST WANT TO KNOW TO YOU HAVE
BROUGHT THAT UP CONSISTENTLYIN
AND I THINK YOU ARE CORRECT.
AND IF WE CAN FIGURE OUT HOW TO
PUT A PROGRAM LIKE THAT. IN THE
PRISONS EFFECTIVELY I THINK
THAT THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING.
SO THAT THAT INDIVIDUAL WOULD
HAVE SOMETHING AT STAKE WHEN
GETTING THE BENEFIT AND I THINK
THAT WOULD GO A LONG WAY TO
RELIEVING THE ISSUE THE MISTER
KILEY BROUGHT UP. THAT WE'RE
WE'RE NOT THEN JUST RELIEVING
TO RELIEVE BUT TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE FINDING A WAY
TO PUT THAT FAMILY BACK
TOGETHER IN A WAY THAT HE CAN.
GET BACK TOGETHER. BUT WE HAVE
A LONG HISTORY OF PROGRAMS THAT
WE PUT IN PLACE LIKE THE BATTER
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS AND OTHER
STATE JUST. AREN'T REALLY
WORKING. IN THE STATE AND IF WE
COULD. HE'LL TAKE A BETTER LOOK
AT THOSE KINDS OF PROGRAMS AND
FOCUS ON ESPECIALLY MEN THERE'S
A GREAT PROGRAM. AS WASREYES
TALKS ABOUT IN WATSONVILLE AREA
POP THAT THAT ADDRESSES YOUNG
MAN ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO'VE
COME OUT OF JAIL AND WHEN THEY
WAKE UP TO WHAT IT IS WHAT
THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES ARE TO
BE PARENTS AT ITS PEER IN FORCE
IN ITS PURE EDUCATED. THE
BENEFITS TO THOSE FAMILIES ARE
ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE SO YES
THIS IS TRYING TO PROVIDE SOME
RELIEF BUT WITHOUT THAT NEXT
STEP OF INSURING. EIGHT EIGHT
DISTRICTS IN THE FAMILY. SO
COMING TO YOU NEXT ANYWAY IT'S
GONZALEZ SO HE COULD CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THAT. ALL RIGHT THIS
COULD REALLY MAKE CLOTHES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I
WANT TO ADDRESS AT SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE. UP
MISTER KILEY TOTALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR QUESTIONS AND WHERE YOU'RE
COMING FROM- MANY OF U HAVE
THE SAME SAME QUESTIONS- BUT IT
TO THE CHAIRS POINT I THINK
SOMETIMES WE HAVE EMOTIONAL
REACTIONS TO. HOW IT IS THAT WE
SEE JUSTICE AND HOW IT IS THAT
WE SEE THOSE THAT ARE CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED ARE BILL DOESN'T
ESTABLISH THE EXCEPTIONS THAT
YOU MENTIONED THOSE ARE PRE
EXISTING. WHAT WE WOULD WANT TO
DO IS EXTEND THE SUNSET EXTEND
THE TIME LIKE BECAUSE IF YOU'RE
MAKING EIGHT CENTS AN HOUR AND
YOUR MANDATED TO PAY CHILD
SUPPORT AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS ALREADY TAKES 55%
OF YOUR EIGHT CENTS. THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY NO WAY THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO PAY YOUR
CHILD SUPPORT- AND YOU'RE GOING
TO GOING TO ADDITIONAL DEBT-
THE COMMENTS MADE BY- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REYES AYE I APPRECIATE
BECAUSE- IN MY DISTRICT. WE
HAVE HOMEBOY INDUSTRIES WHICH
IS AN ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS
WITH FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS MEN AND WOMEN WHO
WISH AND WANT TO DO THAT THAT
VERY BEST THEY CAN TO RE
INTEGRATE BACK INTO SOCIETY TO
BE GOOD PARENTS. AND TO RETURN
TO THEIR FAMILIES I WANT TO.
INVOKE ACTUALLY THE MEMORY OF
BOBBY VERDUGO WAS A CHICANO
RIGHTS- CIVIL JUSTICE LEADER
WHO RECENTLY PASSED INTO THE
LATINO CAUCUS I WAS ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE LAST YEAR WHO IS PART
OF THE NATIONAL COMBAT AT WORK
IN A LEADER IN MY COMMUNITY.
POSSIBLE AND MISSION IS TO HELP
FAMILY INCARCERATED YOUNG MEN
TO THE FAMILIES TO BE GOOD
PARENTS AND ACTUALLY IN MY
COMMUNITY- ESTABLISHED PROGRAMS
MUST CONSOLIDATE TO WHAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO- THAT IT
EFFECTIVELY TAUGHT A YOUNG MAN-
HOW TO BE A GOOD FATHER. ARE IN
IF THEY WEREN'T FATHERS HOW TO
BE GOOD MEN AND THEIR COMMUNITY
AND HOW TO BE GOOD AS BEEN GOOD
FATHERS IN FUTURE THE CHILL TO.
I THINK THOSE ARE INCREDIBLY
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ESPECIALLY IF
YOU COME FROM COMMUNITIES THAT
SUFFERING CREDIBLE. VIOLENCE OR
INCREDIBLE POVERTY AND
SOMETHING THAT I WOULD LOVE TO
ON IN THE FUTURE THE I THINK
IT'S NECESSARY FOR THIS.
IMPRINT ADDING SOMETHING LIKE
THAT- I THINK IN THIS PANDEMIC
THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY LIVING
ACTUALLY WOULD MAKE IT EVEN A
LITTLE BIT HARDER. BECAUSE THEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ALLOCATE
FUNDS. WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS. OR THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES OR WHATEVER
ENTITY IT MAY BE. A TO
ESTABLISH PROGRAMS IN THE
PRISON SYSTEM THAT MAY ACTUALLY
NOT WORK ONCE PEOPLE ARE
RELEASED. SO THAT PROGRAM I
THINK WOULD BE BENEFICIAL. IF
ESTABLISHED ONCE WITHIN YOU
HAVE YOUR CHILD SUPPORT STUFF
VISITATION RIGHTS. TO THE YOUR
CALL CURRENTLY DOING SOMETHING
THAT ALLOWS FOR YOU TO LEARN
OR- HOW TO BE A BETTER. UP
FAMILY INDIVIDUAL WHETHER
YOU'RE A MAN OR A WOMAN- AS YOU
ESTABLISH BACK YOUR
REINTEGRATION BACK TO SOCIETY.
SO I SAY THAT ALL TO SAY THAT
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT WE BEEN
THINKING ABOUT AND HOW DO WE
IMPROVE
THE END OF THE DAY LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCIES AND THE COURTS
ARE ABLE TO COMPLY WITH FEDERAL
RULES AND ARE NOT INUNDATED
WITH UNNECESSARY PAPERWORK OVER
EIGHT CENTS A 55% OF WHICH GOES
BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT. IT
HELPS ACHIEVE THE STATE'S GOALS
THE REDUCING RECIDIVISM
RECIDIVISM RATES AND ULTIMATELY
ENSURES THAT PARENTS ARE ABLE
TO RETURN TO THEIR CHILDREN I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST I. THANK
YOU THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THAT MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE HI
STONE HI GALLAGHER. CHECK OUT.
OUR LIVE TO. TO BUY GUNS ALL.
HOLDEN CALL. FILE. KILEY NOT
NOTING MAIENSCHEIN. OBERNOLTE
OUR OVER NO I REYES ON REYES.
IT HAS FIVE OF. AB TWENTY THREE
NINETY PATTERSON SO OUR NUMBER
SIX IS. THIS DALY WHO IS NOT
HERE SO LET'S GO TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY ONE
AS MR GABRIEL IS HERE. SO I IF
YOU GET A LINE FOR A. TWO TWO
SEVENTY ONE. WELCOME THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR YEAH MEMBERS HI
PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT AB TO
SEVENTY ONE WHICH WILL
STRENGTHEN THE SERGEANT SHRIVER
CIVIL COUNCIL ACT THE SHRIVER
PROGRAM PROVIDES LEGAL
REPRESENTATION TO LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS IN HIGH STAKES
CIVIL MATTERS IMPACTING BASIC
HUMAN NEEDS SUCH AS CHILD
CUSTODY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
EVICTION PROCEEDINGS AS YOU MAY
RECALL LAST YEAR THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED AB THREE THIRTY
BIPARTISAN LEGISLATION WHICH
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDED THE
FRIDAY PROGRAM SO THAT MORE
CALIFORNIANS CAN BE ASSURED OF
MEETING FOR ACCESS TO JUSTICE
THROUGH OUR LEGAL SYSTEM. AB
TWENTY TO SEVENTY ONE BUILT
UPON NOT PROGRESS AND
STRENGTHENS THE SHRIVER PROGRAM
IN TWO IMPORTANT WAYS. FIRST
THISLEGISLATION WILL HELP TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR LEGAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDED UNDER THE
SHRIVER PROGRAM. ACTUALLY MANY
LEGAL SERVICES ORGANIZATIONS
ARE CURRENTLY UNABLE TO PROVIDE
REPRESENTATION TO UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS BECAUSE OF
CONDITIONS ATTACHED TO FEDERAL
FUNDING. THIS LEGISLATION WILL
HELP TO ADDRESS THAT YOU
JUSTICE BY REQUIRING THESE
ORGANIZATIONS TO REFER
IMMIGRANTS FOR SERVICES
ELSEWHERE IF THEY ARE UNABLE TO
PROVIDE THEM. THIS REQUIREMENT
IS BOTH MORAL AND DEEPLY
PRACTICAL ESPECIALLY AT A TIME
WHEN ARE UNDOCUMENTED NEIGHBORS
WHO ARE AMONG THE MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS ARE
BEING DENIED A CENTRAL RELEASED
AND ARE THEREFORE MORE LIKELY
TO NEED THE TYPE OF SERVICES
PROVIDED UNDER THE FIBER
PROGRAM. SECOND THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE COURTS TO COLLECTED
MAKE AVAILABLE CERTAIN BASIC
DATA ABOUT EVICTION PROCEEDINGS
INCLUDING THE NUMBER OF
UNLAWFUL DETAINER ACTIONS FILE
PRESENT CODE. THIS CRUCIAL
INFORMATION WILL ALLOW FOR
IMPROVED RESEARCH AND DATA
DRIVEN POLICY MAKING. INCLUDING
BETTER TARGETING OF LEGAL
SERVICES AND OTHER RESOURCES.
SUCH DATA IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT. GIVEN THE
OVERWHELMING I'M HAVE EVIDENCE
THAT HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION.
IN PARTICULAR STOPPING MORE
CALIFORNIANS FROM SLIPPING INTO
HOMELESSNESS IS KEY TO SOLVING
OUR STATES CRISIS. TO BORROW AN
APT ANALOGY FROM ONE OF THE
SUPPORT LETTERS TRYING TO
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS IN
DISPLACEMENT WITHOUT THE DATA
THAT WOULD BE COLLECTED UNDER
AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY ONE. A
SIMILAR TO ASKING AN
EPIDEMIOLOGIST TO DEVELOP A
PLAN TO FIGHT A VIRAL DISEASE
WITHOUT ADEQUATE TESTING AND
MAPPING. IN SOME AT A TIME OF
TREMENDOUS ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY
AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY ONE WILL
EXPAND ACCESS TO JUSTICE. HOW
PROTECT THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS AND ALL
GOVERNMENTS AND NON PROFITS TO
CRAP DATA DRIVEN RESPONSES TO
OUR HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS APPROACH ARE BRENDA
SHOCKLEY DEPUTY MAYOR OF THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES. CARMEN
MCDONALD. OF LEGAL SERVICES FOR
THE LA CENTER ON LOOK FOR LAW
AND JUSTICE. THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
DON'T. THANK YOU WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES REGISTERED AND BOTH
ARE. WITH THIS TYPE. THIS
SHOCKED. YEAH YES WE GATHER GO
AHEAD. AMERICA THREE YES PLEASE
DO. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. THE ONLY RIGHT HERE YEAH
AND TO THE OTHER MEMBERS OF CAN.
AND THANK YOU TO A MEMBER GAVE
WE ALL FOR OFFERING THE LATEST.
I'M OF THE CITY OF LOS DANCE. I
AM TO WORK WITH THE NAY AND
CITY. AND WE. TO BOB THERE AB
TWENTY TWO S<c.cyan>. ONE THE CITY</c>
OF LOS ANGELES LIKE THE- HAS
BEEN LOOKING CRYING OF HOMELESS.
AND NOW. COLBERT NINETY. WHILE
WE HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
STRIDES IN HOW AND THREE AND
YOU KNOW WE KNOW MARK THAT
OTHERS RECALL IN HOLD WITH.
ALRIGHT WELL ACTUALLY NOT. WE
WELL WILL. EFFORTS TO EDUCATE
AND THAT'S ABOUT THEIR RIGHTS
RESPONSE. WORK WITH LEADING AND
RELATIVE AND LEGAL REPRESENT
AND FIND WITH CONFLICT. TO CREE.
AND SUPPORT LAW TERM. ARE THE
MOST VULNERABLE AND THAT
INCLUDES THE CITY'S DIRECTOR.
IN A MOMENT WELL WE ARE ALL
FAVORITE HOME WE CANNOT ALLOW
ANYONE TO LOSE THEIR WHOLE.
THAT IS WHY THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES EARLY ACTION TO PROTECT
RESIDENTIAL CANNOT MAKING SURE
NO ONE WOULD FACE DETECTION
BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T PAY RARE
AT THE RESULT OF COLD AT
NINETEEN. AS YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA STATE COURT I WALK
WITHOUT VISION COULD BE EATING
UNTIL NINETY DAYS AFTER THE
EMERGENCY IT LET. BUT WE ALL
KNOW WHAT'S COMING. YEAH DANIEL
TO THE HOUSING. HERE BUT THE
PART REPORTS DAY LANDLORDS
CALLING BECAUSE- WHEN THE
MORATORIUM WILL BE OVER SO THAT
THEY CAN BE CARE SERVICE
NOTICES OF THE FICTION. NOW
MORE THAN EVER WE NEED OUR
DIRECTION THE BEST PROGRAM TO
ADDRESS THE TIDAL WAVE OF THE
DICTION WE ARE ANTICIPATING
WHEN THE COURTS OPEN. AND WE
NEED TO TARGET. ADD THIS
LEGISLATION PROVIDE OUR
RESOURCES TO DO THAT AND MUCH
DISPLACEMENT AS HE CAN. JUST
LIKE TO DATE IS. OUR BUDGET
YEAH. SO IF CITY. WE SHOULD.
AND HARDER IT TO ENSURE WE'RE
SPENDING THE DO WHEN YOU THEIR
TAX HERE REPORT IN THE LOOKING
MATTER THAT. THE WHO NEED IT
WELL. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO
SEVEN ONE WILL HELP YEAH THAT.
WITH THE ELECTION FILING DATA
THAT BILL CALLED. RECORDING
CORD PROVIDE TO KNOW OF
UNLAWFULYOUR CASE IS FILED
EACH MONTH. AGGREGATOR BY
DIFFICULT EDUCATE OUT. WE WILL
BE ABLE TO I THE WORD LIKE IT'S
RECKONING COMMUNITY SO THAT WE
CAN FOCUS OUR LIMITED. AND EVEN
OUT OF THE WAY THE- I'LL BE
HALF OF THE CITY OF LOS AND THE
MAYOR AND CITY OF COUNTY.
COUNCIL LEAVE THE POOR AT QUICK
YEAH THE UNIFORM DATA ACROSS
THE STATE. THAT CAN HELP REDUCE
IN. IN THE HOME OF THAT AND
HELP STATE. COMMUNITY. THANK
YOU FOR THE TOPIC. THANK YOU
THE NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
REMEMBER DONALD. HI THERE MY
NAME CARMEN MCDONALD I AM THE
DIRECTOR BECAUSE- BUT THE BUT
THE LOS ANGELES UNDERGROUND ON
JFK. AT THE LA CENTER FOR LAW
AND JUSTICE HE WORKED WITH THE
COURT RT THE JAGGER GAMELY LAW
PROJECT. AND THE GOAL OF A
TRIBE TO PROVIDE ACTIVE TO JUMP
INVISIBLE BEEN. FOR BLOW A
PARTY AND PROVIDE THE FAMILY
LAW BIRTHDAY. OUR DAY ABOUT
BUILDING TO ANY. CALIFORNIA
WILL GUARD THAT THE IMMIGRATION.
AND WE ARE. YOUR TO THE POOR
FOR THE PROGRAM IS CORRECT
STATE COURT ARE OPEN TO ANYONE
I LIVE IN CALIFORNIA IT THIRTY
COURT IF YOU AND SO OUR PROGRAM
ARE AVAILABLE ALTHOUGH INCOME
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR IMMIGRATION. GREAT THANK
YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER SUPPORT JENNIFER
YOURSELF REGISTER SUPPORT. FOR
AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY ONE. RIGHT
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE TELEPHONE WHO'D LIKE TO
IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND REGISTER
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY TO
SEVENTY ONE. LIKE SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK SEVENTY
YOUR LINE OF BEEN OPENED. SORRY
I WAS ON MUTE THIS IS MARCO
GEORGE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION WE
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY
TO SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NO ONE ELSE LIKE TO
REGISTER SUPPORT. LINE ONE ZERO
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. SECOND
TALLEST NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER FOUR. THANK YOU. THIS
REMINDER IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONE MOMENT WHILE I GATHER
INFORMATION FROM THE ADDITIONAL
COMMENTERS.
COMMENT FROM NINE
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU KNOW CAN THE KAISER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION INTO
COURT. NINE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND PLEASE LINE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
TO. CONTACT EQUITY
COLLABORATIVE WEREN'T SUPPORT.
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT CAN QUEUE. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION REGISTERED BUT IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS CONCERNS
FOR NOTE OPPOSITION IF YOU
COULD IDENTIFY YOURSELF. AND
SAY THIS IS FOR AB TWENTY TO
SEVENTY ONE. WE WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
THE ONE MOMENT PLEASE- GATHER
THE INFORMATION FROM THE FIRST
I'M NOT.
NINE ONE ZERO THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE HUNDRED
AND THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE
ON AMERICAN AIRLINES OPEN.
COPPER LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
THREE WOULD LOOK TO MAKE COMMON.
THANK YOU- THIS IS THE AND
DIDN'T EVEN BOMB I AM- CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL CALIFORNIA WE ARE
GRATEFUL TO THE AMENDMENT HAVE
BEEN TAKEN IN THE BUILD SO FAR.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE COUNCIL
HAS VOTED TO OPPOSE- AB TWO TWO
SEVEN ONE IN ITS CURRENT FORM
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE ON FUTURE AMENDMENT.
THANK YOU FOR. THE INTERPRETER
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU READY TO
CLOSE THE LINE ON. AB TWENTY TO
SEVENTY ONE RE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. WELL TO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND THIS
MISTER GIVE REFER BRING IN THE
US- AT. ALTHOUGH I HAD MY
PRIVATE PRACTICE AS AN ATTORNEY
I ALSO VOLUNTEERED WITH OUR
LEGAL AID. AND WE ALWAYS HAVE
TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT WHO WE WERE
HELPING BECAUSE OF THE FUNDING.
AND THERE WERE TIMES WHEN WE
DIDN'T HAVE FUNDING TO HELP OUR
WORK IMMIGRANT. THOSE WHO WHO
WERE UNDOCUMENTED AND SO I
THINK SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS
EXTREMELY POOR TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYBODY IS DIRECTED AND
THEY CAN RECEIVE THE ASSISTANCE
OF THE NEEDS I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. THIS
GATHERED. YES SO. THE TO THE
AUTHOR HAS YOU KNOW UP IN
SUPPORT OF THOSE. OF THE
PROGRAM AND WHAT YOU'VE DONE TO
TRY AND EXPAND IT- IN THE PAST-
SO I'M I'M DEFINITELY SUPPORT
OF. THE REFORM HERE THIS TRYING
TO GET AT THAT ISSUE. THE
COLLECTION OF DATA JUST I
WONDER IF THAT IS. WHAT IT
REALLY TELLS US I MEAN I WAS HE
RIGHT NOW THERE ARE NO
OBJECTIONS HAPPENING FOR THE
PRETTY EXECUTIVE ORDER- SO.
YEAH AS OF RIGHT NOW THERE
WOULD BE ANY OF ACTIONS- YOU
KNOW I I'M ASSUMING AFTER THAT
IT ORDER EXPIRESWE PROBABLY
WILL SEE. SOME OF THE ACTIONS
BUT WHETHER OR NOT A AN
UNLAWFUL DETAINER HAS BEEN
FILED USUALLY THAT'S A LAST
RESORT. YOU KNOW SOMEONE. I
I'VE I BELIEVE IN THE
OVERWHELMING NUMBER OF CASES
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO BE THE
CASE A LANDLORD DOESN'T WANT TO
HAVE TO PROCEED WITH AN
UNLAWFUL DETAINER- IF THEY
DON'T HAVE TO AND IF THEY CAN
WORK THROUGH IT. AND IT ALSO
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN AND HE
MIGHT NOT HAVE UNLAWFUL
DETAINER ACTIONS BUT YOU COULD
STILL HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS
RIGHT- YOU COULD STILL HAVE.
THE OTHER MANY OTHER FACTORS
THAT WEIGH INTO THAT SO. I DO
KIND OF QUESTION WHETHER NOT WE
NEED TO HAVE THIS. COLLECTION
COMPONENT AND WHAT IT REALLY
TELLS US YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF.
BECAUSE AGAIN I THINK IN MY
AREA I COULD HAVE MAYBE NOT
VERY MANY UNLAWFUL RETAINERS
BUT I STILL NEED TO BUILD MORE
HOUSING THIS TO THE PEOPLE- ARE
AVAILABLE TO THOSE UNITS ARE
AVAILABLE FOR PEOPLE TO MOVE
INTO. RIGHT SO I GET MAYBE
SPEAK TO SOME OF THAT YEAH IF
YOU CAN. YEAH MISTER. YEAH I
THINK IT'S A FIX THANK YOU FOR
THE FOR THE COMMENTS IN THE
FEEDBACK AND AGAIN VERY
APPRECIATIVE ACOSTA PART OF AB
THREE THIRTY AND OF THE EFFORTS
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO JUSTICE TO
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS. I
GUESS ON THE- DATA COLLECTION
PIECE YEAH YOU'RE YOU'RE
CORRECT THAT'S THAT'S NOT GOING
TO TELL US THE WITH THE FULL
STORY IS JUST ONE PIECE OF THE
STORY- BUT WHAT I WILL SUGGEST
YOU IS IT'S A PIECE OF THE
STORY THAT THERE IS BROAD
CONSENSUS IS IMPORTANT AND WHAT
I. KNOW FOR YOU IN YOUR PACKET
IS THAT THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS OUR
TENANT RIGHTS ORGANIZATION AS
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS OUR
LEGAL SERVICES NONPROFIT SO. I
THINK THERE IS BROAD CONSENSUS
FROM ORGANIZATIONS THAT OFTEN
AREN'T ON THE SAME PAGE THAT
HAVING THIS DATA IS HELPFUL IN
CRAFTING THOUGHTFUL PUBLIC
POLICY RESPONSES AND SO WE'VE
WORKED WITH THESE ORGANIZATIONS
AS YOU HEARD FROM. THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES THEY THINK THIS
DATA IS A CENTRAL TO HELP
CRAFT- TAKE TO HELP OUR POLICY
AND DEPLOY VERY SCARCE RESOURCE
MISS FIREMEN CERTAINLY THAT
ORGANIZATIONS THE LEGAL
SERVICES ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
PROVIDING THE- REPRESENTATION
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT SO.
IT'S TO TELL US TO BE DO THIS I
DON'T BUT THERE A DAY OUT THERE
THAT COULD NOT. HI BUT I IS
MADE UP WE HOW. IN INFORMING
ALL ECONOMIC BELIEVER THAT DATA
JR POLICY MAKING IS NOT ABOUT
TO GO ABOUT THIS I IN THE
DISCHARGED. I DO WITH RESPECT
TO GET YOU THERE IS BROAD
CONSENSUS BUT THAT'S AND DATA
TO THE WILL HELP IN OUR IN OUR
PART. RIGHT SO THROUGH WHO ON
THE PHONE YOU'RE NOT WOULD YOU
PLEASE YOUR. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
DíAS. RIGHT SIGNAL MR GABRIEL
IN THE CLOTHES. YEAH I THINK
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES- I
WOULD JUST SAY YOU KNOW THIS IS
A ACCESS TO JUSTICE AND
EXPANDING THE FIBER PROGRAM
SOMETHING THAT I'VE FELT VERY
STRONGLY ABOUT FOR A LONG TIME-
EXPANDING TO HELPING TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO UNDOCUMENTED FOLKS I
THINK IS A REALLY ESSENTIAL
STEP. OUT ONE OF THE FIRST
CASES THAT I HANDLED AS A YOUNG
ATTORNEY EXACTLY WHAT THE LA
CENTER ON LAW AND JUSTICE I TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO- YOUNG
WOMAN WHO WAS UNDOCUMENTED WHO
IS TRYING TO SECURE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER IT
WAS REALLY AN EYE OPENING
EXPERIENCE FOR ME HER VIEWS ARE
WISE A CITIZEN I WAS USING HER
STATUS AS SOMETHING AS LEVERAGE
AGAINST HER- IS IT SOMETHING
THAT WAS MAKING HER TERRIFIED
ABOUT THE PROSPECT OF LOSING
HER CHILD. AND PUT HER IN A
REALLY UNTENABLE POSITION
INTEREST EXPOSED ME TO THE
EXTRAORDINARY VULNERABILITY BUT
A LOT OF UNDOCUMENTED FOLKS IN
OUR SOCIETY FACE WITHOUT ACCESS
TO JUSTICE WITHOUT LEGAL
REPRESENTATION SO I THINK THIS
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD I THINK THE DATA PIECE
IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO THE
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION AND
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
DRIVE A- THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. STONE FIVE STONE HI
GALLAGHER. CHECK OUT RIGHT CHAO
HIGH. TO GONZALEZ THOSE AYE
HOLDEN KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
NOW. REYES REYES I. HAS FIVE
VOTES. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WILL
PUT THAT BELONG CALL. THANK YOU.
RIGHT TEXAS STATE I DON'T
NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY FIVE IN THE STYLE. SO
AFRAID RICAN OVER THE PHONE
LINES FOR AB. TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY FIVE. IT FOR THOSE
WITNESSES WHO ARE CALLING IT IF
YOU WERE NOT ACTUALLY SPEAKING
WE WOULD APPRECIATE IF YOU
WOULD BE YOUR PHONES THANK YOU
THIS DALY WELCOME. WELL HI.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN
BY THINKING THE COMMITTEES
CONSULTANT FOR THEIR DILIGENT
WORK. AB. TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
FIVE AS A SIMPLE AND
STRAIGHTFORWARD FIX TO EXISTING
LAW ON PARENTAGE CASES. BASED
ON NINETEEN SEVENTIES LAW THERE
IS NO LONGER SOCIALLY RELEVANT
ALL PAPERS RECORDS AND HEARINGS
PERTAIN TO PARENTAGE ACTIONS.
INVOLVING I'M MARRIED OR SINGLE
PARENTS ARE CONFIDENTIAL EXCEPT
FOR THE FINAL JUDGMENT. THIS
REQUIRES A LEVEL OF SECRECY AND
CHILD CUSTODY AND CHILD SUPPORT
CASES INVOLVING I'M MARRIED OR
SINGLE PARENTS THAT IS NOT
REQUIRED IN KC IN CASES.
INVOLVING MARRIED OR FORMALLY
MARRIED PARENTS. IT CREATES AN
ANALYSIS IT CREATES UNNECESSARY
RESTRICTIONS ON ACCESS TO CASE
FILES INHERITED CASES THE OUGHT
TO BE PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE AS
THEY ARE IN DIVORCE AND CUSTODY
CASES. FOR EXAMPLE IN CHECK
CHILD SUPPORT AND CUSTODY CASES
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES A COURT TO
CONSIDER PAST ACTIONS A
DIVESTITURE BY LET'S BY PARENTS
IN DECIDING CASSIDY. INCLUDING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AGAINST A
CHILD OR CO PARENT WHO IS NOT
PARTY TO THE CURRENT
PROCEEDINGS. BUT DUE TO THE
CURRENT COMPANY GEOLOGY OF
PARENTAGE CASES ANY EVIDENCE OR
ALLEGATIONS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CONTAINED IMPERATIVE
ACTIONS ARE NOT ACCESSIBLE TO A
PRIOR OR SUBSEQUENT PARENTAL
PARTNER. BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
PARTY TO THE PARENTAGE ACTIONS
AND THOSE CASE FILES ARE
SEALED. THE ONLY WAY TO OBTAIN
INFORMATION FROM THESE FILES IS
AN EXCEPTIONAL SITUATIONS UPON
AN ORDER FROM THE COURT WHICH
IS A LONG EXPENSIVE AND DRAWN
OUT PROCESS. THIS UNDERMINES
THE GOAL THE CURRENT CHILD
SUPPORT IT COSTS A LOT AND AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FIVE
PROPOSES THE SIMPLE THINGS.
THIS BILL WILL REMOVE THE
REQUIREMENT THAT PARENTS JUST
CASES INVOLVING I'M MARRIED OR
SINGLE PARENTS BE KEPT
CONFIDENTIAL. EXCEPT IN CASES
INVOLVING ASSISTED
REPRODUCTION. THIS EXEMPTION
WAS NEGOTIATED WITH MY STAFF
AND THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
TO ACCOMMODATE CONCERNS FROM
THE OPPOSITION IN CONCERT WITH
THE COMMITTEE STAFF I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FIVE.
WITH ME TODAY ON THE PHONE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
IS JUST MCCONNELL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
BILL SPONSORED. THANK YOU SO WE
DO HAVE ONE WITH THIS WITH US
ON THE TELEPHONE. JUSTIN
O'CONNELL PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME
CURRENT YES WE CAN'T. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY DISCUSS AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FIVE MY NAME
IS JUSTIN O'CONNELL I'M AN
ATTORNEY IN PRIVATE PRACTICE IN
MONTEREY CALIFORNIA CERTIFIED
FAMILY LAW SPECIALIST BUT STATE
BAR OF CALIFORNIA. AND THE
LEGISLATION CHAIR FOR THE
FAMILY LAW SECTION THE
CALIFORNIA LAWYERS ASSOCIATION.
WHICH SPONSORS THE BILL. AB.
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FIVE
WILL ELIMINATE CONFIDENTIALITY.
ASSOCIATE WITH PACKAGE ACTIONS
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF ASSISTED
REPRODUCTION ACTION ACTIONS
WHICH SHALL REMAIN UNCHANGED.
IN DOING SO IT WILL. MAKE
PARENTAGE FILED ACCEPTABLE TO
PARENTS THE COUNCIL AND IMPORT
AND- WILL PROMOTE REPORT PUBLIC
POLICY CONSIDERATIONS AT THE
CURRENT LAW STANDS THE RECORD
HEARINGS ARE CONFIDENTIAL UNDER
FAMILY COULD SECTION TWENTY
SEVENTY SIX FORTY THREE WHICH
SHOULD NOT APPLY TO MARITAL
DISSOLUTION LEGAL SEPARATION
ACTIONS. THIS IS A COMPONENT OF
THE NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE PAIR
UNIFORMED PARA TO JACK AS
ADOPTED BY CALIFORNIA NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE. AND AT THAT TIME
THERE WERE FEWER BIRTH OUTSIDE
OF MARRIAGE AND THEY'RE JUST IT
BROUGHT TO KEEP EGGMAN NATION
OF ON WHAT MOTHERS AND THEIR
CHILDREN. HERITAGE ACTION FOR
MAY CONFIDENTIAL FOR THAT
REASON. NOW FORTY FIVE YEARS
LATER STUDY NO LONGER HOLD
THOSE VIEWS OF ON WHAT MOTHERS
AND CHILDREN THE ANTIQUATED
JUSTIFICATION FOR
CONFIDENTIALITY NO LONGER
EXISTS. AS NOTED BEFORE THEIR
HURDLES AND OBSTACLES TO
OBTAINING INFORMATION IN
CALCUTTA DETERMINATION AS WELL
AS CHILD SUPPORT TERMINATION
BECAUSE OF CONFIDENTIALITY.
THERE IS NO JUSTIFICATION FOR
THE LAW TO TREAT PARENTS
JACKSON'S DIFFERENTLY THAN
MARITAL DISSOLUTION AND LEGAL
SEPARATION ACTIONS. AB TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FIVE WILL
PROVIDE EQUAL ACCESS ALREADY
AFFORDED TO THIS OTHER ACTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. RIGHT NOW IS THE TIME WAS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEAR THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO REGISTER SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FIVE. RIGHT
SIGNAL AND IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE TELEPHONE. WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE THEIR SUPPORT FOR
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FIVE YOU
CAN GIVE US YOUR- NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION PLEASE. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE ONE ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. THE FAMILY
HAD NO COMMENT CAN QUEUE. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WE DO HAVE ONE
REGISTERED OPPOSITION THE REAL
WORLD. YEAH GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS DOUBLE WALL
THE MORNING- THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK BRIEFLY- MY NAME IS
DOUBLE WALL THEN I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH OVER THIRTY YEARS
IN PRACTICE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO A CERTIFIED
FAMILY LAW. SPECIALIST THANK
YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLAIN TO YOU
WHY THE ACADEMY OF CALIFORNIA
ADOPTION AND THE FIFTH SHOULD
BE PRODUCTION ATTORNEYS. FEEL
SO STRONGLY THAT AB TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY FIVE NEEDS TO BE
AMENDED TO KEEP IT THE DEGREE
PRODUCTION JUDGMENTS
CONFIDENTIAL. I FITTED
REPRODUCTION CASES ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT FROM
OTHER PARENTAGE CASES FOR AT
LEAST THREE READ THAT. PART
BECAUSE UNLIKE OTHER PARENTAGE
CASES THEY ALMOST ALWAYS ARE
UNCONTESTED. SECOND BECAUSE IN
ORDER TO CARRY OUT THE TERMS OF
THE JOHN ARE ENSURING THAT THE
AGREEMENT INTO WHICH THE
PARTIES HAVE ENTERED THE
PARTIES HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO
GO TO COURT TO CONFIRM THEIR
RESPECTIVE ROLES AT PARENTS.
DON'T ARE THERE I GET IT
CETERA. AND THIRD BECAUSE THE
PACKAGE JUDGE MAHON AND
ASSISTED REPRODUCTION MATTERS
TYPICALLY AND THE LITIGATION
BECAUSE THERE IS NO DISPUTE
BETWEEN THE PARTIES AND NOTHING
FURTHER SUCH A COMPANY LIKE
CHILD SUPPORT REQUIRING. THE
COURT'S ATTENTION. THE OWNER SO
I GET ALL YOU KNOW. DONATED
JEFF DATED ON CONDITION THAT
THEIR STATUS AS NON PARENTS
WOULD BE PROTECTED AND ALSO ON
CONDITION THAT THEIR DONATION
BUDGET STATION WOULD BE KEPT
CONFIDENTIAL. THESE PROMISES
GENERALLY WERE INTEGRAL TO THE
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE PARTIES
AND EMBODIED IN A WRITTEN
CONTRACT. THE CONFIDENTIALITY
WE ARE SPEAKING AS A POTENTIAL
CAN MAINTAINING THE INTEGRITY
OF THE CONTRACT. THERE'S NO WAY
TO CRAFTED THIS KID
REPRODUCTION JUDGMENT TO
PROVIDE EVERYONE WITH A WITH
THE LEGAL PROTECTION THEY ARE
SPEAKING. WITHOUT ACCURATELY
IDENTIFYING THEM IN THE
JUDGMENT. THEREFORE IF THE
JUDGMENT IS NOT CONFIDENTIAL
THE PARTIES IDENTITIES NO
LONGER WILL BE CONFIDENTIAL
EITHER THAT FAILING TO KEEP THE
JUDGMENT CONFIDENTIAL UNDERMINE
ONE OF THE PRIMARY PURPOSES OF
THE CAKE THAT IS TO ALLOW THE
DONORS AND SIR I GET TO GO ON
WITH THEIR LIVES WITHOUT
UNNECESSARY DISRUPTION. WITHOUT
THAT CONFIDENTIALITY THERE'S A
LIKELIHOOD THAT DONORS WILL NOT
DONATE LEAVING FOR EXAMPLE MORE
EMBRYOS CRYO PRESERVED. AND
MORE INFERTILE PEOPLE WITHOUT
OPTIONS FOR HAVING CHILDREN.
AND PARENTS WILL BE STRIPPED OF
THE RIGHT TO TELL THEIR
CHILDREN THAT STORY BUT DON'T
WORRY JAN IN THE TIMELY MANNER
DAY DEEMED DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
A VERY HIGH PROFILE EXAMPLE OF
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT PLAYING
OUT IN THE MEDIA. ANDERSON
COOPER RECENTLY BECAME A
FATHER. AND ANNOUNCED HIS
PATERNITY ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION AND HE'S PUBLICLY
THANK TO THIRD GET WITHOUT
AGAIN TO FIND HER. STOP
ANYTHING FOR MOMENT WHAT WOULD
HAPPENED HAD ANDERSON COOPER
COURT JUDGMENT MAKING HIM A
LEGAL FATHER INTO THIRD GET NOT
A LEGAL MOTHER. BEEN MADE
PUBLIC ANY IF YOU DOUBT THAT
THE MEDIA WOULD BE CAMPED OUT
ON HIS SURROGATE SPOT MON RIGHT
NOW HOPING TO GET PICTURES OF
HER AND HER HUSBAND AND THEIR
CHILDREN. THE ACADEMY RESPECT
COMMITTEE POSITION THAT IS THE
GENERAL RULE FAMILY COURT
PROCEEDINGS SHOULD BE PUBLIC.
BUT WHAT ALL PARTIES ENTER INTO
A WRITTEN AGREEMENT BY WHICH
THEY ALL AGREE THAT SOME OF
THEM WILL BE PARENT THAN OTHERS
WELL NOT AND THEIR- PRIVACY AND
CONFIDENTIALITY WILL BE
RESPECTED. HOW IS THE PUBLIC
INTEREST START BY UNDERMINING
DOES AGREEMENT. WHAT MONTH BY
IS ALRIGHT ADDED FAMILY CODE
SECTION SEVENTY SIX FORTY THREE
POINT FIVE. APPLICABLES ONLY TO
ASSISTED REPRODUCTION CASES
THAT MAINTAINS THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF THESE
SPECIFIC CASES WHILE THE OTHER
TYPE THE POUNDAGE CASES ARE
MADE PUBLIC THE ONLY CHANGE WE
ARE REQUESTING. THAT THE
JUDGMENT IN THESE SPECIFIC
CASES ALSO BE DEEMED
CONFIDENTIAL COMPARABLE TO
ADOPTION JUDGMENT WITH LONG
HAVE BEEN CONFIDENTIAL. SO IT'S
NOT THAT UNDERMINE THE ENTIRE
PURPOSE OF SECTION SEVENTY SIX
FORTY THREE POINT FIVE. THIS IS
A SIMPLE FACT AND WE HOPE WILL
HAVE YOUR SUPPORT IN MAKING IT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WOULD
ANYONE ELSE TO REGISTER. UP ON
A TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FIVE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE. IT WAS
FIRST WAS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEEING NONE IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE. THEY
SEE THIS YOUR NAME GOOD LUCK TO
MAKE. I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THE TIME. THE TIME THEY'RE
NOT COMING THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU I WILL. FREE BACK TO
THE DICE IF THERE ARE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT SEEING
NONE- I WILL NOTE THAT FROM THE
OPPOSITION THE WE DID THERE ARE
AMENDMENTS IN THE BILL GET THAT
EXAM THESIS REPRODUCTION CASES
FROM PUBLIC DISCLOSURE BUT WITH
THE TASK IS WHICH IS BEYOND THE
SCOPE OF THIS BILL IS TO TAKE A
FINAL JUDGMENT WHICH IS
CURRENTLY. PUBLIC AND MAKE IT
CONFIDENTIAL AND THAT IS BEYOND
THE SCOPE OF REALLY OF THIS
BILL. RIGHT SALLY MAE CLUBS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME SAY AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU LOOKING FOR A
MOTION BUT THANK YOU. YOU HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND THAT
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. STONE HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I SHOW SO
BY TWO. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN KALRA KALRA KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
I REYES- REYES AYE. HAS SEVEN
THE BILL IS APT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SO LET'S MOVE TO
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTEEN THIS TO GLORIA.
IF YOU COULD OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR. AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTEEN. MORE MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS. AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTEEN AIMS TO HELP
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
TO EXPERIENCE FINANCIAL ABUSE
BY ESTABLISHING SOME
PROTECTIONS THE COURT CAN USE
IN DETERMINING WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR PAYING OFF
INCURRING DEBT- YOU MAY KNOW
THAT FINANCIAL ABUSE OCCURS IN
99% OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES
IT CAN INCLUDE STEALING MONEY A
CREDIT PROPERTY IN IDENTITY OF
A ABUSED PARTNER. CAN ALSO
INCLUDE FORCED A PARTNER INTO
FILING FRAUDULENT LEGAL FILE
FINANCIAL DOCUMENTS OVER
SPENDING ON CREDIT CARDS THE
PIECE OF PARTNERS CAN IN KERR
DEAD WITHOUT AT SURVIVOR AND
ABUSED PARTNER CAN OCCUR DAD
WITHOUT OF SURVIVORS CONSENT-
OR COERCED SO- SURVIVOR INTO
INCURRING DEBT BY THREATS OF
HARM. THIS DEBT AND THE CREDIT
SCORE IMPACT COULD HAVE LONG
TERM CONSEQUENCES FOR SURVIVORS
PREEN BEARS TO EDUCATIONAL
HOUSING AND EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES SINCE THESE DEBTS
ARE ENCOURAGED THROUGH THE
ABUSIVE PARTNER STEALING THE
SURVIVORS IDENTITY IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR SURVIVORS TO HAVE%
THE TOOLS TO ACCESS EXISTING
FEDERAL AND STATE PROTECTIONS
FOR IDENTITY THEFT AND DEBT
DEFENSE. CURRENTLY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS
ALLOW THE JUDGE TO ASSIGN
SPECIFIC DEBT TO BE PAID BY THE
RESTRAINT PARTY BY PATTING THE
SPACE FOR THE JUDGE TO ALSO
IDENTIFY WHICH DEBTS WERE
INCURRED BECAUSE OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND THROUGH THEFT OF
SURVIVORS IDENTITY THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW THE SURVIVOR TO USE
THE RESTRAINING ORDER AS
DOCUMENTATION OF CIVIL DEBT
RELIEF PROTECTIONS. AS WELL-
THE COOPER NOT INTENDED MAKE
HAS DEEP IN THE ECONOMIC
HARDSHIPS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING
SURVIVORS AND THEIR FAMILIES
THESE ECONOMIC VULNERABILITIES
SURVIVORS AT RISK OF ANY
FURTHER INTO POVERTY OR
RETURNING TO THEIR USE OF
PARTNER. STEP THAT WE CAN TAKE
OF THE SLATED TO ECONOMIC
SECURITY FOR SURVIVORS WILL
HELP KEEP THEM SAFE DURING
ALREADY MULTI. WITH ME DID IT
FIND SUPPORT IS CHRIS THAT
NAMES WITH THE CALIFORNIA PAR
TO INTO VIOLENCE AND ERIC V.
HARDER- WITH THE- RIGHT THANK
YOU I HAVE A NOTE THAT YOU'RE-
WITNESSES ARE ON IT.
TELECONFERENCE OR THE ON THE
WANTED BY IS TELEPHONE. RESTART
BELIEVES ON PHONE. OKAY SO
CHRIS THE ARE YOU ON THE PHONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- MY
NAME IS KRISTEN I'M BACK WITH A
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP AND LEFT
THE BALANCE OF MORE PROUD
SPONSOR AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTEEN. SO WE WILL TAKE
IMPORTANT THAT. YOU DO A JOB
THE ECONOMIC THAT YOU'VE BEEN
FINANCIAL CHALLENGES BUT NICK
AND OF PROVIDERS. OUTLOOK ON
THE NUMBER GLORIA JUST REFERRED
TO BE OFFICIALLY THERE EVEN
MORE URGENT NOW WITH SO MANY AT
THE BY VERY. STARTLING
FINANCIALLY YOU THE CLIP THAT
NINETEEN IMPACT THAT WE KNOW
WILL BE A LONG LASTING. AND
IT'LL BE ONE OF THE MOST
POWERFUL NOT GOOD FOR KEEPING A
SURVIVOR TRAPPED IN A FEW
RELATIONSHIPS. IT GREATLY
DIMINISHES WITH SURVIVORS
ABILITY TO MAINTAIN THEIR STATE
WE AFTER THEY DO AND FINANCIAL
COMPLAINED THAT THE NUMBER ONE
REASON I COULD EITHER STAY IN
OR RETURN. IT BUT- EVERY STEP
WE CAN. A JOB OF THE THAT
FIFTY. AT EIGHT O'CLOCK
STRAINING ALL ALLOW JUDGES
INCLUDED FOR CHANGE PARTY EIGHT
ANGELA PUBLIC. BUILDING ON THE
TO ALLOWED TO JUST WITH TO MAKE
FINDING WITH THAT OF THE
AFFECTED THAT RIGHT HEARD OTHER
OF COLLISION RIGHT THEFT OF OUR
TO BE USED. PROVIDE THE OPTION
SURVIVOR AND THEN YOU THAT AS
I'VE BEEN FOR THAT RE AND- THAT
PLUS. OF THE- DEATHS THAT WERE
HEARD ABOUT THEIR YOUR THE
CORPORATION. I'M PARTY THAT YOU.
HELP US I BELIEVE. PROVIDE CARE
BY VERY OFTEN TO USE YOU
THOUGHT CARD BUT THEY IN ON THE
THEY DID NOT KNOW TO HER WILL
INCREASE AND THEN SECURITY THAT
ALSO. QUITE NOT AND USING
FINALLY AND THAT THERE'S ASK
I'VE THANK YOU. JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ERICA VERY
JURADO AND FOR I GET STARTED I
LIKE TO ALSO JUST SAY THAT IF
IT'S AN R. SPEAK FOR ALL OF YOU
AND ALSO TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TODD GLORIA FOR BRINGING
THE- LASTING IMPACT OF
FINANCIAL ABUSE. ON SURVIVOR
STILL FOR. SO AS MENTIONED I
HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF ASSISTING
FAMILY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS ON A DAILY BASIS AS A
STAFF ATTORNEY FOR WE'VE IN
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA. ONE
RECENT CLIENT I HAD WAS A
ELDERLY WOMAN OUR FOR TWO AS
OUT. NOW EL MARRIED. A MAN MORE
FOR TO ASK OUR- AND SHE WOULD
EVENTUALLY CALL HIM HUSBAND FOR
OVER TEN YEARS. HE WAS HER
HUSBAND WHEN HE CHASED HER
AROUND THEIR HOME WITH A
FIREARM. HE WAS HER HUSBAND
WHEN HE TOOK A HAMMER TO. THE
PORTION OF WALL JUST INCHES
FROM HER HEAD. AND HE WAS STILL
HER HUSBAND WHEN HE SHOWED UP
TO HER SISTERS RESIDENTS IN A
CHEAP DISGUISE. AND BRENT TO
KILL HER AND HAD TO BE ARRESTED
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT HE WAS FOUND
ARMED WITH A KNIFE. NOW EL NO
LONGER CALLS ARE HER HUSBAND
ANYMORE AND SHE'S DONE A LOT TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH HER LIFE BUT
THERE'S ONE THING THAT SHE
CAN'T ESCAPE TO THIS DAY. AND
DURING HER BE ABUSIVE RELATED
MARRIAGE WITH OUR- SHE HAD CO
L. HE OF COURSE L. INTO SIGNING
OVER THE TITLE OF HER HOME
WHICH SHE ACQUIRED PRIOR TO HER
MARRIAGE TO HIM. HE THEN PART
AGAINST AT HOME WITHOUT ELSE
CONSENT. WHILE WE WERE ABLE TO
ASSIST THE CLIENT WITH GETTING
TITLES WERE HOME BACK. DEREK
THAT CAME WITH EXTENSIVE DEBT
DEBT WHICH EL IS STILL. DEALING
WITH BECAUSE THERE IS NO CLEAR
RECOGNITION THAT THIS DEBT WAS
WEAPONIZED AGAINST HER. TO
CONTINUE ABUSING HER LONG AFTER
HER RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR AND
IT. NOW THE MAIN THRUST MY
TESTIMONY TODAY IS TO SAY THAT
L. IS NOT ALONE THERE ARE MANY
MORE SURVIVORS WHO ARE SADDLED
WITH DEBT AS PART OF SUSTAIN
PATTERNS OF ABUSE INTIMIDATION
AND EXTORTION. LESTAT FOLLOW
SURVIVORS FOR YEARS AFTER THEY
HAVE ESCAPED AN ABUSIVE
RELATIONSHIP AND KEEPS THEM
FROM GETTING SAFE HOUSING.
TRANSPORTATION AND EVEN
EMPLOYMENTS. THIS COMMITTEE CAN
TAKE A BOLD STEP IN SUPPORT OF
SURVIVORS LIKE L. BY SUPPORTING
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTEEN. THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW JUDGES TO MAKE FACTUAL
FINDINGS THAT IDENTIFY SPECIFIC
DEBT FOR WHAT IT IS. A B. X.
THIS FINDING MAY HELP SURVIVORS
NEGOTIATE WITH CREDITORS AND
FIND A FINANCIAL FRESH START
THAT THEY NEED AFTER WALKING
AWAY FROM ABUSIVE SITUATION.
ACTUALLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE AND
ALLOW THIS BILL TO PROCEED FROM
ANY QUESTIONS I AM A BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US. RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE
ON IN THE CHAMBERS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO. OFFER SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL. SEEING NONE IS THERE ARE
THERE ANYONE ON THE TELEPHONE
LINES. WHO WOULD LIKE TO OFFER
SUPPORT FOR TWENTY FIVE AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTEEN THIS IS
YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND INDICATE YOUR
SUPPORT. THE FIRST PANEL
COMPLAIN OF ONE HUNDRED AND TWO
YOU CAN GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CAN
BALLOTS NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKER CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER AND FOR. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE ZERO SIX PLEASE GO
SIXTY LINE'S BEEN OPENED.
DANIELLE CANDOR CARTER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. FOR THE
REMAINDER OF A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. THE
TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT.
THANK YOU WE WILL THEN MOVE TO
OPPOSITION WE HAVE ONE. ON THE
TELEPHONE MR PAGE. MISTER
CHAIRMAN CLEARING YES WE CAN. I
WOULD DISAGREE EIGHT- MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
GREAT PAGE OF EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT COUNCIL THE
CALIFORNIA LAND TITLE SOLUTION
WE REPRESENT THE TITLE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY CALIFORNIA.
THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM WE
HAD EARNS ABOUT. OFTEN IT DID
PROPERTY LIENS HAVING SAID THAT
WE HAD- RECENTLY HAD A VERY
PRODUCTIVE CALLED SPONSORS
AUTHOR STAFFING COMMITTEES THAT
OUT AND WE HAVE OFFERED AN
AMENDMENT THAT WE BELIEVE WILL
FURTHER THE GOAL OF THE BILL TO
ALLOCATE THAT BUT- WE'VE THEIR
UNDERLYING LEAN AUG AND HACKED-
WE LOOK FORWARD TO. WHILE
WORKING WITH. WHAT THE AUTHOR
SPONSOR IN COMMITTES HAPPENED
A FEW OF WHAT WE GET OUT THE
CORPORATE. GREAT THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE THIRTY ONE OF
THE CHAMBERS WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER OPPOSITION. RIGHT SEE
NINE THIRTY ONE ON THE ON THE
PHONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER OPPOSITION GIVE US
YOUR NAME YOUR AFFILIATION. AND
YOUR OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AT THE
TIME WE HAVE NO COMMON IN Q.
RIGHT. THANK YOU BRING BACK TO
READING QUESTIONS COMMENTS THIS
GALLAGHER. YEAH SO I'M I'M IN
AGREEMENT WITH THE- WITH THE
BILL- WHAT IS TRYING TO DO I
THINK ONE SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT COME UP IS. CERTAINLY I
DON'T THINK THAT THE DEBT
SHOULD APPLY TO A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VICTIM. BUT THAT DEBT
SHOULD STILL 1100% APPLY TO THE
ABUSER. SO ENSURING THAT. YOU
KNOW YEAH THAT IS WHAT ENDS UP
HAPPENING IS. PROVISIONS IN THE
BILL THAT ADDRESS THAT. AND
THEY DON'T SIMPLY LIKE TO TAKE
50% OF THE DEBT OFF. NO ONE
REALLY THE PERSON THAT. YOU
KNOW COMMITTED THE ABUSE AND
CREATED THIS FRAUD ESSENTIALLY
SHOULD BE A 100% RESPONSIBLE
THEN FOR THE DEATH AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY I KNOW THE LAND TITLE
ASSOCIATION IS BROUGHT UP SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT. YOUR REAL
PROPERTY AND- OBVIOUSLY THE
LENDER. DOESN'T KNOW- YOU KNOW
THAT THIS IS GOING ON AND SO IF
THERE LEAN MORE TO GET
COMPLETELY INVALIDATED THAT
WOULD BE A PROBLEM- YOU KNOW
GOING FOR THAT SO MAYBE IF YOU
COULD ADDRESS SOME OF THE ITEMS
ABSOLUTELY NO APPRECIATE THE
CHANCE TO TAKE THAT ON- AND-
YEAH OPPOSITION SHARED A
RECEIVE THEIR- FEEDBACK ON
FRIDAY AND WE'VE ALREADY BEEN
IN COMMUNICATION AND- HOPE TO
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS- THEIR
CONCERNS BEFORE. I DO YOU SEE
THIS IN ANY OTHER SETTING ONE
APPRECIATE- THE CHAIRMAN AND
HIS STAFF- FOR BEING- PARTNERS
IN AN EFFORT TO GET TO ADDRESS
THEIR TITLE CONCERNS- WITH
REGARD TO YOUR QUESTION-
SEPTEMBER GALLAGHER THE DEBT
WOULD BE BECOME SOMETHING THAT
THE COURT WOULD DECIDE HOW WE
WOULD BE THE JUDICATA SO JUDGES
ARE YOU HAVE THE ABILITY- IN
THESE PROCEEDINGS- TWO TO.
ASSIGN THIS RESPONSIBILITY BUT
THE POINT OF THIS IS THAT IT
BASICALLY ALLOWS FOR MORE
JUDICIAL DISCRETION IN THIS
PROCESS- AND- WE CAN CERTAINLY
WORK IF YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL
SUGGESTIONS ON ON HOW TO GET IT
WHERE YOU WANT TO GO I SHARE
YOUR YOUR OVERALL OBSERVATION
WHO SHE TALKED COUNTABLE- BUT
WHAT WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT
THEY SHOULD NOT A SHE SAID
BEAR. RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
SURVIVOR- IN THIS BILL RESETS
THAT HE WILL LIVE WE HAVE MORE.
THE DIRECTION FOR THEM. OTHER
QUESTIONS ARE. SEEING NONE TO
GLORY YOU MAY CLOSE I THINK
IT'S CHEN AND I WANT TO EXPRESS
IS A OF SIX SEVENTEEN THAT
COMMITTEES AND TODAY OF THE OF
IMPLEMENTATION DATING AND KIND
OF LANGUAGE WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO WORK AND I COMMIT
TO CONTINUE TO WORK- WITH THAT
THE OPPOSITION TO FIND A PATH
FOR TO HOPEFULLY WE CAN DO THAT
ASSEMBLY RESPECTFULLY ASK
FIGURE I'VE LEARNED THIS
LEGISLATION THIS MORNING. THANK
YOU. FOR A MOTION. THANK YOU
THAT MOTION IS TO AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ALL THE WORLD.
STONE HI STONE HI GALLAGHER
GALLAGHER AYE JOE SHALL I TO.
IN THE- CONTROLS AYE HOLDEN
KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
I REYES ON. REYES AYE. HAS
SEVEN THAT LEVELS OUT SIGNATURE
PAGE NUMBERS. THE LIST WOULD BE
MISSED IRWIN. HERE MISTER KALRA
ARE YOU READY PERCENT. RIGHT
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER TEN AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY TWO ALSO
OPERATOR COULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY TWO ESTABLISHES DORMANCY
TRIGGERS BY WHICH AN UNPLANNED
FUNERAL TRUST ACCOUNT SHEETS TO
THE STATE I CAN BE LOCATED BY
NEXT OF KIN. GENERAL TRUST
ACCOUNTS OF FUNDS HELD IN TRUST
BY FUNERAL ESTABLISHMENTS FOR
PROMISED FUNERAL MERCHANDISE
AND SERVICES. TO BE PROVIDED
AFTER THE BENEFICIARIES DEATH.
USUALLY THE DISEASE'S STATE
CONTACTS A FUNERAL
ESTABLISHMENT NOR TO FULFILL
THE AGREEMENT PROFESSIONALS.
HOWEVER IN CASE FOR THE STATE
IS NOT AWARE OF THE TRUST AND
IS NOT OF BILL THE SERVICES
PROMISED AND PAID FOR THE TRUST
ACCOUNT CAN LIE DORMANT
INDEFINITELY DESPITE THE DEATH
OR PRESUMED DEATH THE
BENEFICIARY. AT THE END OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THERE OVER
ONE THOUSAND LICENSED FUNERAL
ESTABLISHMENTS REGULATED BY THE
CEMETERY AND FUNERAL BUREAU.
AND THESE FUNERAL ESTABLISHED
IN SUPPORT OF HOLDING FIVE
HUNDRED NINETY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN FREE NEED CONTRACT
FUNDS FOR CONSUMERS. FURTHER
THE BUREAU IS AWARE OF A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX FUNERAL
ESTABLISHMENTS THAT HAVE GONE
OUT OF BUSINESS YET TRUSTEES
REPORTED HOLDING AND EARNING
COME FROM MORE THAN SIXTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN CONSUMER PRE
NEED TRUST ACCOUNTS. CURRENT
LAWS REGULATING PRE NEED
FUNERAL COUNTS BY LICENSED
FUNERAL ESTABLISHMENTS ONLY
INSURE THE FUNDS FOR
MERCHANDISE AND SERVICES ARE
AVAILABLE AT THE TIME OF DEATH.
AS A FORM OF INTANGIBLE
PROPERTY THESE ACCOUNTS FALL
UNDER OUR STATE UNCLAIMED
PROPERTY LAW. BUT THESE
BUSINESSES ARE NOT REQUIRED. TO
HAVE CONSISTENT CONTACT WITH
THE OWNER OF RECORD NOR
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED HANDLING
OF THE BAND IN TRUST ACCOUNTS.
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY TWO
WOULD CLARIFY THE PARTY
RESPONSIBLE FOR REPORTING
ABANDONED TRUST ACCOUNTS.
OUTLINED DORMANCY TRIGGERS TO
PRESUME THE DEBT THE
BENEFICIARY. AND ESTABLISHED
REQUIREMENTS FOR CONTEXT OWNERS
A PRE NEED FUNERAL TRUST
ACCOUNTS. FURTHER FUNERAL HOMES
WILL BE ENTITLED TO A SPECIFIED
REPLICATION PEOPLE IN THE TRUST
ACCOUNT. GOES BACK TO THE STATE.
I'M ON THE TRUST ACCOUNT
TRANSFERS THE STATE IS
UNCLAIMED PROPERTY. FUNERAL
SERVICES WILL BE RELIEVED OF
LIABILITY IS A DORMANT ACCOUNTS
AND ANY DUTY TO LOCATE AND
ESTABLISH CONTACT WITH ANY
SURVIVING HERE. AS A COMMITTEE
AND ALSO STATES THIS BILL IS
PLUGGING OF LONG STANDING GAP
IN CALIFORNIA LAW. CONSTRUCTIVE
DIALOUE CONTINUES WITH THE
CEMETERY AND MILITARY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND I
WANT TO THANK THEM. OF FOR
WORKING SO CLOSELY OF THE
STRESS IN THEIR CONCERNS AND-
YOU COMMIT I COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING. TO TRY TO FIND AS
MUCH COMMON GROUND AS POSSIBLE.
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY TO
APPROVE PROTECT CONSUMERS AND
THEIR SURVIVING LOVED ONES BY
PROVIDING A CONVENIENT WAY TO
LOCATE AND CLAIM ON USE PRE
NEED TRUST FUNDS. WITH ME I
HOPE TO PROVIDE SOME OF THE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY. IS
VENTURE TO OPEN THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE. THANK YOU
RESEARCH REFORM TOLD YOU'RE-
CALLING IN NO THAT THOUGHT ARE
YOU HERE WITH US. YES I AM
HEARING A CHAIR YES WE CAN
PLEASE PLEASE GO AHEAD BIG IN
ARCHITECT BY THE DAY MY NAME'S
BENCHER BUT WHAT THE OFFICE. HE
CONTROLLER BETTY WITH ME DAVID
GILLIAN NINE MAR UNCLAIMED
PROPERTY DIVISION BREAK
TECHNICAL QUESTION. THE CONTROL
OF ANY USE PRE THE BONTA AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA. WHICH IS
IMPORTANT BILL TO ENSURE
CONSUMERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
CAN LOOKING CLAIM. ABANDONED
CREE NEED PEOPLE TRAPPED CAL.
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY WILL.
THE THING ON CLAIM PROPERTY
LOSS. WHEN UNDER WHAT
CONDITIONS CREATED PEOPLE TRUST
ACCOUNT BECOME PAPAL
DISTRIBUTABLE AND A LOT. IT IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE CURRENT MODEL
NOT PROVIDE CLEAR DIRECTION TO
HOLDERS OF CREATING A TRUST
ACCOUNT REGARD THE CONDITION
PLAN FUNDS MUST BE REPORTED
RELATED FIFTY CONTROLLER BUT
GOING FROM PARTY. THIS BILL
PROVIDES BENEFITS BOTH CONSUMER
OF ANTI ALL DALLAS SPENT. THEIR
REQUIREMENTS PROVIDE GENERAL
DEMOLITION CLEAR DIRECTION FOR
WHEN THE REPORT AND REMIT FINES
AND BANDIT ACCOUNT. AND RELIEVE
THEM OF LIABILITY ASSOCIATE
WITH HOLDING UP QUITE PROPERLY.
IN ADDITION. WHICH ARE
CURRENTLY HELD A BANDIT ACCOUNT
WILL BE RETURNED TO BENEFIT
HERE THAT. ARE THERE. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TESTIFY. A
MORE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. RIGHT IS
ANYONE ON THE PHONE WOULD LIE
TO OFFER SUPPORT FOR AB. TWENTY
THREE THIRTY TWO. FIRST HAND-
COMPLINE OF ONE HUNDRED AND ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND- HONORABLE
MEMBERS- I'M GARLAND ALLEN A
VOLUNTEER TO SEE YOUR POLICY
ADVISER WITH THE A RP OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. HE WOULD ALSO
THE TELEPHONE LINES. THE
REMAINDER WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE DIDN'T
ZERO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
WE GATHER INFORMATION FROM THE
NET A MENTOR.
HANNIBAL COMPLINE
OF ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CHURCH
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GERRY
DESMOND AND TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF THE CEMETERY AND
MORTUARY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA NOTED BUT WE HAVE A
SUPPORT POSITION ON THE MEASURE
AS IT MOVES FORWARD AND
CONTINUING DISCUSSIONS AND WE
ARE WORKING ON PROVISIONS THAT
WOULD FINE TUNE THE APPLICATION
TO OUR INDUSTRY. ON THREE OF
THE CENTRAL ISSUES AT THIS
POINT THE EFFECTIVE DATE OF THE
SHIPMENT REQUIREMENTS IN
EXCLUSION FROM THE SHEEP AND
WHEN THE FINAL STEP WHICH MEANT
A SOLD AND THE RETENTION OF AN
APPROPRIATE FREE UPON A
SHIPMENT AND WE ALSO REMAIN
COMMITTED TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THAT THE SPONSOR IN
THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE ON THE
TELEPHONES. AT THE TIME THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN Q.
THIS WILL GO TO COMMENTS FOR
THOSE IN THE CHAMBERS MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTMAS KAYLEE
ON BEHALF OF S. C. I.
CALIFORNIA FUNERAL SERVICES-
I'M TRADE ASSOCIATION JUST
SPOKE WE I JUST REITERATE THAT.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
COOPERATIVELY WITH THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE WITH THE
BUREAU AND OF COURSE THE AUTHOR
AND HIS STAFF AND LOOK FORWARD
TO RESOLVING HOPEFULLY THOSE
THREE FINALLY ISSUES THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
LIKE TO REGISTER SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY TWO. RIGHT
IS THERE OPPOSITION AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY TWO. OPERATORS ARE
THERE'D THIRTY ONE IN THE QUEUE.
THE TIME THEY'RE NOT COMING
THANK YOU. RIGHT GROUP THEN YOU
CAN CLOSE THE PHONE LINES FOR
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY TWO.
QUESTIONS FROM THE DIE. THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. WHICH CAR YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AGAIN
WHAT THINK THE CEMETERY MORE
TREES ASSERTION OF CALIFORNIA
FOR WORKING WITH US- IN TRYING
TO RESOLVE THE ISSUES THE BEST
OF OUR ABILITY AND I ESPECIALLY
WANT TO THANK STATE CONTROLLER
THAT HE- FOR SPONSORING THIS
BILL AND- FOR HER STAFF FOR
WORKING. SO CLOSELY WITH MY
STAFF TO ENSURE WE CAN MOVE
THIS BILL FORWARD AND TRY TO
RESOLVE AGAIN THE ISSUES THAT-
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS MAY HAVE
WITH THAT IS LIKELY
ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE THE MOST IN A SECOND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATE COLOR. YEAH HI
STONE I GALLAGHER. CHAU RIGHT
SHALL I CHIU. GONZALEZ HOLDEN
KALRA OR I KILEY. KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
I READ REYES I. IT HAS EXPOSED
RIGHT THE BILL IS. THANK YOU
MISTER KALRA WE SEEM TO HAVE A
LACK OF. AUTHORS LACK OF
MEMBERS BY INCLINATION IS TO
CONTINUE ON BUT ALL ACTION
THREW IT OUT TO MEMBERS WOULD
TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF A BREAK
MAYBE WE CAN. GET SOME YEAH SO
I'M HAPPY TO. GO AHEAD OKAY. WE
WILL DO THAT THEN WE WILL MOVE
ON. TO ACTUALLY HAVE THREE THAT
I WANT TO DO. AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY AB THIRTY TO SIXTY TWO
AT EIGHTEEN THIRTY THREE SIXTY
TWO WAS ARRESTED YOU. SURE THE
MEAN FOR ME. YEAH JUST DO THAT
FROM THERE. RIGHT. FOR STARDOM
I AM NOT A. FIFTEEN TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY SOMEONE MEMBER STONE.
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE PHONE LINES ON AB. TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY. MR STONE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY IS ABOUT
COLLECTING. TAXES THAT ARE OWED
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT
HAVE NOT BEEN PAID THE
CALIFORNIA FALSE CLAIMS ACT
PROTECTS INCENTIVIZE IS WHISTLE
BLOWERS TO DISCLOSE FRIED FROM
THEIR EMPLOYEES AND OTHER
ENTITIES WHO HAVE PERPETRATED
FRAUD AGAINST THE GOVERNMENT
FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS THAT THE
FALSE CLAIMS ACT HAS PROVEN TO
BE AN EFFECTIVE TOOL TO DEFER
TO DETERMINE FEEL AND PUNISH
THOSE WHO TO FRAUD THE PUBLIC.
OF MUCH NEEDED FUNDS. IS A
SPECIAL ACT BECAUSE IT IS
PROVIDES FOR A TOOL. TO ENSURE
THAT THESE TAX SCOFFLAWS OR
IDENTIFIED THROUGH THE
WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTION TO THE
REASONABLE OR PROCESS. BECAUSE
THEY WOULD NOT THESE ARE THESE
ARE SCOFFLAWS THAT WOULD NOT BE
IDENTIFIED THROUGH NORMAL TAX
PROSECUTION PROCESSES THAT'S
WHY THIS IS SO IMPORTANT. THE
CALIFORNIA'S TACK AT TAX GAP IS
ESTIMATED TO BE BETWEEN TWENTY
AND TWENTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS. THAT IS TWENTY TO
TWENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
OWED BUT NOT ACTUALLY COLLECTED
IT IS THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE. THAT WE HAVE TAKEN. THIS
BILL CAME BEFORE US LAST YEAR.
AND WAS SLOW DOWN A LITTLE BIT
IN THE SENATE. AND WE'RE-
WORKING THIS YEAR TO TRY AND
GET THIS THROUGH AGAIN WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WHO SEES THIS AS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL NOW WHAT WE'RE
WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WERE MAKING
SURE. THAT AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY FULL ONLY APPLIES WHEN
THE YOUR THEIR CASES WHERE THE
TAX PAYER KNOWINGLY KNOWINGLY
SUBMITS FALSE FACTS TO THE
GOVERNMENT SO THIS IS NOT.
WHERE THERE'S A TAX POTENTIAL
TAX LIABILITY THAT IS DISPUTED
WHERE THERE'S A DISPUTE A
FACTOR DISPUTE OF. OF
INTERPRETATION OF THE TAX CODE
THE TAXPAYER WULD HAVE HAVE TO
KNOWINGLY SUBMIT FALSE FACTS
THE GOVERNMENT. AND THE DAMAGES
WHICH MEANS THE TAX LIABILITY
WOULD HAVE TO BE TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS. FOR MORE. SO WITH.
TAXES THE NEAR PROTECT AGAINST
FRIVOLOUS SUITS WERE ALSO
PROTECTING THE TAX RECORDS OF
THE- OF THE TAXPAYER IN THIS
CASE BECAUSE ONLY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OR THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION THE TAXING
AUTHORITY WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
THE TAX RECORD. UNDER A DAY
KEEPS HIM SUIT THE
WHISTLEBLOWER WOULD NOT THAT
HAVE ACCESS IF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OR THE PROSECUTING FOR
DECIDED NOT TO MOVE FOR WITH
THE CASE. UNDER WHISTLEBLOWER
ACT THEN THE WHISTLE BLOWER CAN
USUALLY MOVE FORWARD UNDER QUI
TAM. SUITS IN THIS CASE HOWEVER
THEY WOULD NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
THE TAX RECORDS SO WE ARE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
LIMITING THIS TO TAXES TO
SITUATIONS WHERE THERE IS AN
INTENTIONAL. WITHHOLDING OF TAX
AND INTENTIONAL FALSE CLAIMS
MADE TO THE STATE. THAT THE TAX
LIABILITY IS HIGH ENOUGH. WE'RE
NEW YORK STATE TEN YEARS AGO
ENACTED SOMETHING SIMILAR AND
IN THE ANNOUNCES YOU'LL SEE
DISCUSSION OF THAT. NEW YORK
STATUTE THAT IS PROVEN TO BE
VERY EFFECTIVE OVER THE TEN
YEARS THEY HAVE PROSECUTED TO A
TOTAL OF THIRTY CASES. AND
WHICH IS. WHICH SHOWS THAT IT'S
BEING USED SPARINGLY AND
APPROPRIATELY AND YET THEY HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO RECOVER HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF TAX
LIABILITY. SO WITH THAT I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTES I DO HAVE SOME WITNESSES
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTES ON AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY. FIRST WHAT
IS. HIDE THE DAMPENING LATE CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU- LITERATURE
MEMBERS BY ANTHONY LEAVE FROM
THE OFFICE OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS FOR. THE TURNING
GENERAL DESPAIR OF THE BUNKER
AT THE BILL. I WANT TO THANK
THE MEMBER DON'T TREAD
LEADERSHIP AND OFFERING THE
BILL THE CRITICAL MEASURE THAT
STRENGTH AND THE FOX LANE BACK
IN ORDER PROTECT. PBLIC
DOLLARS CONTACT FRAUD TO GET
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT. AND
BY EXTENSION CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS MY COLLEAGUES MARIA
ELENA COOKBOOK FOLLOWED ME TO
EXPLAIN MORE ABOUT THE
LEGISLATION. AND TRAINING
TECHNICAL QUESTION SO I'LL BE
BRIEF. THE YEAR AND BILLIONS OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS BE COVERED
WITH THE PASSAGE OF THE
CALIFORNIA BOB THE FACT HAVE
PROVEN THE VALUE OF THE ANTI
CORRUPTION NOT. AB TWENTY FIVE
THEN THE HEART OF THE POWER OF
THE FALSE CLAIMS ACT TO UNCOVER
AND PROSECUTE THEM OF THE
AGREED TO TAKE OF THE TAX FRAUD.
THE BILL DOES DRUG THING
ALTHOUGH WITH THE BLOWER THAT
WE APPRECIATE I NEED THEIR
COURAGE AND STEPPING FORWARD
AND COVERED LARGE SCALE FROCK.
THE BILL THE BILL ALSO
CLARIFIED THE HUGE IDENTIFIED
BY OUR SUPPORT WHICH IF LEFT
UNADDRESSED. COULD BE COPLEY
THAT HAVE. TRY TO THINK OF
CALIFORNIA TXPAYERS EXPECT OUR
GOVERNMENT TO OPERATE
EFFECTIVELY WE MUST USE. EVERY
TOOL AT OUR DISPOSAL TO PROTECT
THE STATE PROGRAMS THE THIRD
THE I CAN TRY BUT TACTIC. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE BILL COULD
EVENTUALLY LEAD TO THE RECOVERY
OF HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. BUT I THINK THE
PRODUCT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY THE BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY THE ASSOCIATION
FOR CALIFORNIA COUNTY. WE GET
CITY COUNCIL DISTRICT AS WELL
AS THE PICKED HER NAME THE
BARGAIN I'D LABOR AMONG OTHER.
FOR THESE REASONS THE FOR THE
WRONG LEGISLATIVE PRIORITY FOR
ATTORNEY GENERAL BUT THEY'RE AT
AND WE URGE YOU TO VOTE I STAY
AT THE AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY.
AND NOW I'LL TAKE IT TO BRIAN
CLEAN. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
LIKE MANY. I DIDN'T ANNIKA CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
STANDING COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM
A RAIL AND I CAN'T THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WORKING WITH ATTORNEY
GENERAL THE FAIR AT. THAT THE
CALIFORNIA BOTH PLANES ACTED
AIMED AT UNCOVERING
INVESTIGATING AND PROSECUTING
FALSE CLAIMS COMPENSATING THE
GOVERNMENT FOR FRAUD IN HEARING
I THINK MANY OF THE PROVISIONS
OF AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY
CLARIFY INSURANCE TING YEAH BUT
THE MAIN CHANGE PROVIDE THE NEW
AND EFFECTIVE TOOL TO THE
CAVERN PROSECUTE. FRAUD THE ACT
HAS BEEN EXTREMELY EFFECTIVE WE
NEVER COVERAGE OVER ONE POINT
EIGHT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS FROM
NON MEDICAID FALSE CLAIMS CASES
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT ALL
OF THE FILE CLAIMS UNITS WORK
IS ENTIRELY SELF FUNDED BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SHARE OF THE
RECOVERY INVOLVED CLAIMS THAT
CASES. AND THAT WOULD INCLUDE
TAX FRAUD- THE PACKING AGENCIES
DO THEIR ABOUT THE CLOSE THE
TAX GAP AND TO TRACK DOWN
CHEATERS GIVEN THE RESOURCES
THEY HAVE BUT THEY CAN ONLY GO
AFTER THE TAX RIGHT THEY KNOW
ABOUT. THIS BILL ALLOW THE TO
GO AFTER THE HIT AND FRAUD THE
CALIFORNIA PLAIN FACT
INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE WITH INSIDE
INFORMATION TO COME FORWARD
WITH EVIDENCE OF FRAUD THAT WE
WOULD NOT OTHERWISE HAVE KNOWN
ABOUT BY OFFERING A MONETARY
REWARD. OUR EXPERIENCE SHOWS
THAT THE MONETARY INCENTIVE IS
CRITICAL THINKER URGING
INSIDERS TO COME ABOUT. BECAUSE
FIGHTERS ARE FREQUENTLY
EMPLOYED THE COMPANY COMMITTED
FRAUD ONE WHERE THEY PUT THEIR
LIVELIHOOD AT RISK FOR THE
THREE OF THEM THE BILL ALSO
STRENGTHENED THE ANTI
RETALIATION PROVISIONS. IN THE
ACT WE HAVE A DEDICATED AND
HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL THAT
SPECIALIZES IN CASES INVOLVING
FINANCE ACROSS CAN WORK HAND IN
HAND. THE CAPITAL PRETTY TO
PURSUE TAX. ANY YOUR TEXT
DAMAGE POWER. OF THE TWO THE
FALL CLAIMS ACT IS AN ATTACK
ARENA. TEN YEARS AGO NAY YORK
AND IT OFF CAME BACK TO A-
PACKED FOR CLEAN. ENERGY KERR
OVER FOR HER AND- MILLION. IN
UNPAID TAX. WE WORK WITH THE
THAT THE AND DEVELOP OF THE
THIS A BIT BY THE PLACE. AND
MODEL AFTER YOU YOUR SIX LOOKS.
FIND I'D LIKE TO KNOW THAT THIS
BILL IS LIMITED TO LARGE
OFFENDERS WITH MINIMUM INCOME
AND TAX LIABILITY THRESHOLD.
AND THEN NO ONE WOULD BE LIABLE
UNDER THE FALSE CLAIMS BLOCK
FOR INNOCENT MISTAKES OR
LEGITIMATE TAX DISPUTE. I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU. Q. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS. ON THE
PHONE. FIND ONE TWENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS JEFF DEAL
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES HAPPY
TO SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. FIND ONE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
APPLICATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE THANK YOU THANK YOU. I
DON'T KNOW FOR THE PARTICIPANTS
CUED UP AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
RIGHT WE KNOW THAT WE MICHAEL
LOW TO AND ROB MùT TREE. BOTH
ON THE LINE MR BELOW. IF YOU
DON'T MIND I'D LIKE TO DEFER TO
MR MILITARY TO BEGIN AND THEN
I'LL GO BEHIND HIM IF YOU DON'T
IF THAT'S ALRIGHT WITH THE
COMMITTEE THAT'S FINE. MR
MUTRIE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
OF ROBERT HE FOR THE CAL
CHAMBER WE'RE SUPPOSED TO AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY. FIRST I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE STAFF FOR
THEIR AT LAKE THE IN TOPPLING
NOW THAT THE LIKE THE THINK THE
AUTHOR IS. ON THAT AND THE
SPONSOR FOR DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE OPPOSITION COALITION BOTH
LAST YEAR AND THIS YEAR- WE
YEAH WELL LAST YEAR I JUST LIKE
THE WAY WE PROPOSES THAT A MAN.
TO TAKE- THE BID COMMUNITY
NEUTRAL. WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
COME TO THAT POINT BUT WE YOU
KNOW WE APPRECIATE THE WORK- I
SUPPORT THAT ARE. NOT THEM FROM
ANY DEFENSE OF TAX BROAD ARRAY
INTENTION TO MAKE IT HARDER ON
WHISTLE BLOWERS. WE'RE NOT
OPPOSED TO STRENGTHENING UP.
WITH BOOKS ACTIONS HERE THAT
THAT THAT WE COME FROM. I ALSO
WOULD NOT WE'RE NOT HERE
DISAGREE WITH THE EIGHTY DOLLAR
ABOUT THE OVERALL VALUE TO THE
CALL. FIND THAT. YOU KNOW WE
HAVE WITH THE CALL CAME BACK
VERY. PARTICULARLY COMPLETED.
UNLIKE TACTFUL. WHERE WE DO NOT
HAVE. A CORRECTIVE OVERSEEING
AGENCIES. WHICH ARE IN THE F.
E. B. HE CAN'T PAY WHICH AT THE
OUT NO SIR YOU KNOW ARE. ACTIVE
IN. YOUR NATIONALLY RIGHT FOR
THEIR WORK- THAT'S WORKED WITH
THE CONCERN- FIRST CONCERNING
ALL TRY TO KEEP AT A TIME. I
NEED. HERE REGARDING THE YOU I
AGREE TO HEAR MY COLLEAGUE
MICHAEL WILL HELP ON THAT WILL
MOVE QUICK SECOND GETS REGARD
IT YOU TO THE POP AND THAT INTO
THINK TACK PROVISIONS WE'VE
BEEN YEAH THERE AT THE AT
NUMBER OF MEN OUT TO HELP. YEAH
THE BLUE THAT STATUTE HE THE
ACTUAL THE PATIENT EITHER A ARE
WE TO WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
PACKED THEIR ARCHITECT THAT
RULED THE CONCERT WITH A
STANDARD BETWEEN ACT ARCHING
DIFFERENT AREAS RATHER. AND
WILL ENSURE THAT WE TALK ABOUT
THE BUT IT'S REALLY THE HARD
WORK WE HAVE TO. THAT IF AN
AGING THANK YOU YEAH BUT-
WORKING. PROP THAT WOULD ATTACK
EIGHTEEN. I HAD LIKE AN ISSUE
WITH THEM EXAMPLE HEY WE HAVE
WE HAVE TAKEN AT THAT BELIEVE
IT GOOD BUT WANT TO THANK FOR
YOU. I'M GOING TO MAKE SURE
THOSE ARE AS THE PARK'S IT
WOULDN'T BAIT POTENTIAL A
PARALLEL BUTTE. OF I KNOW THE
NOW FLAG ONE FOR ABOUT THAT
WERE ON GO LEGAL OR- PROPERTY.
I'M NOT CONVINCED THAT THE
PROPER PAPERWORK YOU'RE NOT
FALL INTO THAT DONE BLOOD HAVE
ON THE PROPERTY. ON IT YEAH THE
LAST POINT I'LL MAKE IN LIGHT
OF TIME MY APOLOGIES. AT THE
DISCUSSION OF THE- CáC YEAH
AREN'T. THAT THE BILL I THAT
THERE IS A HIDDEN FRAUD OUT
THERE. KIND OF. IS NOT WE KNOW
WE'RE NOT AWARE OF IT. POINT
HAVE BEEN FOR THAT. WE ARE
AWARE THAT ACT UP ALL THE NOT
THE NEARLY. A BROADER
UNDERSTANDING IN THE PACKED UP
INCLUDE. THE CATEGORY SIMPLY ON
COLLECTIBLE BUT WHERE AYE AYE
THE- THEIR- CANNOT HATED MATH
TACTIC INTO YOUR WORK THAT THEY
CAN'T WRITE UP THE- RIGHT THAT
WE- WOULD. TAKE THE ISSUE THE
ADVOCATE BILL IS OFTEN. OUT
BETWEEN THE- IF WE DON'T DO
THAT HAPPENING NOW WAY OFF
DIFFERENT. THE THANK YOU FOR
THE READ WE ARE PUBLIC. THANK
YOU MISTER BELOW. THANK YOU
CHAIR UP MIKE SPEAKING ON B. OF
THIS JUST SYSTEM OF CAL. LIKE
TO MISTER AND THANKING
COMMITTEES FOR THE VERY VERY
THOROUGH ANALYSIS IT REALLY
GOES THROUGH A WHOLE HOST OF
ISSUES THAT THE THAT THE BILL
RAISES AND I'D LIKE TO STEP
BACK AND APPROACH THIS FROM A
LITTLE HIGHER LEVEL AND THAT IS
IT A GOOD IDEA TO DEPUTISE
PRIVATE COUNSEL TO DO
ENFORCEMENT OF TAX LAWS.
ASSUMING THAT EVERYTHING IN
THE- ANALYSIS IS CORRECT I
STILL THINK THERE'S AN ENORMOUS
POLICY QUESTION RAISED BY
BRINGING. IT SHOULD BE LAWYERS
INTO BE FIRST MONTH OF-
TAXATION- INTERESTINGLY WE HAVE
A SERIES OF HIS OF LAWS WHICH
ILLUSTRATE THE HISTORY HERE ALL
OF WHICH WERE ADOPTED FOR VERY
WORTHY PURPOSES YOU KNOW THE-
ACCESS TO THE DISABILITY ACCESS
LAWS. ABSOLUTELY WORTHY GOAL
BUT HAS BEEN SUBJECT TO ABUSE.
A PROP SIXTY FIVE TOXICS
DISCLOSURE VERY VERY WORTHY BUT
ALL SORTS OF ABUSE OF PROP
SIXTY FIVE ACTIONS. AND
FINALLY- POP OUT THE
ENFORCEMENT OF LABOR LAWS IS
CRITICAL BUT THERE HAS BEEN AN
ENORMOUS ABUSE IN THIS AREA AND
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT SAME
ABUSE HAPPENING WITH RESPECT TO
TAXES. YEAH MAY NOT BE A
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE SORT
OF. AND THAT THE GOVERNMENT
MORE SACRED THAN TAX LAW YOU
SIMPLY HAVE TO BELIEVE THAT THE
TAXES ARE BEING ENFORCED THE
GET TAXPAYERS ENOUGH WHERE EVEN
HANDED WAY. AND GIVING. PROF
INSTEAD THAT I KNOW AND RESPECT
THE PLAINTIFFS BAR BUT ARE VERY
VERY AT I CANNOT. EVER READ UP.
AS LONG AS THAT KEY TâM
ELEMENT IS PRESENT AS TO TAXES
IN THE FALSE CLAIMS ACT-
INSTEAD YOU MIGHT ASK WHAT DO
WE DO TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE ARE
PAYING THEIR TAXES. AND THE
ANALYSIS BY SHOWS YOU THE
PASSWORD- THERE'S ONE PARAGRAPH
IN THE ANALYSIS THAT HAS NOT
BEEN MENTIONED THAT. AND IT.
THE FRENCH TAX BOARD IN CD TFA
HAVE MECHANISMS TO REPORT
CAPTION BROUGHT UP FOR SOME
REASON THE LEGISLATURE HAS
NEVER SEEN FIT TO FUND A
WHISTLE BLOWER ACT TO ALLOW THE
FTP TO REWARD PEOPLE WHO COME
FOR WORK IT'S SUCH A SIMPLE
APPROACH AN EXISTING CURRENT
LAW BUT IT ISN'T SIGNED IT AND
AGAIN IT'S ON PAGE TEN WELL WHY
DON'T YOU LEAVE CAPTION FOR
SMART WEARABLE. THAT IS WHAT.
THE AGENCY CHARGED WITH HIM FOR
DE WHICH THEY VERY AGGRESSIVELY
IN VERY SUCCESSFULLY AND GIVE
THEM THAT WHISTLE BLOWER
INCENTIVE MONEY IT'S SELF
EXECUTING IF NO ONE WOULD
BROWN'S ANY WHISTLES IT
WOULDN'T COST ANY MONEY AND IF
THEY COME FORWARD AND- TO TAX
CHEATS THOSE. PEOPLE ARE
REFERRING TO THEM THEN THEY
THEN THEY CAN BE REWARDED YOU
COULD ALSO BUILD AND THE
WHISTLE BLOWER PROTECTIONS THAT
THIS BILL INCLUDES SO THE ONE
POINT FOUR FIVE MILLION THAT
AND THAT WAS IN AB TWELVE
SEVENTY LAST YEAR. GOES WAY YOU
FUND A WHISTLE BLOWER PLAN YOU
DON'T HAVE TAX LOOPHOLES AT A
TIME- TO EMPLOYEE ROLES AT THE
TIME THAT THE BUDGET IS
CONSTRICTED. YOU ENFORCE THE
TAX LAWS WHERE THEY BELONG AND
IT'S AVAILABLE TO YOU FROM
CURRENT LAW. SO WE WOULD
SUGGEST RATHER THAN GO DOWN
THIS ALBUM ESPECIALLY ON THE
KEY YEAH. AND THE WITH BLOWER
BUT GRAM AND SEE TIAS. AND SEE
THAT WORKS. FOR THOSE THREE FOR
A- AND I THINK WE WILL REMAIN
OPPOSED AS LONG AS THERE IS
FRANKLY A BOUNTY HUNTER
PROVISION IN THE LAW. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER RELOAD ANY
OTHER WITNESSES. THE POST.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTMAS
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF COUNTY THE
COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE THE SAME
OPPOSITION THAT THE PREVIOUS
TWO SPEAKERS AT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THIS IN OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE. ONE
MOMENT ONE IS SHOWING UP. WE
DON'T COUPLE JUNE UP ONE MOMENT
THE OPERATORS GIVING IN THEIR
LINE NUMBER. LINE ONE TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. CALGARY
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION I THANK
YOU BOTH AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY
AND WE LIKE TO NOTE THAT THE
TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR PCKAGE MENTIONED TODAY
I THINK HE SAID WITH TRONG.
THANK YOU FOR COMMENTS NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE EIGHTEEN
JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION.
WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN TO. MILLION
THE- GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JUSTIN I WITH THE BILL CONDON
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED THANK YOU
THANK YOU THERE ARE NO OTHER
FONG COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. THEY DON'T. YEAH THE
MOTION IS SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AN
IMPORTANT BILL BUT WE'RE STILL
OBVIOUSLY WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND TRYING TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
ARE JUST SOME FUNDAMENTAL
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN HOW THIS
TOOL WORKS HOW THE TAXING
ENTITIES FUNCTION AND WHAT THE
CONCERNS ARE BUT REMEMBER. THIS
IS A BILL THAT IT SETS A
MINIMUM. TAX LIABILITY
REQUIREMENTS SO THAT DAY WE
WON'T SEE THE KIND OF. FISHING
EXPEDITIONS I THINK THAT
OPPOSITION IS CONCERNED ABOUT
IF YOU LOOK AT NEW YORK'S
EXPERIENCE YOUR EXPERIENCE HAS
BEEN VERY VERY POSITIVE AND
NONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED HAVE SURFACED IN
UNDER THAT PROGRAM SOWE'RE
TRYING TO LOOK AT THIS
RESPONSIBLY AND COLLECT MONEY
AT THE TIME WHEN LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IN THE STATE ARE
GOING TO NEED. ALL OF THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY- ABSOLUTELY
CAN'T AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATINS
PLEASE TAKE ROLE. SO I WAS
THERE OR WAS THERE A MOTION AND
A SECOND. YES CHAO A KALRA.
THANK YOU STONE HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. JOE SO I TO AND
SALAS. HOLDEN KALRA- KALRA AYE
KILEY ELLIE NO MAIENSCHEIN
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NO REYES HI
RES I THAT'S GOT FOR BOTH.
LEAVE THE RECORD OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN AB THIRTY TO SIXTY TWO
MR STONE. THANK YOU AB THIRTY
TO SIXTY TWO IS TRYING TO
ADDRESS AN ISSUE IN THE
ELECTRONIC MARKETPLACE THAT HAS
BEEN BREWING FOR QUITE SOME
TIME BUT NOW UNDER THE CURRENT
SITUATION IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER AS THE MARKET PLACE A
REPORT. DETAILS TOUR. AND THOSE
STORES NOW WORK BUT YOU PRIOR
MORE MORE PEOPLE WERE GOING
ONLINE WE'VE WE'VE DEVELOPED AN
ISSUE THAT IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT ONE FOR PROTECTING
CONSUMERS FROM DEFECTIVE
PRODUCTS WE HAVE A LONGSTANDING
PRODUCT LIABILITY PRINCIPLES
THAT ENSURE THAT WHEN A
DANGEROUS PRODUCT IS SOLD TO A
CONSUMER THERE IS A LIABILITY
AND THE LIABILITY. IS CARE
THROUGH THE DISTRIBUTION CHAIN
HOWEVER IN ONLINE MARKETPLACES
MORE AND MORE THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDING THAT
MARKET PLACE. DIDN'T NINE THAT
LIABILITY AND AS- AS AS MARK
THOSE WORK PLACES ARE BEING
USED MORE AND MORE- IN THE
CURRENT LOCKED OUT SITUATION
AND AS MORE PRODUCTS ARE BEING
SOURCED OFF SURE WHERE THE-
MANUFACTURERS WERE THOSE
DISTRIBUTORS OF THOSE PRODUCTS.
ARE OUT OF THE REACH OF
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OR
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT LIABILITY
PRINCIPLES. CONSUMERS ARE LEFT.
INJURED WITH ABSOLUTELY NO WITH
REMEDY SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS IT IS IMPOSING ON THE
ELECTRONIC MARKET PLACES THE
SAME LIABILITY AS A BRICK AND
MORTAR STORE WOULD SO THAT WE
CAN PROTECT CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS. FROM THE SITUATION
WHERE THEY PURCHASED ONLINE A
PRODUCT THEY ARE INJURED BY
THAT PRODUCTS. AND THERE IS NO
OTHER REMEDY FOR THAT THIS IS
IMPORTANT. BILL ANYWAY AS WE
MOVE INTO A ENVIRONMENT WHERE
WHERE CONSUMERS ARE PURCHASING
MORE AND MORE ONLINE BUT- IT'S
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT NOW AS
BRICK AND MORTAR STORES ARE
GOING AWAY. AND NOT AS
AVAILABLE WHERE WE ARE
TRADITIONALLY SEE THE KINDS OF
REMEDIES THAT THAT WE NORMALLY
WOULD UNDER PRODUCT LIABILITY
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL FOR CALIFORNIA.
YEAH THE TWENTY TWENTY
SITUATION THAT IS AB THIRTY TO
SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR TO WITNESS ISN'T SPORTS
SHANE GUSMAN HERE IN PERSON AND
DAVE CARPENTER WHO WILL BE ON
THE PHONE. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE SHANE GUSMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE CO SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL THE TEAMSTERS UNITED
FOOD AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS AND
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA. FOR ALL OF OUR
ORGANIZATIONS THIS BILL IS
FUNDAMENTALLY ABOUT PROTECTING
THE PUBLIC- THE BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT ONLINE MEGA STORES
LIKE AMAZON FOLLOW THE SAME
RULES THAT BREAK THE BRICK AND
MORTAR COMPETITORS FOLLOW WHEN
IT COMES TO PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC. FROM DANGEROUS AND
DEFECTIVE PRODUCTS AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE CHAIR
STATED. THIS IS BECOMING
INCREASINGLY- NECESSARY GIVEN
THE STATE WE FIND OURSELVES
AND- WITH MUCH OF THE RETAIL
INDUSTRY LARGELY SHUT DOWN
BECAUSE OF COVERED NINETEEN.
CONSUMERS FIND IT MORE MORE
NECESSARY TO GO ONLINE TO GET
THE PRODUCTS THEY NEED-
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE SOME IN
THE SPACE THAT TAKE THE
POSITION THAT THE LAW DOESN'T
APPLY TO THEM. AND THAT PUTS
CONSUMERS IN HARM'S WAY
BECAUSE- AS YOU ALL KNOW.
LIABILITY IN THIS AREA IS A
POWERFUL INCENTIVE FOR
CORPORATIONS TO ENSURE THAT THE
PRODUCTS THAT THEY PUT OUT OF
THE STREAM OF COMMERCE. ARE
SAFE. WITHOUT THAT. THE INSIDE
OF HIS LAST AND THE PROFIT
INCENTIVE OVERTAKES. SO WE ARE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF BRINGING
SOME RATIONALITY BACK TO THE
SYSTEM AS MORE MORE PURCHASES
MOVED ONLINE. AND SUPPORT THIS
BILL- SHOULD BRING SOME
RESPONSIBILITY BACK TO SOME OF
THESE BUSINESSES AS WELL- AND
TO ILLUSTRATE THAT THIS IS NOT
JUST A THEORETICAL THING BUT-
ACTION REAL PEOPLE REAL
CALIFORNIANS- WE HAVE A WITNESS
ON THE LINE THAT- CAN
ILLUSTRATE HIS STORY FOR YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GROSSMAN
MISTER CARPENTER ARE YOU ON THE
LINE. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU. PLEASE PRESS
FIVE THANK YOU FOR THE- THANK
THE COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR
DURING CHRISTMAS TIME IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN- MY WIFE AND I
DECIDED BY TO HOVER PUBLIC
BOARD FOR MY DAUGHTER. WE ONE
OF THE GOOD ONES WE RESEARCHED
ONLINE- MY WIFE IN THE FINDING
ONE ON AMAZON AMAZON AND SAW
THAT MANY GOOD REVIEWS FIVE
STAR REVIEWS. SO THAT WAS ONLY
DECIDED BY WE TRUST THIS IS
WE'RE BUYING ON AMAZON- WHICH
IS A REPUTABLE COMPANY THAT THE
STATE. BUT WEEKS LATER I WAS
HOME I'M GETTING READY TO GO TO
PICK UP MY DAUGHTER FROM
SOCCER- AT THE PLEASE TAKE MY
DOG WITH ME IN THAT DAY I DID
NOT TAKE MY DOGS LOVE PICKING
UP THREE OR FOUR DIFFERENT
GIRLS. TIME SO I LEFT THEM HOME
AND WHAT THE SOCCER FIELD WHEN
I GOT THERE I SAW LIKE MS
DOUBLE CALLS. SO I RETURN ONE
OF THE CALLS FROM A NEIGHBOR OF
MINE WHO WAS FRANTIC AND-
SCREENING AT MY HOUSE IS ON
FIRE. SO I PICKED UP MY
DAUGHTER- WE DROVE BACK TO WE
REALLY JUST FOR CONCERNED ABOUT
THE DOG BEING IN IN OUR HOUSE.
ARE YOU THERE OKAY SO WE PULLED
UP TO OUR HOUSE HAD A PARK
ABOUT A BLOCK AND A HALF AWAY
BECAUSE BOTH FIRE ENGINES IN.
RAN DOWN THE STREET- FARMHOUSES.
IN PLAIN STILL. AND SO I WAS
LOOKING FOR THE DOG THE
NEIGHBOR FRIEND OF MINE GRABBED
ME AND AT. THE HELP ME BACK AND
TOLD ME THE DOGS WOULD MAKE IT
WOULD MAKE IT THROUGH THE FIRE.
POINTED OUT THERE WERE- OUR
FRONT LAWN. THAT COVERED BY
PART MY DAUGHTER WAS UPSET. OF
COURSE- SHE SOMEHOW THIS IS
YOUR FAULT- WE TALKED TO A FIRE
CHIEF AND HE SAID THIS WAS
CALLED BY HOVER BOARD. IT'S YOU
WAS A MECHANICAL DEVICE WHICH
IN THE BEING THE BOARD WAS
PLUGGED IN CHARGING DAUGHTER'S
BEDROOM DOOR. ANY THIRD WE ARE
ACTUALLY. WHAT HAPPENED NO WAY
MADE OUT OF A PROBLEM SO WITH
ALL LAST. BUT WHERE DO I LEARN
THAT ON THE NEWS THE OTHER
HOVER BOARD BALLING THEM IS ON
EXPLODED ALSO CALLS FIRE. I
ALSO LEARNED LATER THAT.
ALTHOUGH WE BROUGHT BOB ON
AMAZON BUT IT WAS ACTUALLY SOLD
BY A THIRD PARTY COMPANY CHINA
AMAZON NEVER TOLD US RE. OF
BOARD THERE SAID IT WAS
DANGEROUS THE FACT. AND NEVER
US ABOUT OTHER WHICH BOTH BUT
THE COST AMAZON DOES NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT HAPPENED
BECAUSE I THINK WE DIDN'T SELL
STOCK FOR. I'M TELLING MY STORY
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY TOSIXTY TWO. BUT I
WANNA MAKE SURE THIS DOESN'T
HAPPEN ANYONE ELSE. ASSEMBLY
OUT THAT IT WAS ON BE HELD
LIABLE FOR DEFECTIVE PRODUCTS
WITH THIS ON THE WEBSITE.
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME YEAH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR STORY ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTY TO SIXTY TWO. DOES
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. FOR YOUR
COMMENTS ONE ZERO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. HELLO LINE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. FURTHER QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME. I'M SORRY STRAWBERRY
OPERATOR DID YOU SAY THERE ARE
NO FURTHER QUESTIONS. YEAH
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES A WE HAVE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ROBERT
CALLAHAN- BY TELEPHONE ON
CHRISTMAS CHILI ALL IN PERSON.
ROBERT CALLAGHAN. THANK YOU-
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
ROBERT CALLAGHAN WITH THE
INTERNET ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
HERE OPPOSITION TO THE B.
THIRTY TO SIXTY TO. AB THIRTY
TO SIXTY TWO REFLECTS AN
UNPRECEDENTED EXPANSION OF
STRICT LIABILITY AND RADICALLY
DEPARTS FROM DECADES OF WELL
ESTABLISHED PRODUCT LIABILITY
LINE CALIFORNIA. PROPOSED BILL
COMES AT A TIME WHEN BUSINESSES
ARE ALREADY UNDER EXTREME
PRESSURE AND WILL STIFLE THE
ONLINE MARKETPLACE MODEL AT A
TIME WHEN CONSUMERS AS WELL AS
SMALL BUSINESSES. ARE
INCREASINGLY RELYING ON THE
CHOICE TO GIVE UNITS WHICH THIS
MODEL PROVIDES. BUT CERTAINLY
ARGUMENTS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL CREE CONFUSION BY
COMPARING OFFLINE SELLERS AND
THE LIABILITY THAT THEY'RE
UNDER TO ONLINE MARKETPLACES.
BUT THESE ARE VERY DIFFERENT
ENTITIES A FAIRER MORE ACCURATE
COMPARISON WOULD BE TO COMPARE
OFFLINE SELLERS AND ONLINE
SELLERS. BUT LET'S BE CLEAR
ONLINE SELLERS ARE ALREADY
UNIFORMLY LIABLE FOR STRICT
PRODUCT LIABILITY JUST LIKE ALL
POINT SELLERS SO THIS IS NOT A
DEBATE ABOUT DISPARATE
TREATMENT BETWEEN THE OFFLINE
WORLD VERSUS THE ONLINE WORLD.
OUT AND LESS YOU ACTUALLY WANT
TO CONSIDER THAT THIS BILL ARE
ONLY APPLIES TO ONLINE
MARKETPLACES NOT TOO WELL POINT.
THE PRIMARY QUESTION REMAINS
THE FIRST TIME SHE CAL TREAT
ELECT MARK. THE SAME WAY AS IT
DOES SELLER. AB THREE TO SIXTY
TWO MAKE THE OF AN ELECTRON
MARKET STRICTLY LIABLE ALL.
SOLD THROUGH THE MARKET PLACE
THIS WORK REPLIED TO EVERY
ONLINE BUSINESS LARGE AND SMALL
THAT CONNECTS WILLING BUYERS
AND SELLERS WOULD OPEN STRICTLY
WHY I BELIEVE EVEN IF IT DID
NOT MAKEON DISK YOU PROPER
CELL. DESCRIBE HANDLED TO
DELIVER THE PRODUCT- IT WOULD
BE THE FIRST LAW OF ITS KIND IN
THE COUNTRY DOES HE KEEP SHIP
THE PRODUCT LIABILITY WHAT THE
WORLD SIGNIFICANT CONSEQUENCES.
ONE OF THE UNDERPINNINGS FOR A.
B. THIRTY TO SIXTY TWO IS NOT
THAT MARKET PLACES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR DEFECTIVE
PRODUCTS BUT THE MARKET PLACES
SPREAD COST TO CROSS
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES BUT DOES
THAT. FORMER ACTUAL. COMMERCE
BECAUSE MY- IF NOT ALL MARKET
PLACES WILL PASS ON THE COST
YOUR LIABILITY BILLION. PUBLIC
SO. BACK TO PRODUCT AND THIS
ONE TERM RESULT IN WIDESPREAD
ARE DECREASING SO AT A RECENT
PRIDE AT PRICES FOR PRODUCTS ON
SUCH MORE PLACES YEAH WORDS
WONDER MY VERY BAD THE
MARKETPLACE WILL PROVIDE
TICKETS WHY SELECTION WITH MY
PRICE STOPPED. ALIVE RULE THAT
SPREAD ACOSTA AND OTHER
INNOCENTS OUR IS PLAY NOT
REQUIRE ALREADY DOC AND ACHIEVE
THAT AS A CALIFORNIA RECORDED
ACOSTA BURKE RATIONALE DOES NOT
SENSE WORKABLE MUTATION BUT OLD
WINDOWS CONSUMMATE CONSERVE
RESERVES INTENDED TO PROTECT AS
AB THIRTY TO SIXTY TWO CLEARLY
WHAT- THERE FOR DECADES
LEGISLATORS IN EVERY STATE AND
NEARLY EVERY U. S. COURT OF
UNANIMOUSLY DETERMINED AFTER
CONSIDERING ALL THE ROLE THE
POLICY IMPLICATIONS OF GOING
THE BENEFITS COST STRICT
PRODUCTS LIABILITY SHOULD BE
NARROWLY WHEN THEY'RE NOT
EXPANDED. LEGISLATORS IN
CALIFORNIA'S OF YET I RECOGNIZE
EXPANSIONIST REPLY. ABILITY TO
SERVICE PROVIDERS. OKAY DOES
NOT ADVANCE THERE ARE
UNDERMINED INTEREST CONSUMER
DOES AND THE COMMUNITY. AFTER
THESE REASONS MADE UP WE WOULD
OR OF A TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MATTERS REGIONAL MANAGER
MEMBERS CHRIS MCHALE ON WE HAVE
A COMP IN ADDITION TO THE CAN
OF MIKE JUST EXPRESS I THINK
OUR CA IS THAT THIS IS A SICK
DEPARTURE BECAUSE IT IMPOSES
STRICT LIABILITY- REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THE ONLINE MARKET PLACE
HAS POSSESSION OF THE PRODUCT-
OR IF THEY ACTUALLY TOOK TITLE
TO THE PRODUCT XL ITSELF WHICH
IS WHY IT'S A SIGNIFICANT
DEPARTURE. THE OTHER THING IS
COURTS TODAY ALREADY HAVE
DISCRETION TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT THE ONLINE MARKET PLACE
IS IN TROUBLE PART OF THE
SUPPLY CHAIN THIS BILL WOULD
ELIMINATE THAT DISCRETION BY
THE COURTS A LOT HAS BEEN
RAISED IN YOUR ANALYSIS- IN MY
MISTER CHAIRMAN AS THE AUTHOR
OF THE BILL ABOUT- HOLDING
RESPONSIBLE ALTERNATELY LIABLE
THE STORE IN YOU FOR IN THE
PERHAPS A MORE PRUDENT APPROACH
RATHER THAN BE EASY EXPANSION
OF STRICT PRODUCTS LIABILITY.
IS TO EXAMINE CALIFORNIA'S LONG
TERM STATUTE AND WHETHER OR NOT
CHANGES CAN BE MADE TO ENSURE
THAT IF THERE ARE SUFFICIENT
CONTACTS WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THESE PEOPLE COULD
BE BROUGHT BEFORE CALIFORNIA
COURTS AND I WOULD ADD AN
ADDITIONAL AND THAT IS THE- CAR
NOT TIME. WE DON'T WE DON'T IN
THIS MESSAGE BUT CAL IS TOWARDS
SYSTEM IS VERY. AND VERY AND AS
MY COLLEAGUE THE PATH OF THE
COST OF STRICT ULTIMATE GET
PASSED ALONG TO BUSINESSES AND
TO CONSUMERS ULTIMATELY SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ARE OPPOSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
KALING. ANY OTHER WITNESSES. IN
OPPOSITION. TO HAVE- A FEW ON
THE PHONE LINES QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT. THANK YOU.
AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN ONE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JENNIFER BUT WE'RE ON
THE ACT THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE AND WE ARE ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS OF
MIKE BALOGUN BE HAVE THE CIVIL
JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND ONE
MORE IS JUST QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT.
OR ENJOY WHAT AT ALL
BUT OFTEN. THANK YOU. THERE NO
OTHER COMMENT ON PHONE LINES AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU OPERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE THE PHONE LINE
AND IT'S TIME ON IT. THIRTY TWO
SIXTY TWO LET'S BRING IT BACK
THE MAIN MR. THANK YOU I'M HAVE
A SOME SYMPATHY WITH THIS I TO
EXTENT THAT. WHEN YOU WERE
SOMETHING ON AMAZON YOU CAN OF
THINK OF IT GETTING FROM HIM
RIVER OF THE- PARTICULAR COMP
IS AND IT COMES IN THE- BY AND
EVER BUT- YOU KNOW ON THE OTHER
HAND I THINK. THE PURPOSE OF
STRIP FRONT LIVE OR PRODUCT
LINE LAW. IS NOT TO INCREASE
CAUGHT. FOR VICTIMS TO MAKE IT
SO THERE ARE FEWER SO THE WORK
REDUCING THE COST OF. SO WHY
WHAT'S THE MECHANISM BY WHICH
IN ON LAW MARKET PLACE LIKE A
COMPANY LIKE THAT. IS WELL
SITUATED TO MINIMIZE ACOSTA
ACCIDENTS. SURE THEN THAT'S A
GREAT. AND REALLY THIS IS WHAT
UNDERLIES THE NEED FOR THE BILL
IS THERE THERE ARE. RETAIL
RELATIONSHIPS THAT ARE CREE IN
A WAY THAT WHEN THE I. LAW WERE
PASSED IN WHEN WE BUILT UP
CONSUMER LAWS OVER THE YEARS.
DID NOT CONTEMPLATE THE KIND OF
FUNCTIONS THAT THERE ARE NOW.
THE DISTRAUGHT THIS PLACE SO IT
WAS ON IS IT IS A GOOD. GOOD
CASE AND THEY A TREMENDOUS OF
POWER IN THE MARKETPLACE IN THE
INDUSTRY AND WITH THEIR
VENDORS. AND BECAUSE SOME OF
THEIR VENDORS LIKE IN THE CASE
OF THE HOVER BOARD THE PERSON
FLANK TO BURN DOWN THAT THE
POOR MAN'S HOUSE. THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY. TO IN FOR. WITH THEIR
VENDOR. PRODUCT QUALITY AND IT
IN WAYS THAT NOBODY ELSE COULD.
SO INSTEAD OF HAVING A
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM
MANUFACTURERS. AND RECORD
MORTAR. RETAILERS WHO ARE
TYPICALLY. ON WINE SHOULD
SOMETHING GO WRONG. BECAUSE NOW
WE HAVE OPENED UP POSSIBILITIES
IN THIS NEW. ELECTRONIC ONLINE
BROWN FOR. RELATIONSHIPS TO GO
WELL BEYOND WHAT CALIFORNIA'S
LONG ARM STATUTES COULD EVER
REACH. IN THE CASE OF THE- OF
WHERE TO GET A GOOD CASE. STAY
ON THIS BECAUSE THAT COMPANY
WAS REACHABLE. NOKNOWS WHO
THEY ARE REALLY WHERE THERE LOW.
AND THE ONLY ONE WHO DO. IT THE
ONLINE MARKETPLACES TATER HOOK
SET RULES FOR PARTICIPATION IN
THAT MARKET PLACE AND IF
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO WHICH THEY
DON'T SEEM WILLING TO DO THAT
HOW ELSE DO REMEDY THE HARM IN
THIS SITUATION SO TO YOUR POINT.
IF WE'RE GOING TO RATED
SENATORS. TO THAT THE IN FUSION
SO. IS PLAYING THE WAY THAT THE
PRICE WORKS WE THINK OF THE
BREAKING AND THE NORMAL
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM IF WE'RE
GONNA CREATE AS SENT WE WILL
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE WHO ARE
OPERATING IN A PLAY. WHO HAVE
THE ABILITY TO SET. THERE IS
ONE TO PROTECT THAT FOR THE END
TO GO. THAT'S WHERE WE- THEM.
TO BE MORE RESEARCH. TO WHOSE
UP THROUGH THE MARK PLACE YEAH
WE COULD HAVE PEARL. GO AND
CHEAP GOOD THAT'S NOT ALWAYS
THE- YES CONSUMER WANT ACCESS
TO THE TO THE- AW AND- THE-
PRODUCT BUT THEY ALSO. THIS DAY
AND AGE EXPECT A CERTAIN OF
SAFETY IN THAT. WELL BECAUSE OF
THESE TWO IS MY- THAT ARE OUT
THERE THAT EXT. IS A FIFTY. IS
REALLY LONGER THE AND I THINK
THE COW. PUBLIC OTHER REALLY
UNDER THAT AND THEY'VE BEEN.
USE. TO SECTIONS SO MANY YEARS
THEY HAVE THAT BASE SPEC
TENSION. SO THIS IS THE WAY TO
TRY AND MAKE FOR THAT. ALL OF
THE WHO ARE GOING TO BE. SILLY
KADING BRINGING PRADA IN
CALIFORNIA TAKERS. FOR THE SAY
OF THOSE PRODUCTS. I DO TO THAT
POINT BUT IT SEEMS TO ME IS. WE
AND YOU DEALING AN ONLINE. WITH
DON'T HAVE. PHYSICAL OF THE
PRODUCT ANY FOR IS A-
RELATIONSHIP THE STREAM OF
COMMERCE. THERE'S OF IN A BILL
TO ENGAGE. IN QUALITY. SO IT'LL
BE MORE AN INNINGS SO REQUIRE
MUCH OF. MARGIN BUFFER SO THIS
WHEN IT COMES TO PRODUCTS
AREN'T SOME INTO HOT IN THAT
LEAD TO THE- WE HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITE I THERE'S LOT OF YOU
KNOW COMPANY ARE. SHOT OUT OF
MORE. OR CALL RICA. BUT
ARGUMENT. BECAUSE IF YOU BUY
SOMETHING HAD A RETAIL STORE
THEY CARRY ALL OF THAT OUR
PUBLIC THAT'S BILL TO THE PRICE
ANY SO THERE IS A NEW MAC
THAT'S BEEN CRAY WITH THESE
MARKETPLACE. THE IS THE IS NOW
GOING A ALL OF THOSE ABA SO
YEAH PRIDE CHEAP QUESTION IS
SHOULD BE IS CHEAP AS IT IS NOW
FACILITY BRINGING IN HARMFUL AS
FOR THIS OF LOW COST WHEN THERE
IS NO RED YEAH IT IS THE
OPPOSITION CORRECT THIS IS A
CHANGE BUT IT'S A CHIU THAT'S
GOOD RESULT FROM. THE WAY THE
ON MARK WORK AND THE THAT YOUR
FACILITY THE MOVE OF GOOD
THROUGH THE CONNECTION THAT
THEY CREATE AND THE LAW IT'S A
SPECIAL. OUR THEY HAVE POWER IS
THE- TO BE TO ADDRESS THIS AND
TO SO. AND SO IF I OPEN ADD TO
HER WE THAT ISSUE. I DON'T KNOW
THE JUST BECAUSE SOMEBODY IS
THAT THEY SHOULD GET OUT FROM
LIABILITY SPECIALLY WHEN CAL.
INJURE BUT THE LARGE THE
COMPANY THEM. COMPANY THE MORE
HE- POWER THEY- TO THIS. THEY
THE ONES CLEAR. WHO SHOULD BE.
ABLE AND- TO NOT NOT WILL BUT
BE ABLE TO TAKE A RESPONSE.
HERE AND HELP KEEP HEALTH SAY
SOME SO I DO AGREE WITH YOU
THAT THEY NEEDS TO SOME OFFERED.
FOR LAW. I GUESS WHERE I
DISAGREE ISN'T WHEN YOU SAY
THAT THAT YOUR BILL WOULD
CREATE. A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
WITH THE BRICK AND MORTAR
STORES BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE THE SAME LIABILITIES RULES
APPLY WHEN THERE'S A DIFFERENT
ABILITY ENGAGE. IN QUALITY
CONTROL SO WHAT LEVEL IN THE
PLAYOFF PLAYING RIGHT. THAT DID
BILL TO ENGAGE IN ANY CONTROL I
SAID ALLOWING LIABILITY FOR AN
M. BUT A NEGLIGENCE STANDARD OF
THIS FOR LIABILITY STANDARD
CLASSIFIED BILL HOW WE DONE
PROUD I'VE BEEN IN. SO GET WITH
THEIR THEIR- THAT'S UP. WE TRY
TO SEE IF WE CAN FIGURE AWAY.
TO POTENTIALLY ABOUT THAT BUT-
IF YOU AT HOW. AT ARE BEING
MARKETED A THE WAY THAT IT ON
ONLINE READ FUNCTIONS THEY
DIFFERENTLY EVEN BRICK AND
WORSE WHAT WHAT WE OF AS A AS A
AND ALL LINE. MARKETPLACE AND
THEY DO THAT BECAUSE THEY HAVE
SUCH BROUGH REACH AND THEY HAVE
SET UP. SUCH AT BOTH BOTH FROM
THE ACT WAS SIDE AND FROM THE
CUSTOMER BASE SO THE LARGE THAT
WORK. IS THE MORE THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO. HOW PRODUCTS MOVE
THROUGH THEIR HOW AND HOW THEY
MOVE THROUGH. AND SO OF THE
CONCEPTS I STILL WOULD APPLY.
BECAUSE THE COURTS ARE GOING TO
LOOK AT. HOW MUCH A- RETAIL HAS
IF GONNA PUT UP MY BECAUSE WHAT
WHICH I USE CLAY. THAT WOULD
THE SAME FOR PRODUCT LIABILITY
FOR LIABILITY IN THE ONLINE
MARK FROM AS IN. THE CURRENCY I
THINK THAT THE MOST INTEREST.
AND SO IT YOU KNOW IF THERE ARE
WAYS TO BE A HOW WE'RE TO DO
THE IN IN I SEE THE COURTS TO.
OF THIS BE SIMILAR TO THEY'VE
INTERPRET THE STRICT LIVE CASES
WERE IT COMES TO. THAT THE OFF
LINE BROWN AS WITH ALL ROW SO I
KNOW THAT IT WORKS AS MUCH DE.
AS THE FEAR IS THAT WORK. BUT
YET THIS IS THE TO WRECK. THAT
THE WORLD AND THE WAVE
CONSUMERS. PURCHASE NEXT. RIGHT
COOL IT'S THAT'S NEW SHOULDN'T
ABSOLVE ANY FOR. THE TYPES OF.
THAT THE HAVE. IF THEY WERE I
LINE MARKET PLACE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU KERN MR TRUMP ARE
JUST FOR CLARIFICATION FOR. OUT
THIS BILL HE NOT UP ON. MY ANY
OF THE PROVISION REGARDING
THAT'S EVEN FACT RIGHT I MEAN
THERE'S STILL ON HOLD ACTUALLY.
SO I CHECKED YEAH. UP NOW I AM.
INTERESTED IN THE OF THE AT. US
IS AS OPPOSED TO STRICTLY. OUR
HEY I DO ANY FACT THAT YOU KNOW
THE PRODUCT LIABILITY. I LOVE
THE COMPANY THAT HAS YOU KNOW
THE BIG BUCKS I GUESS YOU KNOW
SO I THINK IT MAY MAKE SENSE
FOR US TO KIND OF ALLOCATE THE-
THE- OF. OF THE I MEAN- ALL
COMPANIES DIFFERENT COMPANIES
RESPONSIBLE FOR- FOR THE TO
HARM WITH THEM IS DONE I THINK
YOU KNOW IN A SENSE IT KIND OF
MAKES SENSE TO DO THAT BUT YOU
KNOW I'M I'M I'M- WELL YEAH BUT
I'M NOT QUITE SURE WHICH IS.
THE WHOLE REASON THE PRODUCTS I
DISTRICT BY ABILITY IS BECAUSE
THE NEGLIGENCE STANDARD IS ALL
OFTEN. UNDERSTAND IT ESPECIALLY
WHEN. YOU YOU'RE LOOKING AT A
DISTRIBUTION CHAIN HAD A
PRODUCT MOVING THROUGH THAT AND
SO. A COMPANY EIGHT. IS
DISTRIBUTING A PRODUCT INTO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THROUGH AN
ONLINE MARKETPLACE AND THEY'RE
THE ONLY. ORGANIZATION THAT HAS
ANY RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
MANUFACTURER AND THAT
MANUFACTURE AS IS THE CASE WITH
TALK ABOUT IS OUTSIDE OF THE
REACH OF CALIFORNIA LAW. WHAT'S
THE NEGLIGENCE STANDARD ONCE
WHEN THEY DIDN'T MANUFACTURER
EIGHT THEY THEY DIDN'T TOUCH IT
THEY DIDN'T SORT OF. HANDLE
THAT PRODUCT SO. THAT I GUESS
I'M OPEN TO THE CONCEPT BUT I'M
NOT QUITE SURE HOW THAT
FUNCTIONS AND THAT'S WHAT A
PRODUCTS LIABILITY IS
ESSENTIALLY STRICT LIABILITY
BECAUSE- WE DON'T. IF WE'RE
GOING TO PROTECT PEOPLE WHO
WERE INJURED. IN THE IF WE
START DOWN INTO THAT NEGLIGENCE
QUESTION IT BECOMES DIFFICULT
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE- WHAT
THE VARIOUS RELATIONSHIPS ARE
IN IN WHAT THE VARIOUS
LIABILITIES ARE GOING TO BE. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
MANUFACTURERS. DISTRIBUTORS
BRICK AND MORTAR STORES THAT IN
THIS CASE TRANSLATE THIS TRY TO
TRANSLATE THIS INTO THE ON
RIGHT. ON MY AROUND. OUR
ENSURING THAT THE PRODUCTS ARE
SAFE AND ARE NOT GOING TO HARM
PEOPLE AND THAT WAS
CALIFORNIANS MOVE MORE TO THE
ONLINE ROOM I THINK THAT'S
WHERE WE NEED TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION. TO LOOK AT THAT
ONLINE ROUTE. AND ENSURE THAT
THE SAME EXPECTATIONS OF
PRODUCT SAFETY AT THE SAME
INCENTIVES FOR MANUFACTURERS
AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE UP THE CHAIN. EXIST
SO THAT WE'RE NOT NOW BRINGING
JUST FOR THE SAKE OF. LOW COST
ITEMS BRING DANGEROUS ITEMS
INTO CALIFORNIA. THANK THANK
YOU MISTER JOE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS. GONZALEZ FIRST I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL WE WERE LOOKING AT
SOMETHING SOMEWHERE IN- COULD
NOT QUITE GET TO WHAT WE
NEEDED- I WAS SHOCKED TO LEARN
THAT AMAZON NOW HAS 50% OF ALL
ONLINE SALES- ARE COMING
THROUGH THAT AS OF MARKET
PLACE- SO THOUGH IT SURE POWER
OF ONE COMPANY- TO BE ABLE TO
BRING US. TAKING SOME AS WELL-
I ALSO JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
AS IT MOVES FORWARD MS FLORIDA
I'D LIKE TO KNOW JUST HOW
AUTHOR IF THAT'S ALRIGHT WITH
YOU ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU. WITH
THAT I'M OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
MAY. NO SECOND MOTIONS SECOND
MISTER OBERNOLTE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR SO I'D LIKE TO
PIGGY BACK. CHAIRMAN STONE ON
SOME COMMENTS THAT YOU MADE IN
RESPONSE TO A PREVIOUS QUESTION.
YOU KNOW I FEEL KIND OF FEEL
LIKE WE AS WE TALK ABOUT BOTTOM
LINE COMMERCE AND THE GIG
ECONOMY THAT WE WANT TO SOME
WAY SOMETIMES MAKE IT LIKE A
BRICK AND MORTAR MAKE IT LOOK
LIKE BROKEN OR BUT IT'S NOT IT
IS A FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT
MECHANIC WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AN
INTERESTING SITUATION HERE
WHERE. A MARKET PLACE IS
FUNCTIONING AS A CONDUIT
BETWEEN WILLING BUYERS ARE
WILLING SELLERS AND THAT
PHYSICAL MATERIAL NEVER PASSED
THROUGH THE CHAIN OF POSSESSION
OF THE MARKETPLACE ITSELF SO I
MEAN IT REALLY ISN'T LIKE AN
ONLINE RETAILER WE AND THIS
BILL IS KIND OF REPORTING TO
TREAT IT LIKE AN ONLINE RETAIL.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT A BIGGER
CONCERN THAT I HAVE THAT WHICH
IS THAT. YOU KNOW IN IN THIS
CASE IN IN THE TESTIMONY WAS
JUST COMPELLING. ABOUT THE
FORTUNATE WITH THE LOST HIS
HOME I MEAN THAT'S THAT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT'S-
IT'S EASY TO FIND TO IMAGINE
WHAT IT WOULD FEEL LIKE TO LOSE
YOUR HOME THAT WAY. AND CLEARLY
IT WAS AS A RESULT OF A
DEFECTIVE PRODUCT BUT- WE HAVE
NOT TALKED ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
AMAZON ACTUALLY. WAS NEGLIGENT
IN THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE FACTS
BUT- ITS CLEAR THAT IF YOU
HAVE AN ONLINE MARKETPLACE.
EVEN IF. YOU HAD A FULL TIME
STAFF DEDICATED TO- TO TRYING
TO ENSURE THAT USUALLY SHIP A
QUALITY PRODUCT. EVEN IF YOU
DID EVERYTHING THAT YOU COULD
POSSIBLY DO TRYING TO AVOID THE
SITUATIONS THAT PERIODICALLY
UNFORTUNATELY SOMETHING LIKE
THIS WOULD HAPPEN. SO I MEAN I
THINK IT'S CLEAR THE DID YOU
KNOW THIS IS GOING TO RAISE
COSTS FOR CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA THERE'S NO WAY. THEY
COULD. HE QUESTION. THAT WE IS
WHETHER OR NOT. THE AMOUNT THAT
WE RAISE THE STRAW IS WORTH THE
PUBLIC. BENEFIT THAT WOULD
RESULT IS WRITTEN. FOR RAISING
THOSE COSTS- AND I ALSO WANT TO
SAY ONE LAST THING ABOUT THE
ABOUT WHAT WE WERE JUST TALKING
ABOUT ON AMAZON. YOU KNOW ABOUT
HOW THEY'RE THEY HAVE THIS
MARKET. YES IN THIS BILL AND
THIS IS WHAT I LIKE YOUR
REACTION TO- I THINK THE
PASSING THIS BILL WOULD MAKE
THAT DOMINANCE- EVEN WORSE.
REASON IS BECAUSE EVERY TIME WE
PUT RESTRICTIONS ON A FREE
MARKET WE RAISE THE BARRIER TO
ENTRY. TO COMPANIES THAT WISH
TO ENTER THAT MARKET IN IN IN
CALIFORNIA IF THIS BILL BECAME
LAW- I WOULD THINK THAT WE ARE.
TELLING EVERYBODY THE ONLY WAY
THAT YOU CAN OPEN AN ONLINE
MARKET MARKET PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA IS IF YOU HAVE A
BUNCH OF ONE OF THE INSURANCE
AND IF YOU HAVE THE CAPITAL.
STAFF SINGLE PRODUCT THAT YOU.
IT IS THAT WILL SAYING IS IT'S
SURE SEEMS LIKE THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE SAYING WITH THIS BILL
WELL TO IT TO YOUR FIRST POINT
ABOUT THE NEGLIGENCE OF
SURVEILLANCE. I THINK. I
BELIEVE STREET LEVEL. SOME OF
THE THOSE QUESTIONS TO YOUR
SECOND ONE I THINK A LOT OF
THAT SHIP IS ALREADY SAILED
THAT GIVEN AMAZON'S DOMINANCE
IN THE MARKETPLACE THEIR 50% OF
ON LINE RETAIL NOW SOMEBODY WHO
IS A- A PLACE TO IS SELLING ON
SELLING THEIR PRODUCT ONLINE
THERE'S BUDGET THEY'RE SELLING
ONLINE DOESN'T GET THEM OUT OF
ANY OF THAT THE LIABILITY THAT
THEY WOULD NORMALLY HAVE BEEN.
WE'RE NOT REALLY EVEN WATCHING.
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS. APPLYING A
SENSE OF. LIABILITY PRODUCTS
LIABILITY. IN A WAY THAT
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS ALREADY
UNDERSTAND AND THE PROTECTIONS
THAT THEY GET INTO ONLINE BROWN
THAT SEEMS TO BE TRYING TO
SKIRT THAT LIABILITY AND THOSE
OBLIGATIONS BECAUSE THE
ARGUMENT IS THEY DO BUSINESS
DIFFERENTLY THEY'RE JUST MERELY
FACILITATING THE THAT
TRANSACTION BUT YEAH TYPICALLY
THE ONES WHO HAVE THE BEST IN
THE STRONGEST. ABILITY TO. SAVE
NOT. INTO THE CALIFORNIA MARKET
SO FOR THEM TO STEP BACK AND
SAY LOOK WE'RE JUST TRYING TO
ESPECIALLY COMPANIES LIKE
AMAZON WHICH IS TRYING TO.
FACILITATE WILLING BUYERS AND
WILLING SELLERS AND YET GIVEN
THEIR MARKET SHARE GIVEN THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT THEY MAKE
ON ALL OF THESE TRANSACTIONS
THEY'RE OPENING UP THE
FLOODGATES OF DANGEROUS
PRODUCTS COMING IN THE
CALIFORNIA. WITH OUR PAR
ABILITY TO HAVE ANY SAY OR TO
DO WITH THAT. WITH ANY REMEDY
SHOULD SOMEONE BE INJURED SO I
THINK YES WE'RE NOT EXACTLY
TRYING TO SAY WE'RE GOING TO
TREAT BOTH EXACTLY THE SAME BUT
WE'RE TRYING TO TAKE THESE
KINDS. AN EMPLOYMENT ONLINE
BROWN IN AN ONLINE WORLD THAT
HE IS. FUNCTIONING HE'S VERY
IMPORTANT IMPORTANT ECONOMY
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT TO THE WAY
CONSUMERS GET PRODUCTS BUT IS
LEAVING THOSE CONSUMERS. VERY
VULNERABLE TO INJURIES WITHOUT
RENDON SO TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE CRAZINESS REMEDIES GIVEN
THEN THE CHANGING NATURE OF HOW
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS ARE
EXPECTING TO ACQUIRE THEIR
PROBLEM SO WHAT WHAT ABOUT THE
SITUATION YOU JUST TALK ABOUT
WHERE- YOU'VE GOT AN ONLINE
MARKETPLACE BUT IT'S CLEAR THAT
THE MARKET PLACE IS JUST A
CONDO. FOR A RELATIONSHIP TO
LINK UP OF OUR BEST SELLERS. I
MEAN IN ADDITION TO THE FACT
THAT THERE'S NO CHANGE IN
POSSESSION OF THE GOOD IS BEING
SHIPPED THE MARKET PLACES
EXPLICITLY CLEAR THAT HEY LOOK
WE'RE JUST MATCHING YOU GUYS
UP. IT SEEMS LIKE YOUR BILL
DOES NOT MAKE IT CAPTION FOR
THAT I DON'T REALLY SHOW IT
DOESN'T BECAUSE THE SITUATION
THAT WE'RE SEEING ESPECIALLY
WITH LARGER ONES. THAT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO REACH FULLY AND TO
REACH COMPANY THAT MANUFACTURE.
WHO DON'T HAVE A CONTEXT
CALIFORNIA. OR CALIFORNIA. FOR
THAT THE CONSUMER PROTECTION
LAWS THAT WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
REMEDY A WRONG IF THEY HAVE
THAT ABILITY TO BRING A
DANGEROUS PRODUCT INTO
CALIFORNIA. THEN YES THEY
SHOULD RESPONSIBLE FOR THE FACT
THEY HAVE NOW PRODUCED A DANGER.
FOR WITHOUT ROAMING. OKAY WELL
LET ME THAT THIS IS THIS
ILLUSTRATE MY BIG WITH BILL
THAT YOU KNOW THE IF YOU LOOK
BACK ON ALL OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED IN THE LAST
YOU KNOW FOUND YEARS THAT HAVE
POWER WELL THE INTERNET IS
RIGHT UP THERE AND IT'S A POWER
PEOPLE BECAUSE IT. THIS TRADE
OF INFORMATION THAN. OURS AND
TO TREAT IT LIKE. A BRICK AND
MORTAR. TYPE OF TO. I THINK YOU
KNOW WHAT REALLY DEFEAT THE
PURPLE PURPOSE OF WHAT WE'VE
ACHIEVED WITH WITH THAT FREE
FLOW OF COMMERCE SO- I'LL BE
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION YEAH AND
THEN THAT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME.
BUT IT'S BE BECAUSE- IT'S
BECAUSE WE'RE RELYING MORE AND
MORE ON IN THE INTERNET IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN SORT OF AN EXCUSE
TO GET OUT FROM UNDERNEATH
REGULATIONS FROM. TO AVOID THE
PROTECTIONS THAT YOU KNOW WHERE
THIS IS THIS IS NEW IT'S
INNOVATIVE IT'S SOMETHING THAT.
THAT THAT'S FACILITATING
WHATEVER IN A CATEGORY YOU WANT
TO BE ABLE TO DO SO THEREFORE
DON'T HOLD US ACCOUNTABLE WELL
NOW WHAT HAPPENS WHEN SOMEBODY
IS INJURED AND THERE IS NO
ACCOUNTABILITY THE LAW HAS GET
LOST GET WRITTEN AND SOCIETIES
FIGURE OUT HOW TO STRUCTURE
THAT BACK IN ORDER TO FIND. A
RESPONSIBLE PERSON AND A PERSON
WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
INJURY IN THE IN FACT THAT THEY
CREATED THAT RELATIONSHIP AND
THEY ALLOW THAT PRODUCT TO GET
SO WE HAVEN'T HAD QUESTION
BECAUSE NOBODY'S HAD THE GLOBAL.
ADD SOME THAT ENABLES ON WAR
THESE MARKETPLACES HALF SO IT
IT IS A NEW WORLD. AND JUST FOR
US TO TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT.
RESPONSIBILITIES SOMEONE SHOULD
HAVE IF THEY'RE GONNA
PARTICIPATE IN THAT ROUND.
DOESN'T MEAN THAT ARE
UNDERMINING THE INTERNET OR
GOING TO DO AWAY WITH THE
INNOVATIONS OR THAT THE WAY
THAT THAT IT FUNCTIONS BECAUSE-
WE COULD GO BACK DAYS WHERE
WHERE THEY NOBODY WAS
RESPONSIBLE IF SOMEBODY
PURCHASE PRODUCTS AND THAT
PRODUCT INJURED SOMEONE. THAT'S
WHAT THE REGULATORY SCHEME WAS
WHERE THE STRICT LIABILITY CAME
IN WAS TO WAS TO INCENTIVIZE IN
MAKE SURE PRODUCTS THAT ARE
MOVING INTO CALIFORNIA SKATED
TO OUR- PLAY. ARE THEY SAVE AND
I DON'T HAVE INCENTIVES NOW
WE'RE JUST GO TO BE MOVE A LOT
OF PRODUCTS THAT ARE GOING TO
HARM PEOPLE AND THAT HAS COSTS
TO OUR SOCIETY TOSS OR
COMMUNITY COST OF HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. THIS IS A COVERAGE XIN
WITH HAVING AND US TO BE
UNDERSTOOD SO I'M- WOULD I
WOULD AGREE BUT THAT ENDED AND
I DO UNDERSTAND THAT BUT THAT
THAT IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE COMMENTS
VERY GOOD- CHAIR STONE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I THINK I'VE
SAID ENOUGH I ASK FOR YOUR-
THANK YOU. MOTION AND THE
SECOND. DO PASS PLEASE TAKE
ROLE. STONE FIVE HI GALLAGHER
GALLAGHER NO CHILD SO I TO CHU
I. GONZALEZ AND THOSE AYE
HOLDEN KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
KILEY NO. MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE NO REYES HI RES I.
HAS SIX. SIX IT PASSES OUT OF
COMMITTEE BUT WILL LEAVE THE
RECORD OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
ITEM NUMBER. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
THIRTY THREE SIXTY TWO CHAIR
STONE TANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS OUR ANNUAL BAR
DUES BILL WHICH HASN'T HAD YEAR
TO YEAR INTERESTING PATH IN
THIS COMMITTEE AND I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THIS COMMITTEES
STRENGTH IN HOLDING THE STATE
BAR ACCOUNTABLE AND THE
OVERSIGHT THAT WE HAVE DONE IN
THE CHANGES THAT WE HAVE DONE I
THINK IT VERY MUCH IMPROVE THE
PROTECTION. RESPONSIBILITY THAT
THE BAR HAS HAD THEM FOCUS ON.
THE EVEN THE PUBLIC SAFETY IN
THE LITTLE ROUND THIS BILL
ACTUALLY LOWERS THE- ANNUAL
LICENSING FEES BOTH FOR ACTIVE
TERRY'S IN AN ACTIVE ATTORNEYS.
AND IT DOES SO ALONG THE
MECHANISMS THAT WE PUT IN TO.
HE C. BILL LAST YEAR EVEN
THOUGH IT WAS A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE WE WERE MAKING SURE
THAT. THAT WHERE WE COULD THEN
WHAT'S THE BAR SO SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT SOLVE THE REDUCE
THE FEES THAT IT WOULD THAT
REDUCE FEES- THIS STRENGTHENS
THE- STATE BAR'S ABILITY
RECOVER. AUSTIN THAT THEY'RE
OWED THE STATE BAR AND THE
QUITE SECURITY FUND FROM
DISCIPLINE ATTORNEYS. FROM ANY
PART OF WORK WITH THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD CENTER AGENCY
INTERAGENCY INTERCEPT GRAHAM
RECOVER SOME OF THOSE DEBTS. IT
ALSO CLARIFIES THE LAW
PROHIBITING ATTORNEYS FROM
ENTERING INTO CONTRACTUAL
AGREEMENTS WITH CLIENTS THAT TO
TURN CLIENTS FROM FILING. AT
WORK. PLANE YEAH TURNING THEY
BOUGHT AND TRYING TO MAKE. THAT
THE STATE BAR IS THE PLACE THAT
PEOPLE. I GUESS. AND
TRANSPARENCY QUEST THAT HAVE
COME UP OVER THE- AROUND THE
BAR EXAM IN IN THE STATE BAR
GOING INTO CLOSED SESSION IN.
TAKING PUBLIC COMMENT NOT
TAKING PUBLIC COMMENT WE'RE
PUTTING IN SOME PROVISIONS TO
CLARIFY THAT AS A STATE AGENCY
THEY SHOULD BE DOING EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE IN THE PUBLIC EYE
TAKING PUBLIC COMMENT AND IT'S
NOT HIDING BEHIND THE CLOSED
SESSION RULES THAT ARE THERE IN
ORDER TO TALK ABOUT. SAID THAT
SB FIVE VERSUS SO THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS DOING ESSENTIALLY
THIS YEAR WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE THE- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. SORRY AND I AM SORRY
I'VE I'M ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT. THAT DIFFICULT
STAFF IS FOISTED UPON THE IN
THIS- THIS BILL BUT THANK YOU
ANYWAY THANK YOU TO THE STAFF
FOR ME SURE THAT WE KEEP ALL OF
THIS TOGETHER. ARE THERE ARE.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT BOTH ON
THE TELEPHONE LINE. ALLEN
STOCKBROKER AND DONNA HER SURE
WHAT'S- MISTER STEINBERG. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY TODAY I AMOUNTS THAN
RECORD CHAIR OF THE BAR'S BOARD
OF TRUSTEES. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB
THIRTY THREE SIXTY TO THE CARS
ANNUAL THE BILL. WE APPRECIATE
THE FEE INCREASES THIS
COMMITTEE GRANT OF LAST YEAR
AND WE ASSURE YOU THAT WE ARE
USING THE REVENUE IN ACCORDANCE
WITH YOUR MANDATES AND
CONSISTENT WITH THE STATE
AUDITOR AND LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
OXES RECOMMENDATIONS. WITH THE
HELP OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
THIS COMMITTEE IN PARTICULAR ON
WITH COMMITTEE STAFF. THE STATE
BAR IS MORE FOCUSED ON ITS
MISSION THAN EVER BEFORE. WE RE
PRIORITIZE ARE JUST ONE SYSTEM
SO THE MOST RECENT GO TO THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY CASES THAT.
MOST OF THE PUBLIC. WITH A
TICKET OR FOCUS ON BOTH
POPULATIONS. WE'RE CONTROL OVER
OUR BUDGETING SO AS TO LIMIT
THE NEED TO DEPLETE OUR
RESOURCES FURTHER. WE HAVE
PROVIDED RETIREE HEALTH
BENEFITS TO STATE BAR STAFF
CONSISTENT WITH THE FUNDING YOU
WANT TO RISE. AND OR HIRING
ADDITIONAL STAFF AND OUR CHIEF
OF TRYING- OFFICE SHE TRIAL
COUNSEL. WE DONE A DEEP DIVE
INTO THE CAUSES OF THE JUSTICE
GAP IN CALIFORNIA AND ARE
ACTIVELY ENGAGED FIND WAYS TO
CLOSE THAT GAP. ESPECIALLY IN
WILL GO GOOD NINETEEN WE
ANTICIPATE A TIDAL WAVE OF NEED
FOR LEGAL SERVICES AND ARE
WORKING TO INCREASE FUNDING FOR
THOSE SERVICES. PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC FROM BAD ATTORNEYS AND
ENHANCING ACCESS TO AN
INCLUSION IN THE PROFESSION IS
OUR MISSION. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
PARTNER WITH YOU AS WE CONTINUE
TO IMPROVE THE AGENCIES. I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AND I'M PLEASED TO HAVE DOWN
HER SCHOOL WHICH THE BARS
INTERIM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
HERE TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS
AS WELL THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU MS FOR SURE IT'S- YES
THANK YOU- MENTOR MEMBERS AND
ON OUR FIRST WITH. INTERMIX
SECOND DIRECTOR OF THE BAR AND
I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU ON THAT. THANK
YOU ANY WITNESSES IT'S SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY THREE SIXTY TWO ON
THE LINE. WE SHOULD MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. BUT
THE TIME THEY'RE NOT COMMENTING
CUTE. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. WE
HAVE NONE LISTED BUT IF THERE'S
SOMEONE ON THE LINE. OR IN
PERSON WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
THEIR OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTY
THREE SIXTY TWO. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE. YES MISTER TRUE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF THIS
IS NOT TO BE A SURPRISE TO THE
BAR BUT IN THE PAST SIX YEARS
I'VE BEEN QUITE SKEPTICAL ABOUT
THESE BARFI RENEWAL BILLS GIVEN
THE HISTORY THE CHALLENGES AND-
THE NEED FOR REFORM ON THE PART
OF THE BAR OUT LAST YEAR WITH
THE WHOLE WE CAN INCREASE I
WASN'T ABLE TO SUPPORT IT. THAT
BEING SAID- VERY MUCH WANT
PRECIADO WE DO HAVE A
LEADERSHIP OF THE BARTHE AND-
WHICH HEARD FROM ARE-
RELATIVELY NEW TO THE BARGAIN
IS ATION- APPRECIATE THE
PRODUCT. IT'S BEEN MADE ON A
LOT ISSUES THAT. OUT THIS
ASSEMBLY BODY HAS REALLY HELPED
TO MOVE FORWARD. APPRECIATE
THIS BILL- ASKED FOR IN NEWS
FOR ITS MEDICINAL TRANSPARENCY
I RECALL. AND MOST IMPORTANT
FOR ME- INVOLVES REDUCTION IN
THE FEMALE SO WITH THAT. TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY KIND A
CHANCE TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH SOME LEADERSHIP OF THE
BAR. I APPRECIATE- THE
CONTINUED FOCUS ON ACCESS TO
JUSTICE ISSUES DIVERSITY ISSUES
AND OTHERS AND- AS A NO ARE
THESE ARE TOPICS AND I WILL
CERTAINLY CONTINUE TO WORK. TO
MONITOR. FOR TODAY'S PURPOSES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ANY
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
NUMBER WITH MOST. AND SECOND
PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE. STONE ALL
RIGHT STONE AYE GALLAGHER
GALLAGHER I JOE SO I DO HI CHIU
AYE GONZALEZ THEMSELVES I
HOLDEN KALRA. HOWEVER I. KILEY
KILEY MEAN. OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
I REYES HI RES I. THANK YOU.
THAT IMPASSE. THANK YOU IS
RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
NOW WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
NINE AB TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT.
THIS IRWIN. OPERATOR IF YOU
COULD OPEN THE LINES FOR AB
TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB TWO
TWO OH EIGHT IS A BILL THAT
WILL MODERNIZE OUR STATE LAWS
REGARDING ONLINE. GIVING TODAY
TERRIBLE CHARITABLE FUNDRAISING
IS DRASTICALLY DIFFERENT THAN
IT WAS TEN YEARS AGO. NOW IT IS
COMMONPLACE TO CHARITY DRIVES
THAT COMPLETELY ONLINE. FUNDING
THROUGH WEBSITE OR SOCIAL MEDIA
APP FOR A LOCAL NONPROFIT IS NO
LONGER A FOREIGN CONCEPT FOR
THE NORM BUT THE NORM FOR
CALIFORNIANS. ANNUAL SURVEYS OF
DONORS THIS IS MY SHOW TREND
TOWARD ONLINE GIVING. WITH
BILLIONS OF CHARITABLE DOLLARS
FLOWING THROUGH THESE ONLINE
PLATFORMS AND INTO THE HANDS OF
LOCAL NONPROFITS DOING
IMPORTANT WORK IN OUR
DISTRICTS. ARE LAWS HOWEVER
HAVE NOT KEPT UP WITH TRENDS.
THE TWENTY. WILL UPDATE CAL IS
CHARITABLE GIVING LAWS WITH NEW
DEFINITIONS DISCLOSURES AND-REPORTING REQUIREMENTS TO
ENSURE THAT ALL MIND GIVING
PLATFORMS. ARE OPERATING WITH
THE INTENT OF OUR CHARITABLE
GIVING LAWS AND THE DAUGHTERS
OF CHARITIES ARE PROTECTED. NOW
THIS ISSUE FOR A OF YEARS AND I
BELIEVE THAT- WITH ALL PRIOR
GROUNDWORK LAID THE STRONG
SPONSORSHIP BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE. AND MY
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS THIS BILL
PASSES WE WILL LEAVE. SHAPING
OUR- THIS BILL IS ALSO COMING
AT A CRITICAL MOMENT IN OUR
HISTORY AS A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY IN AN ECONOMIC CRISIS
OR MAKING CHARITABLE DONATIONS
ALL MORE CRITICAL TO
MAINTAINING THE FACT. AB EIGHT
TWENTY TWO IT PROVIDE A- FOR
ALL MY PLEASURE TO MINIMIZE
EXPOSURE TO LIABILITY. WHILE
PROVIDING THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WITH THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE ONLINE. RECIPIENT WELL
THERE ARE STILL CONVERSATION TO
BE HAD ON IS INCLUDE IN THIS I
BELIEVE ALL STAKEHOLDERS
CONTINUE TO WORK AND GOOD. ON
THE PHONE. TWO REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
THE BILL BRIAN ARMSTRONG AND
ANTHONY. THANK YOU SO THE
WITNESSES THAT ARE WITH US
TELEPHONICALLY. MISTER
ARMSTRONG
LEAVE I'M GONNA GO FOR. OKAY
GIVE. I CHAIR THANK YOU
ATTORNEY GENERAL BUT THERE IT
IS PLEASE THE FOSTER FAMILY
BILL TWENTY TWO OF EIGHTY A
BILL THAT WOULD PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED OVER THANK THAT FUND
RAISING AYE PLATFORM. YEAH
PROTECT CAL DON'T. AND AT THAT
DEPARTMENT PLEADING CHARITABLE
TO LOOK. AT THE TIME MEMBER
WENT THERE ARE MANY NEW THREE
WHICH- CAN. CHARITY USING
WEBSITE YEAH LOCAL OKAY. AND
LEAVE LEFT AT TE DONATING.
THIRD AT CHURCH FUND RAISE
PLANT. THE CURRENT HELLO LAW
ADOPTED BUT THEY CAN A- YOU'RE
NOT THE TYPICALLY REACH SPEECH
BY RIGHT WILL PLAY OUT FOR. AND
THAT THINK THAT THING
CHARITABLE VISION ACT. IT'S
SIMPLY UPDATE. IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THE AG CONTINUE ABILITY
PROTECT THE PUBLIC. ARE UP
NEEDS TO BE A POSITION OVER
TEACHER FUND RATE PRACTICES BUT
A CURRENT INTERNET PLATFORM. TO
RESPOND NIMBLY TO NEW CONCERNS
WHERE EVERYTHING I'VE RACKED.
POINTED OUT IN THE HEALTH OKAY
AND BUT NOT THAT WE AN IN
ONLINE FUND RAISING. IN THE
CURRENT CO IN NINETEEN THE NO
DIFFERENCE. BUT THAT WE'VE BEEN
AGREE WITH THE COULD THAT NOW
THE RIGHT TIME TO UPDATE LAW
THAT. BASIC FOR WORK. AND ABLE
TO GENERAL BOB WITH ACTORS
PROPER STEEP. OVER THE FACT
GROW FULLER. TRAIN WE SHARE
THAT WOMEN'S COMMIT TO CONTINUE
TO RAP BUT THE COURT OF THE- MY
AGO. AND TO WORK AT ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO. A OKAY DOUBLE
FOR A GREAT. THANK ASSEMBLY
WOMAN WENT FOR LEADERSHIP ON
SOME. PARKING ISSUE CAL DONOR
AND CHARITABLE PREGNANT.
ATTORNEY GENERAL THE SHERIFF IS
PROUD BONTA AB TWENTY TWO OO
EIGHT I REAFFIRM TO COME TO
PROVIDE TRANSIT. GUARD THE
PUBLIC FRAUD READ THIS BACK TO
THE- AND ENSURE A LEVEL FIELD.
WE THAT BUT I AB TWO EIGHT. I
THINK YOU. THAT'S WHAT THIS
PLACE. BRIAN ARMSTRONG I AM A
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR
ATTORNEY GENERAL BECERRA IN HIS
CHARITABLE TRUST SECTION. WELL
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE ON THE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO TWO OH EIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THIRTY ONE
IN CHAMBERS WHO LACK TO
REGISTER SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
RIGHT SEE NINE IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO.
REGISTER SUPPORT FOR AT TWENTY
TWO OH EIGHT. SURE TO MAKE A
PAYMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE- GATHER THE INFORMATION
FOR THE FIRST HOW MUCH. NINE
ONE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NEWMONT REPRESENTING PAY PAL WE
HAVE A SUPPORT AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU OFFER FOR HER WORK ON
THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU. I DON'T
KNOW FOR THE COMMENTS AND KING
OKAY THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION. OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT. IN THE
CHAMBERS IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
TELEPHONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE B.
TWENTY TWO OO EIGHT. WE ARE
GETTING INFORMATION FROM ONE
LINE OF THE POEM. THIS IS TOM
ON YOUR LINE. LINE ONE FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR LINE AT THE
OPEN. CORY JOHNSON WOULD CAP
THAT WE ARE IN AN OPPOSING NOT
THE MAN DID TO THE CAN- A
NUMBER OF OUR CONCERNS ARE
OUTLINED IN OUR LETTER AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING THE
AUTHOR AND THE PROPONENTS OF
THE BILL I'M AT CONVERSATIONS
MOVED FORWARD. AND THAT LINE
THE IN OUT THE THING YOU. THANK
YOU. WITH ANYONE LIKE TO SPEAK
ON FORTY WILL HAVE. HELLO
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JEFFREY TALK ON BEHALF WITH GOV
BE. WE'RE NOT AT ALL TO THE
BILL WE DO HAVE BEEN ABOUT THE
LANGUAGES INTRODUCED THAT WE'VE
BEEN A PART OF THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE AUTHOR
TO RESOLVE THIS CONCERN. THANK
YOU FOR THANK. THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS YOU.
ALL RIGHT YOU OPERATOR YOU CAN
CLOSE THE- PHONE LINE THAT AB
TWENTY AWAY. BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTONS
COMMENTS. RIGHT SIGNAL ZERO IN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE ALL
THROUGH OTHER THE BILLS BUT-
YOU MAY CLOSE YEAH WE HAVE TO
BE PATIENT IN THESE TIMES SO.
NO I JUST IT WAS WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS THIS IS A
VERY TIME BILL-GIVEN. OF WHAT
WE ARE GOING THROUGH AND THE
EVOLUTION TO. ONLINE GIVING IT
IS REALLY IT IS REALLY TIME
THAT- THAT WE CHANGED. CHANGE
WITH THE TIMES SO WE ARE VERY
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIGHT. THANK YOU I'M LOOKING
FOR MUCH OF THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. YOU
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE. HI. YEAH RIGHT
NOW ALL RIGHT. YEAH YEAH. RIGHT
YEAH. ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT
BELONG CALL FOR OTHER MEMBERS
TO ADD ON THANK YOU. RIGHT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR AUTHORS SAN
DIEGO AND LIVE UP SANTIAGO.
HIDING THE OTHER DID NOT SEE
YOU SO THE TEXAS ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY
THREE. OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
OPEN THE LINES FOR AB TWENTY
NINE SEVENTY THREE. MAIN AS
CHAIR WELCOME. HIGHER LOOK
DIFFERENT IN A MASK. HI YOU'RE
JUST HIDING WHERE YOU HAPPEN TO
BE. SITTING FROM THIS LOWER
SCHOOL HAD SURE AND- I KNOW YOU
HAD A LONG DAY SO I'LL BE BRIEF
BUT TO THE POINT AND ONE THING-
ALONG THAT MISTER CHAIR- THIS
BILL WOULD ESTABLISH IMMIGRANT
AND REFUGEE AFFAIRS AGENTS- AND
OFFICES IMMIGRANT AND G.
AFFAIRS WITHIN THAT AGENCY.
HERE CALIFORNIA VOTERS BELIEVE
ALL YOU IMMIGRANT AND IT'S
IMPORTANT NOW MORE THAN EVER TO
INCLUDE TEAM TO ESTABLISH. THAT
OFF TO PROVIDE THIS IS THE WERE
ONE FOR OF THE POP. CALIFORNIA
WE NOW KNOW OTHERS BUT HE I
NEED TO VOTE AT THIS. AND WE'RE
FOR JURORS AN OP. IT WOULD
STEPS YOU OFFER LIKE IT'S ON
THE- GREEN SERVICES IN A AND
WAS. ALL STATES RESOURCES FOR
EMMA AND OFFER A SOURCES.
DISCORDANT LOCAL IMMIGRANT.
AFTER THIS STREAMLINED SIR
RECOMMEND PAUL BUDGET MAKING IT.
UP MEETING EMIGRATE AND REFUGEE.
AT IMMIGRATION. THERE WE ARE
ONE WITNESS THAT IS ON PHONE
AND HIS NAME IS CHRIS ST FROM
THE CO OF HUMANE IN RIGHTS I
THANK YOU MISTER. IF YOU MAKE A
WE DO A MOVE AND A SECOND.
RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER SANCHEZ.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR.
CHRISTOPHER SANTIAGO CHIRLA
CALL THIS FOR HUMANE AND THE
NUMBER. CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
AND TO GREAT. THANKS FOR IN.
THE STATE. BOB HERTZBERG BONTA
AB TWENTY SEVENTY ESPECIALLY
THEN THESE TERMS OF CRISIS WHEN
WE HAVE SEEN. GAPS IN THIS
TEMPLE STRUCTURE CHAOTIC. SIR
PAUL. NUMBER UNFORTUNATELY IN
THE CURRENT TIME IN THE LEASING
YEARS ON THE WILD USING THAT
THE COMMUNICATE TO THE OF BACK
WHEN WRITTEN TO OF INCLUDE OF
IN THE REGARD OF THEIR STAY AND
OFTENTIMES LACK OF COURT MAKE
AMONG GOVERNMENT. HOW TO BETTER
SERVE THE COMMUNITY DURING THE
TIME OF THE- I'M IT IS RUNNING
OUT OUR STATE NOT. THE SERVICE
CAN YOU ONE CAR. IMMIGRANT
REFUGEE IN AND BE KEEPER THREE
BOOK THE STATE TO ENSURE THAT
ALL ARE. TO PROPERLY SOURCES
JUST THE COUNTRY CHARTS
INSPIRED A- AN OFFICER
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE
INTEGRATION ONE SURE THAT THE-
OUR RECORD NEEDED AFTER. TO
REMOVE ENSURE THEIR ACTION
MEMBER. FROM FOR DURING THE
COURSE OF. CONNECTING AVAILABLE
FROM ANY LEGAL PERMANENT RUN TO
NOT IT SHOULD. IN A TO
SUPPORTING REGIONAL. THE I HAVE
THE PROPER TO SUPPORT YOU CAN.
IT IS FOR THE EVENING THAT WE
ASK ENERGY. THANK YOU. IS THE
ANYONE IN THE CHAMBERS WHO'D
LIKE TO SUPPORT THIS. THIS IS
AB TWO NINE SEVEN THREE. RIGHT
SING NOT THIRTY ONE THE PHONE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE CASE
SUPPORT FOR AB. TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY THREE. WHAT KIND OF
COMPANY LINE UP ONE HUNDRED AND
TWO THIS CALL AT. WHAT I CAN
POLISH NATIONALISTS THE OPPOSED.
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
KIND OF A LINE OF SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARCO GEORGE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
REMINDER LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE DIDN'T ZERO.
FOR NO ADDITIONAL COMMENT AT
THE TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION. THIS
IS IT TWENTY NINE SEVENTY THREE.
ANY OPPOSITION THE CHAMBERS
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY WHEN I
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO A BETWEEN AT
SEVENTY THREE ON THE PHONES.
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AT
THE TIME THERE ARE COMMON CAN
GIVE. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU OF
THREE TO THE COMMITTEE I THANK
YOU OPERATOR YOU CAN CLOSE THE
PHONE LINES AND AB TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY THREE. ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
RIGHT SIGNAL. SANTIAGO YOU MAY
CLOSE. I THINK MR MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK I THOUGHT.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOST A
SECOND THAT MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE. STONE BY STONE
I ORDER. THE NO CALORIE NOW.
CHAO YOU. IN THEMSELVES I
HOLDEN KALRA FOR AYE KILEY
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN. OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE NO RAY IS FINE REYES
I. AS FOR OKAY THE BILL HAS
FOUR VOTES WILL PUT IT ON CALL
THANK YOU MISTER. THANK YOU. MS
WEBER. OUR LAST TWO BILLS I
REMEMBER THIRTEEN AB. THREE
ZERO SEVEN ZERO. OPERATOR IF
YOU COULD OPEN THE PHONE LINES
FOR AB THREE ZERO SEVEN ZERO.
THIS IS. I KNOW SAY GOOD
MORNING. WELL THIS MORNING
SOMEWHERE BUT AFTER HERE GOOD
AFTERNOON. I TOLD ME THEY WERE
VERY. THAT WAS OBVIOUS YEAH.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS CAIR AND
MEMBERS TODAY I HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF VISITING AB THIRTY
SEVENTY. UNLAWFUL
DISCRIMINATION IN THE SELECTION
OF JURIES REGARDLESS OF
INTENTIONAL OR IMPLICIT BIAS BY
USING OBJECTIVE TESTS TO
DETERMINE WHETHER
DISCRIMINATION HAS OCCURRED.
AND WE'RE- TURNING UP SOUNDED
YOUR THE STATE THE FOR THE
CHALLENGES WHEN EVER JACKSON'S
MADE THAT THE CHALLENGES OF THE
TWO. THANK TWENTY SEVEN FOR THE
THAT'S IN WHICH WAS DO NOT
INTEND ACTS OF DISK BY LAW WHEN
THE EXCESS WAS. PREEMPTORY OF
THE POST TO ELIMINATE A
PROSPECTIVE JURORS THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT IS
ONLY OPEN TURN 2% THE JURY
SELECTION BIAS PIECES THAT IT
HIT YOU TWENTY YEARS. HOWEVER
PETER FAILED TO ACHIEVE IT. SO
FAR AS- AFRICAN A- RIGHT.
BACKROOM THREE CHALLENGE AS AT
A MUCH HIGHER RATE AS MUCH AS
TWO AND A HALF TIME THEN FIRST
JURORS OTHER REYES ARE LIMITED
QUOTA BUT NOT THAT IT CAN BE
DIFFICULT AND OFF IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THE TRIAL JUDGE DETERMINE
WHETHER THE LORD MAKE TALENT AT.
THIS GROUP. THE JUDGES WITH
SHOP BOTH THE TRY COURT. OFFER
REASONS GIVEN BY THE PARTY
MAKING STRIDES WILL ALMOST
ALWAYS SUFFICE EVEN IF THEY ARE
TRIVIAL ARBITRARY OR ATTIC SO
LONG AND NOT HAVE TO
DISCRIMINATE. BOB THERE IS
SACRAMENTO CA AB AMERICANS LIKE
TO ABOUT PEOPLE OF COLOR
CALIFORNIA CUT COURTS TEAM WE
PREVENT JUSTIFICATIONS THAT ARE
SUPPORT NEUTRAL CLEARLY WE
DISCRIMINATION SUCH AS WHETHER
THE JURY HAS HAD NEGATIVE X.
WITH POLICE LET TAKE ABLE WHO
WHERE IS OUR THIRD WAY PUBLIC
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT. HELLO
UNFAIRLY. REGARDLESS OF
INTENTION OR IN BY BY USING OF
TO THE TO WHETHER THE HAS HEARD
AND REQUIRING ATTORNEY
CHALLENGE A JUROR TO STATE THE
REASONS FOR THE CHECK EVER CHEN
ME. AB THIRTY SEVEN BE. THREE
ACTUALLY GIVEN AND NOT ALLOW
COURTS TO ON WHETHER THE ARE
UNDER I'M STATE REASONS FOR THE
CHECK. IN ADDITION TO BUILD
JUST ALLOW THE REASONS FOR THAT
WHEN WE USED TO JUST A SOLUTION
OF RACIAL AND ETHNIC GROUPS. IT
IS BEING USED ON THE WASHINGTON
SUPREME JENNA THIRTY SET. WHICH
WAS AFTER TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THIS
BILL IS ABOUT CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
WITH SEVERAL ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION ACLU AND SEVERAL
OTHERS. YOU'RE JUST HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. AND A
TECHNICAL AB THIRTY. IS WOODS
THE CHEAP BUT THE OF ALAMEDA.
AND ELIZABETH SO MY ALL WHO
REPRESENTED THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
AND PROFESSOR OF LAW AND
DIRECTOR OF THE UC BERKELEY
DEATH PENALTY. RIGHT YOU. WE
HAVE RENDON AND ELIZABETH SEMEL.
AND I'M TOLD CONFERENCE NEAR
MISSES. COULD GET PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
BRENDA THAT IF YOU CAN HEAR ME
OKAY YES. FIND OUT ON THE
COUNTY NOW BEEN LITIGATING FROM
WERE YEAR. I TRIED YOU RISK.
THANK YOU BYE PROBLEM UP WHILE
OVER HER PROP. I CAN BEGIN TO
TELL YOU HOW DIFFICULT IS YOU
MY OFFICE OUT COUNTY. THE%
SECOND LARGEST JAIL IN
CALIFORNIA IT HOLD FORGOTTEN
PEOPLE AS 40% BLACK. ACCOUNTING
PRINCIPLE ABOUT WE LOOK AT THE
HAVE A FAIR AND IMPARTIAL
JURORS. YOUR DIRECTION ACOSTA
COMMUNITY FOR YOUR OF YOUR
PEERS THE DURING THE DIVERSE. I
WANT TO CHECK WITH OUR DEAR. WE
DO NOT THINK THIS IN OUR
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM. I KNOW
MY POCKET. MY PROFESSIONAL
EXPERIENCE. SHOP ON HOLIDAY
OKAY WAS BLACK. WHICH IS TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS IN PRISON AND
WITHIN A SINGLE BLACK PERSON
WANTED YOUR- GOOD AFTERNOON
LAURIE MY OFFICE WHOSE HARD.
MOST REQUIRED NEW BLACK MAGIC
NUMBER ACT YOU'RE PART OF THE
CASES ON ONE HERE. OFFICE RIGHT
CASE WE'RE THEY WERE THAT NEXT
MANAGEMENT JURY POOL. THE
PROSECUTOR KICKED OFF THREE OUT
OF FOUR. AND THEN THAT THAT
YEAR BECAUSE BECAUSE IT SHOULD
BE. WHERE SOMEONE WITH ABOUT.
BUT HE KNEW SOMEONE WALKING
JUST THE COURT DOES OKAY. OKAY
COPTER THE PROSECUTOR KICKED
OFF ITS BLACK WOMEN IN A ROW
SIX IN A ROW AND THE COURTS
THAT THAT OKAY BUT THE CURRENT
LAW. IN A CRIMINAL TRIAL HE
STARTED GIVE US ARE NOT
CHALLENGES. THEY CAN USE OF
EXPOSURES. IF YOU THINK THAT
THE POPULOUS COUNTY BECAUSE THE
RACE. MUST FIND A SHOW THAT WAS
BASED ON SOME READ NOT
DISCRIMINATORY. TO GIVE THE
RACE NEUTRAL EXPLANATION IN
THAT CHALLENGES ALLOWED TO
COMPLETE THE- SOME RESULT IN
UTAH. DESTRUCTIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT I BELIEVE THAT WE
CAN GET YOU WERE SUPPORT BY. I
DON'T CLOSELY TOP WRESTLER
CONVICTED OF A CRIME. HAVING A
CHILD MARRIAGE RECEIVING STATE
BENEFITS NOT BEING A NATIVE
SPEAKER. DRESSED BUT HIRE A
PERSONAL TO THE YOUR- ALL WE
THAT ARE NOW OUT UNDER THE LAW.
THE THIRTY SEVEN POINT THAT
WOULD MAKE. REYES WHAT INCLUDED
FORTY BUDGET IT WOULD MAKE THEM
PRESUMPTIVELY INVALID. BLACK
BOX GOOD YOUR SERVICE BY
QUICKLY JUMPED AT A RATE THREE
POINT FIVE TIMES HIGHER NEW
JERSEY ANYWAY. THANK ABOUT THAT.
THE RATE WHAT COULD BE
INCARCERATED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND HARDWARE PROPERTIES IS ALSO
TO RAISE MOST LIKELY THE JURY.
LOOK AT OUR CHECK. SO I'M THE
FIRST BLACK PUBLIC DEFENDER
ABOUT ME TO COUNTY. NOT ONLY
BLACKS BUT DIFFERENT IN THE
STATE. IN THE EVENT THAT
HAPPENED LAST WEEK AND I
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY. TALK ABOUT DR GRANT
YOU'RE RIGHT ERIC GARNER
MICHAEL BROWN SEAN BE AT A
MARCH BOB WE- I CONSIDER MYSELF
TO SOMEONE ALREADY WHEN IT
COMES TO RACE. AND JUSTICE.
BLACK PEOPLE COUNTY POLICE
BETTER THAT. WE HAD TO WALK
FORCING COURSE AT A MUCH HIGHER
RATE ALMOST ANY OTHER RIGHT.
AND BECAUSE THAT. BECAUSE WE'RE
JUST WAS BLACK AMERICA. I'VE
BEEN OF YOU DO NOT LET OUT BE
USED WITH THAT. IN A CREEK PART
OF THE LEGAL SYSTEM. CHANGE
YOUR YOUR BILL TO PASS AB
THIRTY SEVENTY THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU AND THEN
ELIZABETH SEMEL AND I'LL ASK
THAT IF YOU'RE NOT SPEAKING IF
YOU COULD PLEASE PUT YOUR PHONE
ON MUTE WE WOULD APPRECIATE.
THIS I THINK YOU CAN HEAR ME
YES THANK YOU I THANK YOU SO
MUCH- MISTER CARE AND DOCTOR
WEBER COMMITTEE MEMBER- I AM
WITH THE FAMILY MEMBER APPLE T.
THE BERKELEY SCHOOL ALL RIGHT
DIRECT THE DEATH. CLINIC AND
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF U. K. THE
BILL'S SPONSOR I WANT THE STATE
PARTICULARLY FOLLOWING UP WITH
MR WILL THAT I SPENT MORE THAN
TWENTY YEARS OF MY LIFE. IN THE
COURT OF. CRIME YOUR CRIME. AT
LEAST TWENTY YEARS LOOKING VERY
AT THE ISSUE QUIRK TO
DISCRIMINATION IN VERY COOL THE
DEATH PENALTY BECAUSE BUT THAT
THE PART YEAR INVEST IN JUST.
ALLEN DID IN THE STATE YOU HAVE
ARE FINDING AND- OUR REPORT
CONFIRMS THAT FORTY YEARS AFTER
WHEELER AND THIRTY YEARS AFTER
BACK THEN. IT CRAFTED. IT IS
GREAT THAT YOU DESCRIBED RIGHT
BY PROSECUTORS AND ACTUALLY
AGAINST BLACK JURORS I WANT TO
TAKE YOU BACK TO NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX WHEN JUSTICE
THURGOOD MARSHALL WRITING AND
BACK THEN. IT THAT THE NEW
PROCEDURE WHICH- TWO OF THEM
BREAK BATES RIGHT. THE THREE.
AND HE WAS COOL ON ALL COUNTS.
JUSTICE MARSHALL PREDICTED IT
WOULD REALLY DIFFICULT
DEFENDANTS TO ESTABLISH A PRIME
KNOWING ABOUT THE FIRST STEP.
AT DOCTOR WEBER. AS TO WHAT IF
THE DEPEND CANNOT A PRIVATE
ISSUE SHOWING THE PROSECUTOR
IT'S NOT REQUIRED EIGHT ANY
REASON FOR STRIKING A JUROR.
THE RECORD OF THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT. JEFF MARSHALL.
THE COURT LAST EIGHT BACK THEN
EXCEPT ONE THIRTY FIVE YEARS
AGO AB THIRTY SEVENTY LIKE
WASHINGTON GENERAL RULE THIRTY
THIRTY SEVEN. ELIMINATE THE
FIRST STEP IF THE DEFENDANT
OBJECT UNDER THE STATUTE THE
PROSECUTOR MUST STATE THE
REASON SECOND JUSTICE MARSHALL
PREDICTED PROSECUTORS WOULD
EASILY COME UP WITH A NEUTRAL
EXPLANATION. THAT MATT. YOU
DOESN'T GIFT ATTORNEY TRAIN. OF
THE REASON FOR THE READ TO
WEBER AND MISTER WOULD DIFFER
FOR YOU TO THE THIRD LIKE THE
RESIDENCE THE JURY DECRY CALL
WITH A LOT OF. WHAT IT. NO THE
REASON HIGHLY WITH RACE AND
ETHNIC BECAUSE JUST FOR RE IN
TRACTOR FEATURE OF OUR FIFTY
AND AT HAD CORD HAVE REPEATEDLY
THANKS AND BE OF THE REASONS AT
RIGHT NEUTRAL EIGHTY THIRD
SEVENTY LIKE TO WATCH RULE I
READ THE DOOR COOLEY IF WITH A
NATION IT CLAIMS THE HIGHER
BURDEN ON THE- SHOW THAT STRIKE
IS NOT DISCRIMINATORY IF A
PRODUCT HELLO. WILL LIVE. THREE
I AM AT THAT GROUP IN THE- WHAT
A LOT I'M KIND RACISM THAT'D
THE BIAS TO ON. THE JUDGES
WOULD BE UNWILLING OR SECOND
PROP READ THEM BECAUSE OF THEIR
ONLY BY. BECAUSE THEY DID NOT
WANT TO THE PROSECUTOR A BIG
AGAIN TO TRY RECORD OF OUR
COURT CONFIRM DOCTOR MARSHALL
AND IN MORE THAN YEARS THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT HAD
FOUND BACK IN ERROR ONLY THREE
TIME AND IN THE LAST TWELVE
YEARS CALIFORNIA COURT. OR HAVE
WITH THAT ABOUT CASE. AB
SEVENTY LIE TO WASH ROLE DOES
NOT REQUIRE PROOF OF INTENT
JUST AND IF YOU COULD GIVE
JUDGE MORE ALL. AND STRIKE.
PLATE THING THE JUDGE IN THE
THIS POSITION OF AN OBJECT OF
WHO THE WAY OF THE ROLE THEY
PLAYED THE- TWO AND THE TEN BY.
IT PAST TIME TO PUT AN END TO
THE TO GET SUPPORT THINK OF
LARGE. CAL FITNESS IT AST TIME
TO ENSURE THAT OUR
REPRESENTATIVE OF A FAIR CROSS
SECTION OF CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES I URGE YOU TO PASS
ON EIGHTEEN THIRTY SEVENTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE IN HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. COME UP TO
THE MIKE. I'M NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY AT THIS POINT SO YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION. MY
NAME IS LEAH CALDWELL. THIS IS
A DAHLE SACRAMENTO. I'M NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY JUST YOUR
NAME AND THAT YOU SUPPORT THE
BILL. I DO SUPPORT THE BILL FOR
THE REASON. THAT BLACK
AMERICANS IN CALIFORNIA ARE THE
DESCENDANTS OF PERSONS IN SLATE
IN THE UNITED STATES AND IN
ORDER TO CLOSE THE RACIAL
WEALTH GROUND GAP WHICH IS HERE
IN TWENTY TWENTY REPARATIONS
MUST BE GRANTED WILLIAM DIRITTI
JUNIOR THANK YOU UNIVERSITY ARE
YOU TALKING ON THIS BILL OR YOU
TALKING ON TV. CONCERT
CONCERNING AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY
ONE WE'RE NOT I'M SORRY MA'AM
WE'RE WE'RE NOT ON THAT BILLION.
OKAY. THANK YOU THIS IS A. B.
THIRTY SEVENTY. YEAH I'M SORRY
I CAN'T TAKE ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
THE SUPPORT THE BILL NOR IS
CHRIS IS DOING HERE ALL DAY.
THANK YOU- NOR IS BECAUSE WITH
IT IT WAS LIKE ABOUT-AND WE'RE
HERE FOR THE NEXT BILL BUT-
DEFICIT PORTED TO OKAY THANK
YOU. WELL IN THE ROOM. KIM
MEMBERS WITH EIGHTY UNLESS
SACRAMENTO AND I ALSO SUPPORT
THIS BILL I'VE NEVER BEEN
SELECTED FOR A JURY MYSELF SO
YOU KNOW MAYBE SOMETHING IS
GOING ON THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE TWO WOULD
LIKE TO. GIVE YOUR NAME THE
AFFILIATION AND YOUR SUPPORT
FOR A BI THREE THREE ZERO SEVEN
ZERO. SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MARCO GEORGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND.
RIGHT THE END IS CONNECTED.
NINE ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TO YOU WANT. WHICH IS
BY YOU KNOW CLINTON THE COURT.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. BACK IN
SALAS NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
RIGHT ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE AHEAD. LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
NATASHA MINSKER ON BEHALF OF
THE EIGHTH AMENDMENT PROJECT
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
CHAPTER. ASIAN LAW CAUCUS
INITIATE JUSTICE IT PUT UP
FIFTY WITH A- HELLO BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS. ANTI
DEFAMATION LEAGUE ON STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THE TIME WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND I'M GONNA GO TO
OPPOSITION WHAT WALL WALL. WELL
HELLO THE ABSOLUTELY YES LARRY
BOARDS WITH THE CALIFORNIA JUST
THIRTY DISSOCIATION THANK YOU I
WAS JUST GOING TO OPPOSITION
AND NOTE THAT WE HAVE MISTER
MORRIS YOU'RE LISTED HERE IS IN
PERSON. ON THE PHONE SO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH THANK YOU OF
SOMEONE AND I APPRECIATE MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS WORRY MORE
SO ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
WELL WE CHER ASSEMBLY- WOMAN
WEBER AMENDMENT. DURING THE
JURY FILES ARE UNTAINTED BY
BIAS PREJUDICE. ANY WE ARE.
THIS BILL THE BILL WE CHANGES
TO THE JURY SELECT PROCESS YEAH
LITTLE MORETHAN BLOW STATE.
THREE LEGISLATIVE AND LINE AND
ANECDOTAL WITH OF PURVEY BY HE
BELIEVED ZERO IN YOUR SO WERE
ALL THE RESPECT MISTER WOULD
LIKE TO THE TRIAL PROSECUTOR
FOR TWENTY SEVEN YEARS- TRY
CASES IN SAID COUNTY VERY
DIVERSE COUNTY AND- WITH- THE
JURY'S BUT BROWN THREE
CHALLENGES. OF EVERY. RIGHT DEL
DEEPLY INTO THE MARION COULD UP
ALL OVER EXIST LIKE THAT BY
PREVENT AND DISK. CORRECTLY
CHALLENGES THIS IS STILL
INVALIDATE A NUMBER OF REASONS
THAT HAVE LONG BEEN ACCEPTED BY
STATE AND FEDERAL COURTS THE
JOB THE BY A CHILD WORK IT IS
WHAT'S THE STATE THAT THE COURT
NEED NOT APPLY FOR PEOPLE TO
FILL IN A. BOB YEAH LAW. ALL
THE MONSTER BRING THE BILL AS
THE CALIFORNIA'S REPORT JEEP
GIVE IN JANUARY AND NOW THAT
SHE STAFF WAS WORKING GROUP
COMPRISED ALL STATE IN THE
DOCTOR SYSTEM TO THE ISSUE FIRE.
SELECT SHOULD EXTEND TO THE
TEAM THE COURTESY PHOTO WORKING
GROUP'S FINDING. AND COOL FOR
FASTER FOR REACHING THE PROBLEM
THAT MAY NOT THE MOBILE WHAT
ADEQUATE BASEBALL BERKELEY AND
BY. WHAT THE CHIEF JUDGE AND
THE WORKING GROUP AND DR I A-
DETAIL STUDY THE BILL MA'AM AND
THEN AND ONLY. DID A LOT. YOUR.
I WOULD DURING THE BRING BUT
THERE'S IN THE- RESPECTIVELY TO
KNOW ABOUT. AB THIRTY SEVEN. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE- TO
GATHER INFORMATION FROM THE
WRITERS. COLORFUL COME FROM THE
LINE OF ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES WE
CAN. I'M SORRY I YEAH
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. MY NAME IS EDWARD LITTLE
ON THE HAPPEN CALIFORNIANS
EIGHT BE INGESTED. THE BORDER
VIDEO ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
THAT'S FIVE THANK YOU. WHERE IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE TH
COMPLAINING ON HER. THANK YOU
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON JERRY MEMBERS AND MY
NAME IS MICHELLE HOW MAY SHOCK
REPRESENTING ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY NEEDS YOUR
MILEY WHO IS ALSO THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT AND PDA. I'M HERE
ALSO IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL
AND WE ASK OF THE STATEMENT
FROM LARRY MORRISON PDA AND
THINK THIS BILL IS PREMATURE.
AND I DON'T THINK ANNOUNCEMENT
AND THAT SHE GOT. TOGETHER A
GROUP TO THEM ISSUE FURTHER
THANK YOU THANK YOU I AM NOT
ABLE THANK YOU NOT ABLE TO TAKE
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY POINT. IF
ANY WOULD LOOK LIKE TO WAY AND
GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
FILIATION AND THAT YOU OPPOSED
TO THE THAT'S- WILL TAKE ANY TO
TESTS. THANK YOU. OPERATORS
THERE WHETHER MORE ONLINE. LINE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN. ALL
OKAY- I'M ACTUALLY TRYING TO
GET THROUGH THE COURT THE BILL
MY NAME IS DAN WILLIAMS I'M
WITH A DOG CALIFORNIANS AND I
SUPPORT THE BILL. RIGHT THAT'S
FINE THANK YOU. LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES WE CAN. HI MY NAME
IS OSCAR BARBER ON THE
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDER ASSOCIATION OF THE
TRYING TO GET TO EARLIER I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
I JUST WANT TO SAY FOR FAR TOO
LONG. UNDER THE CURRENT PLAN TO
CARRY THE CROSS THE STATE THANK
YOU SIR THAT YOUR YOU'VE- SIR
OF WOULD START WITH CRIMES. SIR
I'M SORRY WE CAN'T TAKE IT
TESTS THIS POINT BUT WE WILL.
RECORD YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL THANK YOU. PRESIDENT OF
THE PUBLIC DEFENDER ASSOCIATION
STRONGLY COURT. PERFECT THANK
YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
REBEKAH YOUNG I AM THE MANAGING
ATTORNEY FOR COLLABORATIVE AND
SPECIALTY COURT. IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE AND A SEASONED TRIAL
ATTORNEY I AM STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT THIS BILL THE CORRECT
THE INEQUITIES APART THE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS LISA STANLEY I AM AN EIGHT
EIGHT YOUR ALLY AND I SUPPORT
THE BILL. WHEN ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH LET US REMEMBER WHAT THEY
FEEL YOU OF CALIFORNIA WHAT
ABOUT. WHEN ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NOT ME. YES. HI MY NAME IS VERY
SHOT BRIGGS I'M AN ELECTED
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC STATE CENTRAL
COMMITTEE ADD A MEMBER OF THE-
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AFRICAN AMERICAN POCKETS AND
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
UP THAT THEY ALL. IF YOU. YEAH
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX RELATED
TO OPEN.
THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENT CAN QUEUE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ARE YOU CAN CLOSE THE- PHONE
LINES FOR THIRTY SAID AB THIRTY
SEVENTY ALL RIGHT- BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE NOW
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. THIS CAR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
WANT TO THANK THE SUMMER WEBER-
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AS SO MANY YOU KNOW I WORKED AS
A THAT THE PUBLIC DEFENDER FOR
ELEVEN YEARS AND I APPRECIATE
THE PERSPECTIVE AND THOUGHTS%
FROM- THE OPPOSITION. ALTHOUGH
THEN APPRECIATE THIS THE
SHARING OF THE COMMITMENT TO
ROOT OUT RACIAL BIAS ALTHOUGH I
WILL SAY THAT SUGGESTING THAT-
THAT THE BROUGH INCLUSIONS OR
ANECDOTAL EXAMPLES OF BIAS I'M-
AS AS REFERRED TO- IN THE
SUMMARY OR THROUGH STATEMENTS
OR THE POSITION OF DOCTOR WEBER
I THINK- FLIES IN THE FACE OF
COUNTLESS STUDIES. THAT CLEARLY
DEMONSTRATE BIAS RADICAL JUST
SYSTEM AND SPECIFIC TO THE JURY
SELECTION PROCESS. I'M
CERTAINLY SEEN IT FIRST HAND IT
WAS ALMOST LIKE A BIGGER JOKE
TO HAVE TO DO ABOUT HER HEARING
COULD YOU KNEW YOU WOULD NOT
GET A GRANTED. AND THAT ON
APPEAL IT WOULD NOT BE A
GRANTED EVEN THOUGH- THEIR
EXPLICIT EXAMPLES OF BIAS IN
TERMS OF ROOTING OUT PEOPLE OF
COLOR. PRINTER. WE KNOW THE
BATON WE HERE TO PROCESS
DOESN'T WERE TO WITHOUT RACIAL.
IN THE JURY SELECTION AND
SUGGEST IT DOES PLEASANT FACE
THE FACTS OF WHAT WE SEE IN OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND
YOU KNOW WE MUST RECOGNIZE THAT
WHAT I LIKE ABOUT THIS-
DIRECTION IT THAT IT RECOGNIZES
IMPLICIT BIAS WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT WE I THINK I WAS
A BODY OF THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
HAVE FINALLY STARTED TO MOVE IN
THE DIRECTION ACROSS MANY
DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES. THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
PROBABLY ONE THAT HAS MORE.
IMPACTS FROM BIAS THAN PRETTY
MUCH ANY OTHER INDUSTRY I CAN
THINK OF IN OUR SOCIETY- AND IT
USES FACIALLY NEUTRAL REASONS-
THAT ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
ASSOCIATED. WITH PROTECTED
GROUPS. AND IT INTENTIONALLY
THAT PUTS THE BURDEN ON THE
PARTY EXERCISING. THE
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGE. THE
CURRENT PROCESS PASSED. A JUDGE
DETERMINED THE STATE OF MIND OF
A PROSECUTOR. BASED ON DEMEANOR
AND CREDIBILITY. NOW I CAN TELL
YOU BASED UPON BEING AN
IMPORTANT. OF FOR MANY YEARS
THAT. THE REAL LIFE APPLICATION
OF THAT IS ASKING THE
PROSECUTOR WERE ASKING THE
JUDGE. TO ESSENTIALLY TOLD
ROSECUTOR THAT APPEARS A FOR
THEM ALL THE TIME. THAT YOU'RE
USING RACIST OR BIGOTED
JUSTIFICATION AND YOUR- YOU
SOME. DOESN'T A REAL. TERMS OF
HOW COME TO HUMAN NATURE THAT
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE JUDGES ARE
LIKE THE COMFORTABLE DOING THAT
ON A ROUTINE BASIS. THAT'S WHAT
THIS. USING CHECK THE RESERVIST.
ACTUALLY ALL. A JUDGE OF TO
HAVE THE- NECESSARY TO USE
IMPLICIT BIAS THAT EXIST IN OUR
SOCIETY. TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
JUROR HAS AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
TO BE PART OF THE- WITHOUT.
CASTING CASTING ANY ASPERSIONS
ON A PROSECUTOR OR OTHER PARTY.
OR ATTORNEY THAT MAYBE USING A
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGE THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE BE DEEMED BIASED. AND
SO- I WOULD HEAR IT ALL THE
TIME IN TERMS A WORD SOMEONE
NEIGHBORHOOD THEY LIVED IN.
CERTAINLY EXPERIENCE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR HAVING RELATIVES
THAT HAVE BEEN ARRESTED OR
INCARCERATED OR DATUM CELLS
ARRESTED OR INCARCERATED OTHER
JUDGES BUT THE COME JUSTICE
SYSTEM. THAT WE WANT A JURY A
TRUE JURY OF ONE'S PEERS. TO BE
ABLE TO BE A AS A JURY INCOME
OF QUE WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE JURORS THAT ARE BEING
SEATED HAVE A CROSS SECTION OF.
THE AMERICAN EXPERIENCE AND SO
THAT IS WHY I THINK THAT THIS
BILL IS SO IMPORTANT IT IS AND
WOULD BE. A THE SHIFT BUT IT'S
A SHIFT OF BASED UPON. THE
SYSTEMIC RACISM THAT OUR
SOCIETY HAS HAD SINCE ITS
INCEPTION. SINCE THE CONCLUSION
OF SLAVERY WE'VE SEEN COME THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM HAS
CONTINUED THE RACIAL ANIMUS-
THAT HAS EXISTED THAT IS NOT A
FAULT YOU CAN'T POINT ONE
PROSECUTOR. OR IN THE DO YOU
SEE YOUR- ON THE BECAUSE OF THE-
BUT THE DA AND THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S THE JUDGES HAVE TO
BE THE SOLUTION. AND IN BEING
EXPLICIT AND MOVING OUT THIS
RACISM AND SO- THAT'S WHY I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
HOPE. THAT WE CAN. MOVE IT FOR
TODAY- BECAUSE I THINK IT.
SENDS A STRONG MESSAGE THAT
ACTUALLY DOES SOMETHING EXTRA
ABOUT ROOTING OUT RACISM
PROBLEM IN OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLD. BUT I
LIKE TO TAKE A DOCTOR WERE FROM
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AS
WELL- I CAN. ADD TO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE HAS JUST DESCRIBED IS
REALLY THE FUNDAMENTAL WHY THIS
BILL WORTH SUPPORTING I THINK
IT'S ALWAYS UNDERSTOOD IT IS
OUR EXPECTATION THAT WE WOULD
HAVE A DIVERSE- JURY POOL. THAT
IS REPRESENTATIVE OF OUR PEERS.
AND THIS BILL ESSENTIALLY IS AS
I UNDERSTAND IT. IS CALLING FOR
THE NEED TO GIVE A RATIONALE
BEHIND ONE PERSON IS BEING
DISMISSED AND I THINK THAT
THAT- SEEMS A VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD AND FAIR
APPROACH FOR THE RECORD TO
REFLECT. AND SO WITH THAT. OUR
PRESENTATION SOCIAL BRING BAD
BILLS SO- I'M SUPPORT OF YOUR
BILL AND LOOK FORWARD TO.
DEVOTING FORD ON THE FLOOR AS
WELL. THANK YOU FOR. I WOULD
LIKE TO BE CONSIDERED TO BE A
CALL. THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. YEAH SO. YEAH MY
UNDERSTANDING OF. YOU KNOW WHAT
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES ARE
TRYING TO GET IS ACTUALLY TO
GET AT. YES THAT MIGHT BE AN
INJURY. AND GIVE THE PARTIES
BOTH SIDES THE ABILITY TO PASS
FOR JURORS TO BE EXCUSED IF
THEY THINK THE- THERE'S GOING
TO BE BIAS IN THE DECISION SO.
ON THE VERY BEGIN OF WHERE WE
START I THINK THIS PROCESS IS
IN PLACE IN ORDER TO HELP
ENSURE A FAIR. AN UNBIASED JURY
SYSTEM. I DO GET THE CONCERN
THAT IS BEING BROUGHT WITH THIS
WITH THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
BUT WOULD WITH THE WITH THE
REVERSE BE TRUE. LET'S SAY THE-
DEFENSE WANTS TO DO A
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGE TO JUROR
THAT IS EXPRESSED THAT THEY ALL
THAT THEY TRUST LAW ENFORCEMENT
IMPLICITLY. AND THAT THEY'VE
NEVER HAD A BAD EXPERIENCE AND
ALWAYS FOLLOW THE LAW. MY TO
DEFEND IT SAY WELL THE
DEFENDANT. DEFENSE ATTORNEYS
SAY WELL HEY I'M I'M CONCERNED
THAT THIS PERSON. IS GOING TO
BE UNDULY BIASED AND SO I'M
GOING TO ISSUE A CHALLENGE.
UNDER THE CURRENT LAW WOULD
ALLOW THAT SO I MEAN IF WE'RE
GOING TO DO THAT IN THIS
INSTANCE TO WE ALSO PRECLUDE
THE ABILITY TO. THE PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES AND- IN THE REVERSE.
I WOULD IMAGINE THAT- AND I AND
HAVING BEEN. QUESTION FOR JURY
DUTY MANY MANY TIMES- CLEARLY-
IF YOU'RE ASKING WHAT THE NOT
THE PERSON IS GOING TO BE- BIAS
AGAINST THE FULL CASES ONE
THING AND THAT THAT MAY BE WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT VERSUS
SOMEONE ELEVEN CAN YOU BASED ON
YOUR THIS YOUR GENDER. OF
MAKING CERTAIN ASSUMPTIONS
BASED ON WHO YOU ARE YOU
NATIONAL DEPTHS IF AUTOMATE THE
OPPOSED TO NOT ASK ABOUT BUT
BASICALLY BECAUSE- THE DENTAL
FIVE THOSE CARE RISK. THAT PART
OF GENTLY OF THE EIGHT WITH
THAT IF YOU ASKING WHAT LIVE
DOES DOES THE BLACK THE TO LIVE
ON DETERMINE YOUR RELATIONSHIP
TO YOUR ATTITUDE TOWARD LAW
ENFORCEMENT. BUT YOU THAT
QUESTION- ASKING YOU HAVE YOU
HAD ANY RELATIVES EVER
ARRESTED- AND YOU'RE THE ONLY
ONE IN THE WHOLE JURY POOL
BEING ASKED THAT QUESTION I'VE
HAD THE CHANCE OF ME- AS IF TO
SAY YOU'RE- TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT. OF THAT WOULD. I'M
INTERESTED IN. IN IT SO THERE'S
BY THAT IN THE YEAR THAT ARE
BUILT INTO THE SYSTEM NOW WE
HAVE TO RECOGNIZE WHO BUILT THE
SYSTEM FIRST OF ALL. AND WHAT
THE SYSTEM IS TO. BEING OUT OF
THE- OF THAT THEY MAY HAVE A
HANSARD MAKES. AND THEREFORE
MAY NOT BE MAYBE OPEN MINDED
BUT IT NEVER RELEASED WHAT THEY
MEAN BY OPEN MINDED OBVIOUSLY
IS VERY CLOSE MINDED IN TERMS
OF THEIR PERCEPTION LAW. AND
THE KIND THINGS THAT THAT THE-
WHERE. A QUESTION OF OTHER
BARBIES CHALLENGES BASICALLY
BASED ON A PERSON'S RACE THEIR
ETHNICITY THEIR GENDER ALL
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
WOULD THEN PRECLUDE YEAH. NEVER
MIND BE ON THE JURY IT'S- AND-
ASKING A PERSON THAT QUESTION
MAYBE FOR AS YOU SAY PROBABLY
IS WHITE. IF THEY HAVE OF YOU
KNOW THE ATTITUDE TOWARDS US
THOSE PARTICULAR CASE BEEN
JURIES WHAT I'VE ASKED
EVERYBODY SAID BECAUSE IT IS ON.
ONE KNOW WHO AT ANY ANY KIND AT
ALL. AND THAT HAVE SOME
RELEVANCE BECAUSE OF A CASE THE
REALLY WELL ABOUT IN. IN AND
THEY ASK EVERYONE NOT JUST
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD BEEN-
WHO WORK BASICALLY OF COLOR OR
WOMEN WHO THEY THOUGHT MIGHT
HAVE BENEFITTED OR NOT. SENATE
FROM SOMEONE SHOULD. I THINK.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOUR **** THEM
THAT WOULD BE TO IN THE COURSE.
BUT WHAT WAS SIMPLY SO IS THAT
IF YOU'RE ASKING CHALLENGED AND
IF SOMEONE IS COUNTING BASED ON
RACE GENDER OR CLASS THEN YOU
HAVE TO EXPLAIN WHY YOU WHY
YOU. WHY YOU COULD ASK THE
QUESTION WHAT NOW YOU DON'T
HAVE TO BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT IT HAS TO
BE- INTENTIONAL VERSUS- UP. TO
A BASICALLY THE BOX IS THE
INTENDED BIAS. THAT'S. THE
QUESTIONS THAT. YEAH AND IT WAS
PERFORMED NUMBER BEEN THAT BASE
PREVENTS PEOPLE FROM SERVING ON
JURIES NOT DISTRICT ATTORNEY
HAS ALREADY ADMITTED THAT HE
BELIEVES THERE'S ON THAT THERE
ARE THERE IS UNCONSCIOUS BODY
AND WE'VE HAD THAT THAT WE'VE
HAD THE DEBATE. FOR MANY. ABOUT
ONE OF LOS AND LAW IS NOW SAYS
IS WE HAVE ONE INTENT BIAS
SIMPLY IT KNOWLEDGE IN YOU HAVE
IT IS NOT SO. IN ITSELF BECAUSE
THEN YOU HAVE TO ASK THE
QUESTION WHAT DO YOU DO ABOUT
IT BECAUSE OF THE IMPACT OF BUT
IN. A LOT JUST AS- AT THE STATE
AS HE AS AS INTO. BY IN TERMS
OF A PERSON LIFE. AND WOULD BE
HAPPY IN THE- THAT WE MAKE.
RIGHT SO I APPRECIATE. BUT
AGAIN I THINK WE'RE- WE ARE
MIXING THINGS UP A LITTLE BIT
AND THEN I MEAN IF IT WAS
INTENTIONAL AND SOMEONE WAS
TRYING TO GET SOMEONE OFF THE
JURY BECAUSE OF THEIR RACE
NATIONAL ORIGIN THAT SELF
ALREADY CONSTITUTE. SO THAT I
MEAN CURRENT LAW ALREADY DEALS
WITH THAT SITUATION. BUT I
THINK WHAT WE'RE GETTING AT IS
A IS THERE SOME SORT OF PRE TAX
IS THERE SOME SORT OF THING IS
BEING USED TO. COVER UP THAT.
WHAT WE'RE DOING IN THIS BILL
IS WERE SAYING HEY THESE
QUESTIONS THAT WE'VE OUTLINED
IN ONLY THESE QUESTIONS WILL
ASSUME THAT THOSE ARE PRETEXT.
AND I THINK THAT'S PROBLEMATIC
BECAUSE WE'RE SAYING FOR YOU IF
YOU HAD A NEGATIVE EXPERIENCE
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT
THAT'S PRETEXT. FOR RACE. I
DON'T KNOW THAT IT NECESSARILY
IS YEAH- ASKING IF YOUR FAMILY
MEMBER YOU KNOW WAS CONVICTED
OF A CRIME. YOU'LL BE THE
REVERSE IS TRUE THE DEFENSE IS
GOING TO ASK DO YOU HAVE A
FAMILY MEMBER LONG FORSMAN.
YEAH TE DEFENSE IS GOING TO
ASK YOU NO QUESTIONS ABOUT
THEIR CONNECTIONS TO. LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE LAWS WELL
AND IF THEY FEEL LIKE THERE'S-
SOMETHING THERE THEY'RE GOING
TO EXECUTE A PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGE IS THAT IS THAT
QUESTIONS BEING ASKED BASED ON
RACE GENDER. WELL I WOULD SAY
THAT ALL THESE QUESTIONS ON THE
OUTSIDE OR NOT BE YOU KNOW IN
THAT WAY OKAY RIGHT- BUT WE'RE
ONLY WITH YOUR LEGISLATION
WE'RE ONLY SAYING SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS THE ONES THAT ARE
OUTLINED IN YOUR BILL
AUTOMATICALLY SUSPECT DID NOT
AUTOMATICALLY SUSPECT ONLY IF
SOMEONE OBJECTS. TO THE
QUESTION THEN IT'S BECOME THEN
YOU HAVE TO JUSTIFY WHY YOU
HAVE Y. U. S. THAT QUESTION
RIGHT BUT YOU CAN ONLY OBJECT
ON THOSE QUESTIONS AND WE DON'T
ALLOW THAT FOR OTHER OTHERS AS
WELL I MEAN I THINK OF PERSON
MAKES AN OBJECTION BASED ON.
THE IT DISCRIMINATION ON THESE
PARTICULAR CHARACTERISTICS THEN
IT'S INCUMBENT UPON THE PERSON
MAY BE WHO. WHO'S BASICALLY
MAKING THE CHALLENGE TO JUSTIFY
WHY IT IS NOT DISCRIMINATORY
BASED ON THOSE OF RACE GENDER
OR OUR- OUR SEX. WHAT IS SAYING
THAT THEY HAVE TO BASED ON THAT
IT. THEY DON'T RATE ISSUE THAT
IS THAT IT'S NOT DISCRIMINATE
THEN WOULD NOT HAVE TO IT. NOW
WORK THAT'S BEEN IN WASHINGTON
SHOWS AS SOME WOULD SAY WITH
THIS TIME REPORTS FOR EVER- THE
WORK DONE IN WASHINGTON SHOWS
THAT THEY ACTUALLY HAVE FEWER.
CAKE IS BASICALLY BEING
CHALLENGED BECAUSE PEOPLE
BECAME CONSCIOUS. OF THE
QUESTION THEY WERE GOING TO ASK
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT DID NOT
REALIZE THAT THEY NEEDED TO
FILL TO THEMSELVES AND- TO
THEIR OWN BIASED. TO MAKE SURE
THEY WEREN'T ASK THESE KINDS OF
QUESTIONS THAT HAVE NO
RELEVANCE. TO THE CASE. OF SO
AS A RESULT OF IT ACTUALLY DID
NOT EXTEND TO BE ON THE BUT IT
PUTS CISCO A- MINDSET THAT'S
TOTALLY DIFFERENT. THAN SAY YOU
HAVE TO HAVE AN- BECAUSE- YOU
KNOW IT'S DIFFICULT TO PROVE
INTENT. OFF TIMES IT HAS SUCH A
BIG READ SAYING THAT YOU SEE.
OFTENTIMES WE O THINGS WITHOUT
NECESSARILY WITH WITHOUT
THINKING ABOUT DOING IT BECAUSE
OF THE- BIAS THAT THAT ONE
ALREADY. TOO AND THE SYSTEM IN
WHICH WE EXIST CAUSES US TO DO
THESE THINGS. WITHOUT ACTUALLY
THINKING ABOUT THE STUFF THAT
WE DO. IN THE END THE IMPACT IS
THE SAME. IT'S ALMOST LIKE
BEING IN A CLASSROOM WHERE
TEACHER TARGET CERTAIN KIDS WHO
SHE BELIEVES IS GOING TO BE OUT
OF CONTROL. YOU HAVE CERTAIN
THINGS AS A RESULT. PART OF. I
ASKED THE DOT TO THE- NET YOU
MAY NOT. BUT SHE HAS A BIAS IN
THESE YEAH MEN HER CLASS BUT
THE IMPACT IS THE BECAUSE
MISSING AND I DIDN'T BENEFIT IN
STOCK AND THEY'RE BEING OVERLY
OF CHRIS. COMPARE TO THEIR
PEERS WE SEEN THAT TIME AND
TIME IN SCHOOL IN CLASS SO THE
BUYER ISSUE THE UNINTENDED. IS
JUST AS DON'T AS INTENDED BY
AND THIS IN THIS BASICALLY
DEALS WITH WITH THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE. RIGHT AND I APPRECIATE
THAT I GUESS THE PROBLEM WITH.
WITH THE CURRENT BILL AS
WRITTEN IS. IT'S SORT OF
CALLING OUT ONLY CERTAIN
QUESTIONS AS BEING POTENTIALLY
SUBJECT TO OBJECTION. THERE ARE
OTHER QUESTIONS THAT CAN WE
GET. IN AND LOOK AT TENNIS HARD
TO PROVE I MEAN IT AND MANY.
YES EXACTLY WHY THIS BILL IS
BECAUSE INTENT IS HARD TO DO IN
MANY CASES YOU KNOW AND ARE IN
GOING THROUGHOUT OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. YOU EVEN TRYING
TO PROVE- YOU KNOW. CERTAIN
CRIMES YOU HAVE TO PROVE
INTENT. AND CERTAINLY THAT IS
IT'S DIFFICULT TO PROVE THAT
RIGHT AND SO I THINK THAT GOES
IN AND BUT AS WE'RE GOING INTO
THIS DISCUSSION WITHOUT HAVING
THIS- STUDY EVEN COME BACK YET
FOR INSTANCE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SUPREME COURT
AND JUST SORT OF ARBITRARILY
DETERMINE DETERMINING THESE ARE
THE QUESTIONS OF THE STAIRS
BACKED. I DON'T THERE'S A LOT
OF SUPPORT FOR THAT. THAT'S WHY
I CAN'T I CAN'T SUPPORT YOU
KNOW THE BILL AS IT'S
PRESENTED. TIME IS CERTAINLY
WANT TO ENSURE THAT OUR JURIES
ARE UNBIASED BUT I UP BUT AGAIN
ARGUE THAT'S PART OF WHY WE
HAVE PRINT THREE CHALLENGES. IS
SO THAT. IN BOTH SIDES ASKING
NO NOT UNLESS YOU'VE BEEN ASKED
A SPECIFIC QUESTION IN BOTH
SIDES ASKING QUESTIONS OF
JURORS. THEN THEY CAN MAKE A
CHALLENGE THAT JUROR IS SAYING
HEY I THINK THIS PERSON ISN'T
GOING TO BE- FAIR THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO BE UNBIASED IN MAKING
A DECISION AND THE JURY AND I.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE IS A GOOD
WAY OF DETERMINED THAT- SO. I'M
HESITANT TO MOVE FOR WITH THIS.
ALSO WITH WITHIN THE TIME FROM
THAT WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW AND WE
HAVE A STUDY COMING BACK TO
STUDY IN THIS VERY ISSUE- AND
ONE THING SIR WE DON'T HAVE AS-
OUR HEARINGS HAVE BEEN PUSHED
TOGETHER AND WE DON'T HAVE AS
MUCH TIME TO THAT AND GO
THROUGH THIS. I'M HESITANT TO
SOMETIME FOR LIKE A LET ME LET
ME SO THAT'S I MEAN THAT'S JUST
WHERE I'M SURE LET ME LET ME
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE OF THIS
WORKGROUP THAT. WE'VE HEARD
ABOUT- IN IDEA THAT WAS IN A
PRESS RELEASE THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT IN JANUARY. AT
THAT TIME CHIEF JUSTICE
PROMISED TO APPOINT ITS
MEMBERS- IN THE COMING WEEKS-
NEARLY FOUR MONTHS LATER.
INCLUDING A SUBSTANTIAL PERIOD
BEFORE THE SOAK SHELTON. ORDERS
THERE STILL NOT ONE MEMBER
SELECTED FOR THAT GROUP- OF
PEOPLE FOR THERE HAS BEEN NO
INDICATION WHAT AUTHORITY ANY
THE GROUP WOULD. GIVEN EVEN TO
RECOMMEND. CHANGES OF WHAT TIME
FRAME WOULD BE POLL WELL.
INSTEAD BE THE- NOT TO MENTION
WE GOT THE WORK. PERSONS WANTED
THERE'S NO TIME LINE THERE'S NO
DISCUSSION OF WHAT A FORTY MAY
HAVE BUT THIS IS ONE OF THE HER
MUSING I GUESS THE DISCUSSION
OF THE FACT THAT THE FLAWS THAT
EXIST IN THE SYSTEM ONE OF THE
FLAWS HAS TO DO WITH THIS WHOLE.
A JURY SELECT. YOU DON'T HAVE
SHE DOES NOT HAVE A COMMITTEE
FORMED YEAH TO TALK ABOUT THIS
AND- SO RATHER THAN JUST
SITTING AROUND WAITING WE HAVE
A RESPONSIBILITY TO RESPOND TO
THESE ISSUES THAT ARE IMPORTANT
AND TO RESPOND IN A WAY THAT
HOPEFULLY WILL MAKE A
DIFFERENCE FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA- SO IT IS SOMETHING
THAT IS IT EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
TO AFRICA CAN LEAD CITIZEN. A
WITH REGARDS JURY AND OF
DISSIPATION IN IN IN BEING
SELECTED FOR JURY THE WHOLE
IDEA OF HAVING EQUAL PROTECTION
AND SURELY HAVING ACCESS TO OF
JURIES THAT ARE OF THEIR PEERS
IT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THE
FACT THAT THE BASS PERSONS.
AMERICAN. YEAH HELLO BILLION
QUESTIONS. LIVE RESEARCHERS
THANK YOU ARE WANNA MAKE A
COUPLE COMMON FIRST OF ALL SHE%
YOU BRING FOR THIS AND TOP IN
BY WAY BACKGROUND WHEN I WAS IN
LAW SCHOOL I HAVE WORKED AS A
RESEARCH ASSISTANT FOR AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN LAW PROFESSOR
WHO WAS ONE OF THE COUNTRY'S
LEADING FROM DEFENSE ATTORNEYS
AT THE TIME IN THE MID NINETIES
WE LOOKED AT THE BATSON
DECISION WHEELER DECISION AS
MODELS WHAT WE DO TO PROTECT IN
THIS SITUATION SO YEARS LATER
ON SEE WE'RE HERE REVISITING
THIS WHICH I THINK IS
APPROPRIATE. MY NAME IS THE
BILL TODAY BUT I WANNA MAKE
CLEAR THAT I AM. HOPING THAT
WE'RE GONNA GET A LITTLE BIT
MORE GUIDANCE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT ON
THIS POTENTIALLY FROM THE STATE
OF WASHINGTON ON THIS AND I
WOULD ALSO LOVE. SEE A LOT OF
INFORMATION AND DATA AROUND
CALIFORNIA. AND IF YOU HAVE
THAT I WOULD LOVE TO LIST TO
SEE THAT- AS A FORMER FROM. A
COUPLE THINGS I WILL SAY. ONE I
CERTAINLY AGREE WITH THE IDEA
THAT BOTH SIDES WOULD- COULD
USE A COULD CHRISTMAS JEFF OUT
OF THE CAR STE- PROSECUTORS
COULD. ON THE FLIP SIDE I'M
CERTAINLY WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
TO MY GOOD FRIENDS WHO ARE
CRIMINAL DEFENSE ATTORNEYS.
SCENE PRINTER YOU JUST USED IN
EXACTLY THE WAY THAT WE WANT
BUT ON THE OPPOSITE SIDE AND I
THINK. THAT HAS AN IMPACT. THE
THING I WILL SAY THOUGH IS. IT
IS ALL ABOUT INTENT AND AS
SOMEONE WHO WAS ASKED THE
QUESTION OF JURY POOLS. HAS
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM HAD. OF
EXPERTISE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHEN IT COMES TO A PARTICULAR
SITUATION. I WOULD SUBMIT THAT
I DIDN'T HAVE A DISCO TEN IN
ASKING THE QUESTION. THE REASON
I WOULD ASK A QUESTION WOULD BE
TO UNDERSTAND WHETHER. JURORS
WOULD BE ABLE TO BE FAIR AND
IMPARTIAL. CONSIDERABLE ALL OF
THE FACTS IN MAKING DECISION
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT.AND
I I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT
HOW YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO ASK
THAT QUESTION IN A WAY. BECAUSE
OFTENTIMES INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY
HAVE HAD NEGATIVE EXPERIENCES
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT TEND TO BE
OF CERTAIN RACIAL OR ETHNIC
BACKGROUNDS AND THERE IS AN
ASSOCIATION BUT THAT IS NOT
ALWAYS THERE'S NOT A DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP HOW DO YOU TEACH
THOSE ISSUES MEANT THAT YOU CAN
STOP ESOS QUESTIONS BUT- UNDER.
PART OF WHAT YOU WERE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE HERE SO THIS IS REALLY
MORE COMMENTS- AS OPPOSED TO
ASK YOU A QUESTION BUT- BUT YOU
KNOW LOVE TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION I'M
CERTAINLY GOING TO WILL. BE
THINKING ABOUT THIS WITH BOTH
THE WE HAVE TURNED. I DO THINK
IT'S A DECISION THAT SHE
CONTINUED ON LOAN SUPPORT TODAY
BUT- HOPEFULLY WE HAVE NOT HAD
A CHANCE TO TALK MORE ABOUT
NEGLECT. WELL I THINK IT'S A
GOOD THING IS THAT YOU ASKED
EVERYONE THE SAME QUESTION. THE
FACT OF THE MATTER IS I WOULD
ASK THAT QUESTION TO EVERY
TEACHER. DOESN'T SAY YES AND
I'VE BEEN. I'VE BEEN THE ONLY
ONE ASKED THAT QUESTION.
MISSION AND MAYBE THAT WAS THE
CASE. IN YOUR COURTROOM BUT
THAT CERTAINLY IS NOT. I'M NOT
I DON'T THINK EVERY COURTROOMS
THE SAME. TO YOU. RECORD HAVING
A BIT. OF A INVOLVED IN THAT
BUT- BUT THERE ARE. THERE ARE
CASES. YOU DON'T. ASK QUESTIONS.
NOT YES I WOULD. JUST I WOULD.
PAY AND THE AND THE PROBLEM WE
HAVE ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO DO
WITH. WITH THE- KINDS OF.
THINGS THAT. THEY HAVE IN TERMS
OF THE- INTERACTION. JURIES
WERE THEY WERE DEALING BUSINESS
THINGS PEOPLE. JUMPING OFF THE
CLIFF WHATEVER THOSE THINGS
CALLED AND ASKED THAT QUESTION
YEAH. SO I THINK YOU KNOW I
THINK THE IDEA OF PUSHING
EVERYONE TO BE CONSISTENT IN
THE TYPES OF QUESTIONS THEIR
HOUSE AND NO ONE'S GETTING
SINGLED OUT I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT ONE. JUST I'M I'M
JUST NOT EXACTLY SURE HOW THIS
BILL WILL ADDRESS THAT
SITUATION BUT I'M WILLING YOU
KNOW I DO THINK THE
CONVERSATIONS IMPORTANT AND SHE
CAN. HANDLE FOR TWO TO THE
DISCUSSION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THE CALL QUESTIONS. RIGHT
WITH THAT MS WILL BE MAKE
CLOTHES YEAH I JUST SIMPLY WANT
TO THANK ALL OF THOSE WHO-
WILSON TESTIFIED AND THOSE MADE
COMMENTS CONCERNING AB THIRTY
SEVENTY- THIS IS ALWAYS A
DIFFICULT DISCUSSION BECAUSE OF
JUST LIKE THE BILL IT'S THE
DEALS WITH IN TECH IS KIND OF
DIFFICULT TO. WRAP YOUR HAND
AROUND AND UNDERSTAND WHAT
INTENT IS AND SOMETIMES ONLY
WAS MOST BLATANT FORM OF INTENT
DO WE ACTUALLY RECOGNIZE THAT
EXIST VERSUS THE FACT THAT IT
MAY HAVE OTHER LAYERS OF AND
THAT'S THERE AND SO- BUT IT'S
CLEAR THAT EVERYONE HAS
PROBABLY RECOGNIZES THAT
THERE'S CURRENT. THAT EXISTED
OBVIOUSLY UNFAIR AND- AND HAS
ME BIASES IN IT AND- ALLOW THE
TO. I HAVE ALWAYS ENJOYED POOL
THAT IS REFLECTIVE OF THIS. OF
CALIFORNIA AND REFLECTIVE OF
THE PERSON TO BE TRIED AND
THAT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT OF
GETTING TO THAT POINT IS NOT AN
EASY TASK TO DO WITH WHERE WE
COULD MAGICALLY MAKE IT HAPPEN.
AS ALL OF OUR BIASES THAT. THIS
COUNTRY WHETHER IT'S DEALING
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT WHAT IS HE
HELPED THE BIASES MEDICAL
APPLIANCES YOU NAME IT WE HAVE
IT BECAUSE IT'S BUILT INTO OUR
SYSTEM. ONLY WHEN WE BUDGET AND
BEGIN ROUTED OUT AND TRY TO
WORK TO A TWO TO. ELIMINATE WE
REALLY HAVE TO LOOK AT THAT
POINT- MY MIND TO REALLY TALK
ABOUT THE FACT THAT GETTING TO
CHANGE. I MEAN JUST SAYING THAT
AND WE KNOW OUR AND MOVE
FORWARD INTO. TO THE DAM THIS
THERE ARE QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
AB SO. THANK YOU FOR. AND WE DO
MOTION AND A SECOND THAT MOTION
IS TO PASS TO. CALL ROLL PLEASE.
STAND BY STONE I. GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO SHALL SO I TO BUY
TWO I GONZALEZ SALAS AYE HOLDEN
ALL RIGHT HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN. OVER OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE NO THREE IS ON YES I.
THAT'S OUT THE BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY
ONE OKAY AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY
ONE IS THE TASK FORCE TO STUDY
AND FELLOW REPARATION PROPOSALS
FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS. AB
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE WOULD
ESTABLISH A TASK FORCE WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THANKYOU A TASK FORCE TO STUDY
DEVELOP REPARATION PROPOSAL FOR
AFRICAN AMERICANS THE BILL
WOULD BE TASK FORCE CONSISTS
EIGHT APPOINTED MEMBER. THIS OF
A HISTORICAL RECORD OF BLACK
SLAVERY AND THEY'RE ALL. LIVE
IN CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES FURTHER THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE TASK FORCE TO
RECOMMEND AMONG OTHER THINGS
THE APPROPRIATE MECHANISM FOR
REDRESS AS IT PERTAINS TO
CALIFORNIA'S ROLE IN THESE
LEYVA BLACK PEOPLE AND THERE
AND THEY'RE AFTER LIVES. IT
ALSO REQUIRES THEM TO
DISSEMINATE THAT INFORMATION IN
AN EDUCATIONAL FORMAT SO
CALIFORNIA CAN UNDERSTAND ITS
RELATIONSHIP. I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF PROVIDING A
VERY THOROUGH ANALYSIS OF THE
BILL AND I HOPE SOMEBODY READ
IT BECAUSE IT GIVES A REALLY
GOOD HISTORICAL INFORMATION
WITH REGARD TO HOW LONG THIS IS
THE CONCEPT REPARATION HAS BEEN
AND MANY OF THE CHALLENGES AND
THE THINGS TAKING PLACE.
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA STATE
EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN EIGHT SLAVERY
IN EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE
CALIFORNIA WAS A FIFTY STATE IN
NAME ONLY MUNICIPAL AND STATE
AUTHORITIES ACTIVELY SUPPORTED
BLACKEST LET ME IN A VARIETY OF
WAYS. FOR EXAMPLE CALIFORNIA'S.
RIGHT SLAVE. SINCE THE BOND IT
SO LONG AS THEY HEAD INTO STATE
WITH AGAINST PROP PRIOR STATE
IN EIGHTEEN. CALIFORNIA
COURTROOM PROVIDED SANCTUARY TO
THOSE WHO DARE TO ESCAPE THE
BONDS OF SLAVERY IN CALIFORNIA
IN EIGHTEEN FIFTY TWO
CALIFORNIA DOCTOR THEIR HARSH
FUGITIVE SLAVE ACT EMPOWERING
STATE AND LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITIES TO FOR SELF AND
EMANCIPATED PERSONS LIVING
WITHIN THE STATE BACK INTO
CHAINS OF ENSLAVEMENT THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
ORDERED FUGITIVE SLAVES AS IN
THE HISTORICAL QUE TO PARTY
LEASE RETURN THERE IN SLAVERY
IN DIRECT VIOLATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S CONCEPT. TO THE
END OF THE U. THE- CALIFORNIA
CITY IN LAW. AUTHORITIES FORCED
A CONTRACT LABOR SYSTEM ALONG
SLAVEHOLDERS TO EFFECTIVELY
HOLES PERSONS AND BONDED TO
BITE AND ANOTHER NAME. IN OTHER
WORDS CALIFORNIA STATE COUNTY
AND CITY AUTHORITIES ACTIVELY
SUPPORTED THE INSTITUTION OF
BLACK SLAVERY BOTH WITHIN AND
BEYOND CALIFORNIA. THIS IS TRUE
IS NOT PART OF OUR STATE LARA
CALIFORNIA CURRICULA BUT OFFICE
CONCRETE EXAMPLES CALIFORNIA'S
COMPLICITY IN RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION. IN FACT THE
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES OF THE
PAST ECHOES IN THE EVERYDAY
LIVES OF TODAY'S BLACK
CALIFORNIA. ACCORDING TO
GOVERNMENT NEWSOME'S TWENTY
TWENTY STATE OF THE STATE
ADDRESS BLACK PEOPLE MAKE UP 8%
OF CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION
HOWEVER 43% OF THE HOMELESS
POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA OR
BLACK PEOPLE. ACCORDING TO THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN REPORT ABOUT
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA. AFRICAN AMERICAN
MALES ACCOUNT 420% OF THE
STATE'S MALE PRISON POPULATION
IS AFFECTED ME IN MAKE UP. FIVE
SIX AND OF THE STATE ADULT. A
RECENT STUDY CONDUCTED BY
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE IS THAT I
NEARLY EVERY STATE. LET K.
TWELVE DO HAVE A WAS
PERFORMANCE OF RACE ETHNIC
GROUP. EVEN AS WE DEBATE MS OF
THE DEBATE THE NEED FOR THE
STUDY. COLBERT NINETEEN SO
BRING LIGHT ON THE CULMINATION
OF THESE PERSISTENT DISPARITIES
EMERGING DATA CONFIRMS THAT A
DISPROPORTIONATE BURDEN OF
ILLNESS AND DEATH DUE TO CALL
BUT NINETEEN FALL ON THE BLACK
COMMUNITY. AND SOME THE AGE OF
ENSLAVEMENT BOTH IN CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THE NATION BIRTH A
LEGACY OF RACIAL HARM IN IT IN
IN EQUITY THAT CONTINUES TO ACT
THE CONDITIONS OF BLACK LIFE IN
CALIFORNIA. WHO SUFFER INJURIES
AND LOSSES THROUGH THE
MALICIOUS AND CULPABILITY
NEGLIGENT CONDUCT OF OTHERS
HAVE A RIGHT TO REDRESS. AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY ONE WOULD
REQUIRE AN IN DEPTH EXAMINATION
THE IMPACTS OF SLAVERY AND ITS
AFTER LIVES IN CALIFORNIA AND
PROVIDE THE FRAMEWORK TO
DEVELOP- BADLANDS ONE HOW TO
BEGIN TO ADDRESS THE
DISPARITIES BORN. OF A SHAMEFUL
HISTORY. AS OUTLINED THIS BILL
DOES NOT TAKE A POSITION ON THE
FORM THAT REPARATIONS WOULD
TAKE. WHAT DOES TAKE A CLEAR
POSITION REPETITIONS AS NOW
THERE TO ADDRESS THE PERSISTENT
EFFECT OF SLAVERY AND THE SIX.
INCLUDE JACK WELCH. RED THAT
THE BLADE. WELL CAPITAL IN
CARSON. OVER THE SINK THIS IS
THE MET AND SYSTEMIC THE
PATIENT. IN THE PAST RIGHTLY
ADDRESS EVEN READ ALMOST
PREPARATION. NATIVE AMERICANS
FOR THE DEAF TO THEIR LANDS
JAPANESE AMERICANS I'M JUST IN
TURN WITH. THE MARSHALL PLAN
AND SHOULD EUROPEAN JEWS
RECEIVE REPARATIONS FOR THE
HOLOCAUST. AND EVEN AT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS
WITH THE SIDE WILL HAPPEN
THIRTY THOUSAND LESS VICTIMS.
OF THE- YEAH IN THE- WE SEEM TO
WRECK AND JUSTICE FOR THAT WHO
HAVE BEEN UNDER NEED THE MAIN
TO MAKE HOLDEN TO MAKE UP FOR
THE LOSSES THEY EXPERIENCED TO
CATCH THEM BACK UP WITH THE
REST OF SOCIETY ALL OF THAT IS
IMPORTANT EXCEPT FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS THE ONE ATTEMPTED
REPARATIONS AFTER THE CIVIL WAR
THE PROMISE OF FORTY ACRES AND
A MULE WAS REVERSED LINCOLN'S
DEATH AND FORMER SLAVES ENDED
UP WORKING THE LAND OF THE
MISLABELING. WHILE REPARATIONS
SOME. LATE OWNERS FOR LOSS OF
SLEEP. AS MENTIONED CAL WAS IN
FACT AN IN LAW COMPLICIT IN
ENABLING SLAVERY WITHIN ITS
BOUNDARIES. THIS PANDEMIC IN
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON THE
BLACK CALIFORNIA'S IS ONLY THE
LATEST REMINDED BUT THIS IS
NEVER BEEN RECTIFIED AND THAT
OUR COMMUNITY CONTINUES. GRANTS
THE HARDSHIP OF THIS INJUSTICE.
WE HAVE WITH US TODAY TO
TESTIFY KELLY LYTLE HERNANDEZ
WHO'S THE DIRECTOR OF THE RALPH
J. BUNCHE CENTER. OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDIES AT UCLA AND
ISAAC BRIAN. ALSO THE BLOOD
CENTER AT UCLA. RIGHT SO THE
WITNESSES SAYS HERE VIDEO BUT
ASSUMING THERE ON THE TELEPHONE
OR ADAM HERE THE BUILDING OKAY
SO FIRST WITNESS PLEASE. THAT'S
CORRECT AND ARTICULATE AND IT'S
ALL BE HERE TODAY ON RUNNING. I
SHARED OF THE HEARING I'M AT
OPPORTUNE TO BE ABLE YOU ALL
DAY. FOR THIS CALL AND BILL
AUTHORED BY DOCTOR SHOULD WEBER
BECAUSE MY BODY INTO LEADS
BLACK. AGAIN MY NAME BY THE ON
THE DECADES USED BLACK POLICY
BY. ADDITIONAL FEATUES ROCK A
BUNCH OF RAPTORS THAT. HELLO
THERE DON'T KNOW THE ROB BY SEN
YOU SEE OTHER STAND CALIPH
PREMIER ONE OF OUR NAY MOST.
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS DATA TO THE
OF LAW LIFE. OVER FIFTY YEARS
ABOUT OF WORK IS TO CHANGE WITH
YOUR CONDITION THE LIGHT. BOB
LOSING RIGOROUS SCHOLARSHIP IN
ACTION TO BE. IS ONLY SHOULDERS
OF THE CONTENT HIS OF PRAGUE.
THAT I COME YOU TODAY URGING
THE COMMITTED TO A- ON A FOUR
CENTURIES OF STRUGGLE. VIOLENCE
IN A PRESS EXPIRY BY BLACK. IN
THAT CAR. ASSEMBLY THE ROLE
THAT I RELEASED THE PLAY. IN
EXACERBATING THOSE. WE HAD
ORIGINALLY WEBER STATE CAL
BECAME A STAY IN EIGHTEEN
FIFTY. AND IT'S LARGELY BACK.
INITIALLY BUT TODAY FREE STATE
HOW CALIFORNIA WITH ALL THAT
FREE FOR BLACK PEOPLE DO THIS
TIME THE LEGISLATOR DOESN'T
VOTERS HOLD PEOPLE IN. IF THEY
HAD ENTERED THE STATE WITH
THEIR PRIOR TO STATE THAT.
STATE DIFFERENT WAY CAL GET
FACT OF FLAYED OWNERS TO AN
SUBJECT BLACK BODY DESPITE. ITS
JOB DESIGNATION OF THE FREE
STATE. ADDITIONALLY CALIFORNIA
COURTROOM PROVIDED THANK YOU
VERY THE BILL TO GERD WHICH
GATE ANY DRASTIC SEEKING
FREEDOM. IN EIGHTEEN THIRTY TWO
CALIFORNIA ADOPTED A MORE
DRACONIAN FUGITIVE SLAVE. ACT
THIS LAW IN PALO LONG LADY DI
AND ALL JURISDICTIONS ACROSS
THE STATE TO FORCE. FARMERS IF
YOU CAN READ THE PATIENT BACK
INTO THEIR THE BY. FOR THE MORE
THE CALIFORNIA PLEASE AND YOU
CAN BUY BACK WITH. ARCHIE LEE
CASE FOR DUE TO DO TO THE
FORMER ALL. THIS RULING WITHIN
THE CON. TO GOT TO DO. AND ONE
OF THE MANY MANY. THAT COULD BE
TO BURKE ALTON OF FREE FALL.
THAT IS OFTEN DESCRIBED SHORT
EARLY IN THE STATE IT. TODAY
THE LEGACY SLAVERY AND ADAPT
LIVE ARE STILL. ACROSS MANY OF
OUR- TO SHOULD. DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR CALIBER. MORE MORE AND
HUMID. WITH HIGHER EDUCATION.
LINING THE ONLY DISRUPTING
DESTROYED THE ABILITY OF BLACK
FAMILIES TO ACCMULATE AND
PASSED DOWN WELL IN THE SAME
WAY OTHER RACIAL ETHNIC GROUPS
COULD THE IRANIAN ONES BEING
CONSIDERED AS PROPERTY AND THEN
BEING LEGALLY UNABLE TO OWN
PROPERTY YOUR NEIGHBORHOODS A
CALIFORNIA LISTED IN THE
SPECIALLY Q. STAND UP AND GET
THE GENERATION AFTER NON PAID
LABOR LOSS IN CALIFORNIA AND A
LIST. YOU CAN TALK TO THAT FOR
EVERY ONE AND WHAT THE FAMILY.
A TYPICAL WHITE FAMILY OF YOUR
TEN DAY. INCOME AND WEALTH
INEQUALITY APPROVED OF LATELY
AND IF THEY CODIFIES. COME
AGAIN WITH A BLACK POLITICS.
THE REPRESENT OF LOCAL THE- CAN
BE SEEN RIGHT OUTSIDE A OUR
STREETS. ALMOST 40% THE BODY TO
LIVE AFTER GET TO THE MARCH A
BLACK BOTTOM. IS NOT GOING TO.
IT IS NOT IN A- AND DOES NOT
HAVE TO. BE THIS WAY. THERE'S
NOBODY SO IF YOU CONOMIC
OUTCOMES ANY MEASURE THAT DOES
NOT. HAVE BLACK RESIDENTS WHO
CAL. UNDER RELATIVE TO THEIR
PEAK MR THE WHY PEERS. CAN
THERE IS NO NO SAYS YOU AND
OUTCOME THAT CAN BE MADE THE
DOES. HAVE BLACK LEATHER NOT.
OVER REPRESENTED. THE CURRENT
KOBE NINE AND MAKE AN JUST
RAISE BACK. ON IT'S CLEAR THE I
THINK THEY TO DO AT. I FEEL ANY
ASSERTION THAT THE CAN. THAT
THE DAY AND BEEN MAN OF. BY THE-
OF OUR HAPPEN CREDIBLY. AND I'M-
A LITTLE AGGRESSIVE STATE IF
YOU GET. CALIFORNIA HAVE THE
POWER. AND FOR TOM BEFORE.
ECONOMIC WEIGHT DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. WE OWE IT TO
OURSELVES TO OUR ADDRESSES INTO
OUR FUTURE STUDY. FOR BLACK
RIGHT INTO CAL. DEVELOPMENT
PAUL WHO FOR REDRESS FOR MEDI.
CAMPAIGN TO REDIRECTING. IN
TOWARDS THAT. WELL MAYBE FOR
OPTIONS. MY CATS WHAT IMPACT.
OUT AB THREE ONE TWO ONE
WITHOUT WHETHER THEY THIS BILL
A VERY FIRST STEP BETTER OUR
OUR OF HIGH AND CREATING A
PATHWAY FOR THE JOB EACH YEAR I
PLOPPED THE TRIP LEADERS OF DR
WEBER I NEED I JUST BLACK NOT
URGENT CALL ON LIBERAL THIS
COMMITTEE TO. ACT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THANK.
TYPICALLY THIS POINT WE WOULD
ASK FOR JUST WHETHER OR NOT YOU
SUPPORT THE BILL. OKAY MY
SITTING HERE FOR FIVE HOURS SO
I'LL GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT OF
LATITUDE. SO JUST LIKE TAKE A
MINUTE HE WOULD. MY NAME IS
LEAH CALDWELL I WITH EIGHT ALL
SACRAMENTO AND I SUPPORT. AB.
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE AND THE
UNATTACHED AMENDMENTS. IN
RESPECT FOR YOUR OFFERED TO
GIVE US A MINUTE TO SPEAK I
JUST WANTED TO REAFFIRM. THAT
SANDEEP DOCTOR SANDY DIRTY LOOK
OF DUKE UNIVERSITY HAS GIVEN AN
ACRONYM FOR THE IMPORTANCE OF
REPARATIONS AND THAT ACRONYM IS
ARC. IT STANDS FOR. KNOWLEDGE
MINT. REDRESS ENCLOSURE PLEASE
RESEARCH A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT DOCTOR. WILLIAM CHARITY
IT TO JENNIFER CITY AND- A DOS
ONE NO ONE DOT O. R. G. SO YOU
CAN UNDERSTAND HOWIMPORTANT
REPARATIONS ARE AND WHY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO AGAIN DO
I GET A MINUTE TO LOOK AT.
CHRIS WITH THEY DON'T
SACRAMENTO- RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE
SUPPORT OUR WORKERS WORK ON
THERE ARE SOME AMENDMENTS THAT
EIGHT OH SACRAMENTO HAS
CEMENTED DOES IS AND I. ARE
GOING TO SENATE'S OF SLAVERY
IT'S A LINEAGE OF US WERE IN
SLAVE BY THE U. S. HERE IN THE
U. S. SO WAS WE ARE THE PEOPLE
WHO TALK TO WEBER IT PART ARE
TALKING ABOUT WE ARE ALL
CHILDREN OF MOST. OUR HEROES.
IS LONG OVERDUE. FOR A. B. O.
THANK THANK YOU. HELLO JEFF
BARTLETT A LECTERN. HANG ON ON
THE PHONE JUST , UP
JUST AS- HI MY NAME IS KIM. I'M
HERE I STAND IN A LINE OF AB
THREE ONE TWO ONE- FOR THE SAME
REASONS THAT YOU KNOW DOCTOR
WEBER STAYS AND MY EIGHT THIS
CAN PARK THERE BUT I ALSO- HAVE
A STORYOF. A PERSONAL NATURE
NOW YOU SAY WE'VE GOT TIME. BUT
NO SERIOUS YEAH IF THEY'RE NOT
PLOY TO BE ESTABLISHED IF YOU
WILL. NOT GOING TO GIVE US A AT
AN OPPORTUNITY TO YOU KNOW MAKE
LIVABLE WAGES AND TO FLORES IN
THIS AMERICAN SOCIETY. I ONCE
BELIEVED IN THE AMERICAN DREAM
I'VE BEEN LOOKING FOR A JOB
THAT PAID A LITTLE WAYS FOR THE
LAST. SEVEN YEARS. THREE OF
THOSE IN WITH CITIES SACRAMENTO
I PAY ALL OF THEIR TASKS THERE
IS. YOU KNOW THAT THE ALL OF
THE ITEM. YOU KNOW. YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO GET AN IDEA SAID ON
THOSE LISTS AND I NEVER GET IT
ALL SO WHEN YOU CREATE AT. A.
COPY CAME TO TOWN IT WILL. THEY
WERE FOR CITY. HEY THERE I PUT
IN A FOR. THE ON COMMUNITY WITH
LOCAL AND ISSUE BECAUSE WE
NOTHING LIKE THAT EXIST ACT. SO
KNOW PROVIDE THEM WITH THE TO
PUT THIS WHOLE CITY OFFICE
TOGETHER WHICH THEY DID I
DIDN'T EVEN HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INTERVIEW FOR
THE POSITION AND OF COURSE TO
YOU KNOW WHITE LADY WHICH IS
PRETTY TYPICAL THE CITY
SACRAMENTO IS. AGAIN IF WE'RE
NOT THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMPETE
ON A COMPETITIVE ECONOMIC LEVEL
THEN WE NEED REPARATIONS ARE
IT'S GONNA BE EXIT THINKING FOR
THE BLACK RACE AT THIS POINT SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU. RIGHT NOW
WILL GO TO THE PHONES. IF YOU
JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR SUPPORT FOR
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE. HELLO
MEDICARE NUMBER KEPT THE MARKLE
ELECTRIC CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND ALSO THE DEFENDANT
OF PEOPLE COOLEY RIGHT OTHER
PEOPLE. AND THEY MIGRATED TO
CAL. IN SUPPORT. THANK. NINE
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT LET'S
REMEMBER WHAT THEY TELL YOU OF
CALIFORNIA CALLING. LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BACK IN COLLEGE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MARCO GEORGE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON JIM ONE BURKE ON
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA
INTO. ONE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS YEAH
WILLIAM I'M WITH A DOT BLOT BUT
NOT BAD TO LIVE I'M STANDING IN
THE TWO. AND OLD CAR. AND I
WORK AB. THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE BUT I WILL LIKE YOU
TO. RECOMMEND THAT WOULD
MANDATE BY EIGHT OUT CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE WITHOUT A YOU BUT- AND
THE JUST WENT TO THE LINE. THE
BILL. WELL NOT ALL GOAL
THEREFORE WE ARE THE COMMITTEE
TO WHAT THE RECOMMEND. MADE BY
A DOG SACRAMENTO AS THE MID BUT
THE RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE ONE HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT
THE GO AHEAD DAVID GOT A THE
FUN FOR NOW I'M NOT ANGELES AND
THE OPTICAL ABOUT. ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY FISCAL AHEAD. HELLO HELLO
WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY THE FIRST
FAMILY AB AT ALLY I SUPPORT THE
BILL WOULD BE I THE MAY MADE BY
A DEAL WITH CALIFORNIA EIGHT
THAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FOR
THE REMAINDER PRESS ZERO TWO OF
A COMMENT. THE COMMISSION
COMMENTED GIVING UP ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
TURN MEMBERS STILL BE AT THE
LEAST SHOP ON BEHALF OF THE
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AT THE
TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT CAN QUEUE. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO A. B. THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE. NONE OF THE ROOM.
JUST TO CONFIRM OPERATOR
THERE'S NO ONE ON THE- LINE
YOUR CUES. CORRECT AT THE TIME
THEY'RE NOT COMMENTING CUTE.
OKAY YOU THINK YOU ARE ALREADY
MAKE CLOSE THE PHONE LINES FOR
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. GREAT
SIGNAL TO EVERYBODY CLOAKS I
JUST SIMPLY WANT TO SAY THAT
THE AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE IS
THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY BILL
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS WELL IT FEELS VERY
STRONGLY THAT. AFTER ALL OF THE
CONVERSATIONS UP TO FOUR
HUNDRED YEARS ON THIS IN THIS.
IN THIS NATION THERE IS A NEED
FOR A SERIOUS DISCUSSION OF
REPARATIONS WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES IN SAN DIEGO LAST
YEAR IN PRESENTING THE
RESOLUTION TO PUT IT ON OUR
MINDS. BUT IT IS ABOUT TIME
THAT WE BEGAN TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION AND AS POINTED OUT
IN THE BILL IT DOES NOT SPECIFY
EXACTLY WHAT THE REMEDIES ARE
BUT THERE CAN BE MULTIPLE
REMEDIES FOR THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE- THAT IT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTAN THAT WE EXAMINED THE-
THE DEEP HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA'S OF. A RELATIONSHIP
WITH SLAVERY IT'S AN ACT COULD
BILLION SO HOPEFULLY ON THE
STATE AND ITS ONGOING GOING. OF
HAS BEEN. THE DISPLAY BETWEEN.
IN AMERICANS F IN THIS COUNTRY
SO I RESPECT ASK I WILL FOR AB
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE. RIGHT
YOU WE DO HAVE A OF THE SITE
THAT MOTION TO PASS TO PRO.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE HI
STONE I GO. GALLAGHER NO. CHAO
SHALL I TWO HI YOU AYE GONZALEZ
AND SALAS HI HOLDEN HI HOLDEN
AYE KALRA. KALRA AYE HIGHLY
HIGHLY NO MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE NO REYES HI RES I.
OUT THE BILL IS THAT THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU NOW WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK THROUGH OUR
AGENDA THERE ARE SIX BILL STILL
LONG CALL. YES IT'S A LOOKS
LIKE EVERYONE'S HERE LET'S JUST
GO THROUGH THE AGENDA IN ITS
ENTIRETY STRAIGHT THROUGH AND
PEOPLE CAN ADD ON WE GET TO
THAT ITEM. OUR FIRST. IS I
REMEMBER. AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY
SIX WEEKS IT IS ON CALL I'M
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GONZALEZ
DOLLARS I. HOLDEN FIVE HOLDEN I.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I RAY
IS YES I. THAT'S OUT OKAY THE
BILL IS THAT ITEM NUMBER TWO IS
AB THIRTY NINETY TWO WEEKS OF
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GONZALEZ
THEMSELVES AYE HOLDEN HI HOLDEN
I. MAIENSCHEIN HI MAIENSCHEIN I.
OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING.
SET UP OKAY YES I HAVE NEVER
THREE IS AB THIRTY TO SIXTY
WORKS CALL THE UPS A MEMBER.
HOLDEN. OR NOT VOTING.
MAIENSCHEIN ARE MAIENSCHEIN I.
BUT OUT WITH THE IDEA OF THE
BILLS ALREADY OUT ITEM NUMBER
FOUR IS ON CALL THAT IS AB.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE CARDIO
I'M GONNA LIFT THE CALL.
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER NO.
GONZALEZ. CORREO. HOW DOES NOT
VOTING. HOLDEN HI ALL THE NINE.
KALRA FLORA I. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I. THE TOP OKAY THE
BILL IS OUT OF NUMBER FIVE WAS
PULLED FROM THE TO AND I
REMEMBER SIX IS OUT THE WILL
CALL THE OF THE MEMBERS AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FIVE DALY.
TWO HI TO I. HOLDEN HI HOLDEN I.
KILEY PROBABLY I. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I. OKAY ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN IS ON CALL AB TWENTY TO
SEVENTY ONE GABRIEL MIDDLE IF
THE CALL. GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER
NOT PUTTING. TWO FIVE CHU I.
HOLDEN OUR HOLDEN I. KILEY
KILEY NO. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I. THAT IS OUT THE
BILL PASSES I DON'T NUMBER
EIGHT AB TWENTY FIVE ONE
SEVENTEEN HAS ALREADY PASSED
BUT CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
TWO HI CHU I. HOLDEN AYE HOLDEN
AYE. KILEYHI KELLY AYE.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I. OKAY
ITEM NUMBER NINE IS ON CALL
THAT'S AB TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT
OR ONE OF MY LIST TO CALL.
GALLAGHER VOTING. CHAO CHOW I.
TWO FIVE CHU I. HOLDEN HI
HOLDEN I. MAIENSCHEIN MENTION I.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NO. AND
THAT THAT IS OUT OKAY THE BILL
IS OUT ITEM NUMBER TEN IS
ALREADY OUT WHO. CALL THE
TWENTY THREE THIRTY TWO KALRA
GALLAGHER THE OLDER I. TWO FIVE
TWO FIVE. GONZALEZ THOSE AYE
HOLDEN. HI YEAH ALL THE NINE.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I. OKAY
A NUMBER ELEVEN WAS PULLED ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE. AB TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY THREE SANTIAGO IS ON
CALL IN THE LIST TO CALL. TWO
HI. I'M SORRY I SKIPPED A
SHOWER. SO I TWO I. HOLDEN FIVE
HOLDEN I. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I. LEVELS OUT
GRADES NUMBER THIRTEEN IS
ALREADY OUT BUT CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AB THREE THIRTY SEVENTY
WEBER. MAIENSCHEIN HI
MAIENSCHEIN I THINK WE HAVE
EVERYONE ON ITEM FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE. YES OKAY
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY STONE IS ON CALL
IT WOULD LIFT THE CALL.
GALLAGHER GALLAGHER NO. TWO HI
CHU I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I.
HOLDEN FIVE HOLDEN AYE.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NOT
VOTING. THE BILL SO THE VISIT
THANK YOU I REMEMBER SIXTEEN IS
ALREADY OUT WE'LL CALL THE UP
TO MEMBERS THE V. THIRTY TO
SIXTY TWO STONE. HOLDEN FIVE
FULL AND I. MAIENSCHEIN HI
MAIENSCHEIN I. OKAY IN THAT
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB THIRTY
TREE SIXTY TWO THAT'S THE
STATE BAR BILL TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE BILL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS HOLDEN FIVE HOLDEN I.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I. RATE
IN THE CONSENT AGENDA. CALL THE
UP TO MEMBERS THIS BILL THERE
ALREADY HAVE. HOLDEN FIVE
HOLDEN I.MAIENSCHEINI
MAIENSCHEIN HI. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
BELIEVE THAT CONCLUDES OUR
HEARING FOR TODAY SO WE ARE THE
GERMANS.